all right good morning
um it's 901 sorry we're a minute late
we're going to start the hearings of the
house uh Judiciary Committee and first
I'm going to recognize representative
Us in the Pledge of Allegiance
for which it stands
indivisible with liberty
thank you representative sir
all right um
so the first bill we have on for hearing
is HB 112 an act relative to tenants
rights to notification prior to the sale
of a multi-family home and I'm going to
recognize
do we have the spot representative rock
is representative uh
oh oh I'm okay I'm sorry enough
representative for you please come if
you come up
oh no I'm yeah I'm sure
representative Reed Rockingham 10.
sorry so for the record my name is Ellen
Reed and I represent Newmarket and new
fields which is Rockingham 10. thank you
Mr chair and thank you honorable members
of the committee for hearing me and in
advance for hearing me four times today
I apologize I will be before you all day
long uh you may get sick of me so I'm
just my apologies in advance
um because all four of these bills will
be pertaining to housing
um I'm going to for just this first one
talk about the housing crisis uh very
briefly
um and I won't repeat that through the
rest of this you know you'll already
understand and be familiar as you
probably already are with the fact that
we're in a housing crisis and I won't
have to repeat the reason and rationale
for for having these bills to begin with
but as you do know we are in and
increasingly so have been for many years
but increasingly in a severe housing
crisis especially in certain communities
like mine of the Seacoast region
um and we're really talking about two
crises at the same time because another
crisis that's been facing New Hampshire
in fact I would say the housing and the
uh the graying of New Hampshire have
been the two biggest crises of New
Hampshire for consistently for a number
of years everybody's smiling
for for a number of years and they're
actually very closely they're basically
the one in the same crisis we talk a lot
and I've been here for six years and
I've heard so many times legislators
talk about the gring of New Hampshire
and I've heard proposals such as well
maybe we should build a water park
as if 20 somethings and 30 somethings
would would be able to live here if we
had a water park it would it's just a
matter of Attraction it's not New
Hampshire is a wonderfully attractive
state to live in it's incredibly
desirable in every way except for the
fact that it's simply unlivable in many
places for many many people so
you deal with the housing crisis you
will automatically deal with the graying
of New Hampshire
and the reason it's called a crisis is
because it is in fact and especially now
an emergency and I mean an emergency in
the highest order of Maslow's hierarchy
of needs emergency we are pushing people
out of their homes many people are
becoming homeless it's been increasing
and I'm not talking about whatever
stigma of homeless people one might have
I'm talking about people working
full-time who have up to now had a roof
over their head but just cannot find a
place to live now
in the last couple weeks two people have
died of exposure in this state
people are not just being pushed out of
their homes but as I already mentioned
they're being pushed out of their
communities being pushed out of the
regions in which they work which
effectively means they're being pushed
out of their jobs and they are in fact
being pushed out of the state the state
that we want them to live in
much of this is being pushed by
predatory landlord practices I won't go
into that but uh because it's not
specifically relevant to this bill but
it doesn't have to be this way
um
in my particular Community rents have
gone up because of one particular
landlord buying up many of the
multi-family homes have gone up two and
a half to three times what they were
January 2022 one year ago these tenants
have experienced increases of over a
thousand dollars a month these are the
people who in my town three of them are
postal workers
several work in the local restaurants in
my town they make my food when I go out
to dinner
um and a lot of them are young
professionals working at tech companies
and a number of them are actually
retired
um retired people but especially retired
veterans they're two retired veterans
that were displaced uh one had just lost
a wife like the two days before finding
out his rent was going up or no it was
the other way he found out two days
before she she passed and the other one
is battling stage four cancer so these
are people
and so when we talk about the housing
crisis and I'll just wrap it up with
this when we talk about the housing
crisis we do talk about Workforce
housing we talk about the ability to
have people who actually work the jobs
that we keep complaining we don't have
people to work well if they can't live
in those areas you're not going to find
those people to work and we talk about
this in economic terms Workforce housing
how do we have the workers but it's
really a human crisis
it is for them not an economic theory
for them it is will I be living out of
my car next month for them it is
how will I take a shower before I go
into work what do I do with my dog while
I'm looking for housing do I have to
pull my kids out of school it is a real
problem a real visceral crisis that
should be taken seriously without smiles
so this particular bill
extends a current law that we've had in
place for quite some time that law says
that owners of multi excuse me owners of
manufactured housing Parks shall give 60
days notice to the tenants prior to
selling the property that they will give
the information to the tenants about
what would be an acceptable offer and
other such information and we'll
consider in good faith any offer that
the tenants bring to the landlord
whether an individual tenant or as a
group that law that's already been on
the books for quite some time has been
wildly successful because the incentive
that law when it was originally passed
was to allow tenants the opportunity to
be owners of their own Community
resident owned communities and since
that law has passed we now have 184
resident-owned communities in other
words co-ops these manufactured housing
Parks have gone Co-op and what you're
doing when you do that is you're doing
everything that we want in the community
you're making tenants into homeowners
when you have higher rates of home
ownership you have more stable
communities more stable workers more
stable consumers for your businesses in
that Community you have residents of the
community that are more long-term
invested in the well-being of the
community
everything pretty much every single
metric improves with increased
homeownership rates when you have half
of all your housing as rentals you have
people who don't know whether they're
going to be living in that town the
following year you have a lot of
instability a lot of changing of jobs a
lot of fluctuation in the people who are
living there and the businesses ability
to keep afloat
so everything improves everything in a
town improves when you have increased
rates of home ownership home ownership
right now especially is just not
achievable for many people individually
but if they come together we have proven
through these 184 resident owned
communities with the current law
in in manufactured housing parks that
they can and do successfully come
together buy their properties become
homeowners and become stable long-term
well-invested members of their community
the requirement to as I said it's it is
an already existing law that we are
simply expanding to multi-family housing
it's restricted property so it has to be
it's not like you know one person
selling their house with an Adu or two
it's actual multi-family housing
um
and that requirement as we've already
learned through the last since 1984 when
this law was um I believe when this law
was first put in place when the first
Co-op started the manufacture housing
Co-op uh it is not an onerous
requirement for the landlord to Simply
say I'm planning on selling here's what
I'm looking for for uh for an offer
that's not an onerous requirement
there's nothing in this and nothing in
the current law that says that they
there's a right of first refusal or they
have to accept it under certain terms
they simply have to entertain the offer
in good faith that's all that's required
so with that because it's been so
successful
um because we've had people across the
state in Alton by the way that 184
residential communities are in all 10
counties so it's not
um one specific area of the state it's
been successful everywhere
um with that I'll just go ahead and wrap
up and ask that you support and take any
questions that you have thank you very
much representative read questions for
representative Reed
yes representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
taking my question so I'm
I'm kind of torn on this because I I
hear that co-ops right the manufacturing
co-ops there's one in Goffstown for
instance on medville Co-op um there's
like over 100 units there right so like
if they
I'm confused because nowhere in here
does it say like you know if if there's
a cash offer say that say the landlord
was never intending on selling but
there's been a cash offer on it
um you know I think like I get texts
from Realtors all the time like God's
Town's a hotbed like everyone wants to
move there
um would you like to sell your your
townhouse or your you know and I might
have somebody living with me or whatever
but
um and there was no intention of selling
but then like right you'd ended up you
get offer right you get an offer and
you're it is a cash offer and you're
like all right you know let's do it I I
find it it's hard to get a cash offer on
like a huge hundred unit Co-op right
like there's some sort of financing or
whatever my question is like does this
kind of hurt like property rights when
you have like you know somebody that
might want to sell a three unit house
and gets a cash offer on it so this
doesn't apply to three units how many
units I believe the current definition
of restricted units is over for over
four so right but that's still I mean
four compared to like 100 150 that's
kind of my question is like how do we
how do we do that so this doesn't say
that a person couldn't accept a cash
offer that they weren't expecting all it
says is that they would have to allow 60
days which if you're familiar with the
buying process like closing takes a long
time anyway but they they would have to
allow 60 days before they closed on that
Mr representative
um well let me hear me you know um my
what I know about the co-ops uh
particularly the ones in Newmarket is
that
when tenants form the co-op they buy the
land and not the units on the land so
there's sort of a difference
um between you know selling individual
units and selling a lot of land because
the tenants actually uh lease the land
from the co-op ownership and that makes
a lot of sense with manufactured housing
but that's certainly not the only way to
do it in fact there's I got quite in
depth with Community Loan Fund which
does a lot of the lending and helping to
organize these communities into co-ops
into resident owned communities and
there's about seven or eight ways to
form a co-op there's like a trust
there's you can incorporate there's a
bunch of different ways to make those
agreements you can own your particular
unit kind of like a condo and then be
able to sell your part of the co-op or
you can sublease or there's restrictions
on what you may or maybe it all depends
on what that group of tenants wants to
do and there's at least three
organizations Community Loan Fund Chief
among them ready and willing to help
them help guide them in those processes
help them understand what their options
are and help them make those decisions
and that's why we have 180
184 I think
yes 184 successful Community or resident
owned communities
with so just the concept of co-ops has
been taking off across the entire
country there's been numerous articles
in the New York Times in Washington Post
and now in California about successful
Co-op communities those are multi-family
dwellings they are not
um they are not what we've been limited
to here which is manufacture housing
parks and the only reason we're limited
to them is not because there's anything
structurally about a co-op that
prohibits uh prohibits multi-family
housing it's only because the law only
applies to manufactured housing Parks
that's the only reason we've been
limited to that so just extending that
Whittle would really facilitate people
being able to buy their their Building
Together
other questions I represent Testament
oh
a question about the tenants
not necessarily good or bad
but are we talking tenants who work in
New Hampshire or tenants who work in
Massachusetts because I've asked this
question of some
Town managers and they say that
a great majority of the homes that are
or the apartments that are filled down
in Southern New Hampshire are
predominantly people who work in
Massachusetts what are we talking about
here so that's inherently because of the
geographic region you just mentioned if
you're close to the Border you will have
increasing percentages of people who
work across the border so you don't have
people in kowas county for example
working in Massachusetts so it has
nothing to do literally nothing to do
with whether they're in a co-op or
whether they're an apartment and has
everything to do with how close to the
Border they are so having said that like
I mentioned before
184 successful resident owned
communities already in manufactured
housing across all 10 counties across
the entire state so whether you're close
to a border and potentially maybe more
likely to be working in Massachusetts or
whether you are in the middle of the
state and definitely definitely working
in New Hampshire these communities have
taken off and have been successful
follow-up representative
that's fine
but you're still not answering the
question you know where are the majority
of
the people who don't work in in New
Hampshire living as far as these kinds
of homes
so I I don't see the the tie to homes I
see you're asking where the majority of
people who work across the border where
do they live and the answer will always
be near the border right that's just
whether they buy a home whether they
rent a single family house whether they
rent or buy a condo whether they rent an
apartment it has nothing to do with the
type of housing it has to do with how
close they are to work
pushing just to be one last question one
more follow-up
those are fine generalities
but do you have any numbers of
you know the people who live in uh
India Dairy for example people who live
in in co-ops do you have the numbers of
people who you're talking about here
talking about people in general is one
thing but talking about them
specifically do you have a real set of
numbers that would define what you're
saying so in terms of the already
existing resident owned communities I do
have the set of numbers for the number
of people in these resident owned
communities in each County if you're
talking about what already exists but
it's definitely across relatively evenly
by population across the entire State
there's no preference or no you know
there's no factor of oh well I I live I
work in Massachusetts so that's why I
want a resident owned Community there's
there's no tie there at all you may work
across the border and therefore live
near the border but it has nothing to do
with whether or not you want to start a
resident owned Community that's that's
across the entire state
other questions uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for uh coming before us
today and looking forward to seeing you
three more times after today uh
why are you just focusing on the
restricted properties the five plus
units and not looking at the smaller
properties when those may actually
present greater opportunities for home
ownership
and
and then as a as a follow-up I'll go
ahead and mention it if you need me to
restate it I will uh the term final
unconditional acceptance presents very
problematic uh because in all real
estate transactions there's no such
thing as final unconditional because
everything is based on whether the
financing goes through or acceptable
terms here inspections there all I mean
literally all the way up to the day of
closing there may be a reason why the
deal is not not finalized so at what
point in time is a a a final
unconditional acceptance until the lien
is actually or the deed is actually
turned over so that's you know it may
very well be problematic language but
that is the language that currently I
had the language duplicated from the
current existing law that's existed for
what I understand to be decades for
manufactured housing Parks so if it's
problematic it's already problematic in
our statute already having said that the
first question was why not smaller
because I was trying to make this as a
small and ask as possible but I'm very
happy to extend it to other properties
as well if you think if the committee
thinks that that would be in in the best
interest of tenants so I'm asking for a
little if you want to give me more I'm
happy for that as well
other questions
representative Perez
thank you for taking my question
you keep using the term Co-op do you
attribute co-ops to being
um
I live in a co-op I live in Londonderry
I live in a 128 home individual homes
the developer chose it to be a co-op as
opposed to a condominium which has been
great for us because it keeps our but
would this apply to our homes I mean our
homes are
you already you're already your Co-op so
you're you you are already owning right
I understand yeah but I just wondered if
when you talk about if someone's renting
in my area if this would impact them
because they already you know because we
are an existing Co-op so I mean our
homes turn over in two days right
um and they're mostly cash authors so
those are individual
individual homes right so so you're
using multi-family but then again you're
talking about manufactured homes so I
guess I'm confused about that oh that's
because I'm talking about manufactured
homes because this law exists already
and has for decades for manufactured
homes I'm simply extending that same
language in the current statute to
multi-family houses as well so as for
your question for your community you're
already Co-op this wouldn't in fact
affect anyone I I I'm I'm hesitating to
ask I'm holding in the urge to ask how
many of people in your Londonderry
Community work across the border
no it was it was a fair bit of snark and
I apologize but my point is my point is
that um it you're already Co-op this
doesn't affect you what this does is
allow people who are renting from a
landlord that owns a large multi-family
structure to have the opportunity if
they so want to form a co-op put in an
offer and have that offer fairly
considered that's it since you're
already Co-op that doesn't apply to you
those individual units selling all the
time it's that's one unit that's not a
multi-family housing structure other
questions for this week yes
representative
thank you Mr chair
um representative Reed thank you for
taking my questions I wanted to ask
whether you would be willing to supply
us or provide for us the RSA that
applies to manufactured housing I'm
happy to do that for you okay I may ask
Apollo yes of course um the other
question I wanted to ask is I was
confused and not understanding what the
60 days applies to is it the pns or is
it prior to closing could you just walk
through
in more detail how the 60 days works so
like it currently works for manufactured
housing it's before the final final
closing so as it was already stated
there could be any number of factors
that
upset or prevent something that was
planned on closing from closing at the
last minute this essentially would
become one of those factors which is
that if they had not notified the the
tenant 60 days prior they would have to
wait for that 60 days to lapse before
the final closing
yes follow-up thank you
so
the existing tenants would
only have
the when would the when would the
existing tenants have to put in a
counter offer or meet the offer how much
time would they have so there's no
specific restrictions on the offer the
only restriction is that the landlord in
good faith consider the offer so in
theory if the landlord in good faith if
the tenants put in an offer if you're
trying to get like an example of if the
tenant's been an offer the day of
closing then as long as the landlord had
considered the offer in good faith then
he could sign as long as they had the
notification 60 days prior so there's no
there's no time lapse from the offer
there's the time lapse from the
notification
right representative cutoff
so I'm a little bit confused so does
this mean that you want it to be
acceptable to take a multi-family singly
owned home and split it up so that it
could be owned by multiple different
owners is that what this is offering so
Co-op is one entity but it's it's an
entity kind of like a corporation that
has shareholders so all of those people
would own part of their home having said
that there's multiple ways to set up a
co-op but it's not going condo if that's
what you mean it's different from going
condo you have an actual entity that is
the owner of the the property the entire
property and the people that go into the
the the agreement for the co-op
um
they agree on democratically agree on a
set of bylaws to rule them in terms of
what's acceptable what's not what kind
of subletting when do you sell it for
what can you sell it for those types of
things are all agreed to but um like I
said there's trust there's a bunch of
different methods but it's not it's not
the same as going condo
thank you representative Tripp did you
have a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh
it seems that uh
this whole concept is predicated upon
say say you have a five unit
multi-family
dwelling
that uh
all five of the tenants agree to buy it
uh what would happen if say one tenant
doesn't want to buy it
so so are you you mean like four of the
five units the the residents of four the
five units so that those four people
would create a co-op
so it's being sold right like that's the
idea it's being sold anyway
so it's either being sold to another
landlord who will rent out to them
presumably for more money because that's
usually how that happens or the co-op
buys it you don't need to have all
residents agreeing to a co-op if that's
what you mean
so that Resident would essentially be
renting from the co-op the one that's
staying their new landlord is the co-op
instead
does that make more sense
instead of a different landlord buying
the the place and renting it out their
new landlord becomes the co-op
because that's who bought the property
right thank you very much other
questions for the yes representative
Turner
yeah yeah thanks and and thanks
representative Reed um quick question
um hopefully uh does this
state or or imply that
uh and maybe it builds on on what
representative Gleason was asking in
terms of a final offer can this
introduce a negotiation going back to
the original buyer or is it sort of the
idea that the original offer is fixed
and then then this gives the tenants the
right to
um makes a better offer I guess oh so
like there's nothing in it restricting
that normal back and forth that would
typically happen in a negotiation so no
this isn't enough of an offer and then
coming back with more that that process
yeah just just clarifying
would that would would the owner be able
to go back to the person who made the
original offer and say
you know the tenants are willing to buy
it for this can you know in other words
can can it initiate bidding on this
property with the original purchaser I I
see what you mean so by I didn't
understand what you meant originally by
original purchaser but in the example
that was given earlier about somebody
coming in and say Hey you know you're
not selling but I'm going to offer you
this amount of money is that what you're
saying
so that's the original purchaser is a
different a different landlord
I mean you have to present the purchase
and sale either final or or in some
status to the tenants
60 days ahead
um if the tenants make an offer can the
owner of the property who's going to be
selling it go back to that original can
there a negotiation or is the other one
like fixing the initial offer and and
and then the tenants can only build off
of that right so because this is model
left off yeah after current law
um it's only that initial offer that has
the stipulation of having to notify an
amount that the that the seller will
consider to be reasonable or that would
the seller would consider or sell at and
um and good faith consideration right so
that's the initial that just applies to
the initial offer because that's what's
already in the law I didn't want to
reinvent any Wheels here I wanted to
just duplicate what we have
other questions for this Witness
see I I do have a couple of questions
um
am I correct in understanding that the
the scenario you presented of the people
wanted uh tenants wanting to form a
co-op
nothing in existing law would prevent
that from happening is that correct that
is correct nothing does prevent that
except for the practice of the fact that
landlords don't have to notify their
tenants at all until it's done in fact
in our town representative De Lorenzo
and I share a town a 61 Dame Road
reached out to me recently because they
just found out that their building had
been finally closed like they didn't
know it was up for sale that it had been
closed on and that they had a new
landlord without ever knowing that that
process was in the making whatsoever in
fact the new landlord inspected the
entire property by claiming he was an
insurance adjuster so that they didn't
were completely unaware of the fact that
their building was for sale and that
somebody was going to be purchasing it
so because they have no right to that
information which of course impacts
their shelter and for something to
impact such a basic needed shelter you
should have the right to information
when that's going to impact you so
that's what's preventing it so it's not
law that's currently preventing it it's
the current practice the fact that
there's no notification yes my question
though is is it really realistic to
believe that if tenants have a desire
that they might want to purchase a
property that they wouldn't on their own
making and making an inquiry to a land
to the owner saying listen you know if
you ever decide to sell this property we
we might be interested in buying it so
we hope you'll you will consider it why
wouldn't that why wouldn't that happen
it's extremely realistic because we saw
that we didn't have these manufactured
housing Parks going Co-op until we've
guarantee that they had 60 days notice
and then all of a sudden they started
going Co-op and now we have 184
successful resident-owned communities
who turned from renter to homeowner like
every Community wants across the entire
State all 10 counties so with regard to
that that's a very good regard to that
isn't isn't there a fundamental
difference between the manufactured
housing situation and this in that in in
the manufactured housing situation the
very basis for that law was
most of the time I'm not saying always
but most of the time the person owns the
manufacture tenant quote unquote owns
the manufactured home and doesn't but
but leases the land and isn't it a lot
doesn't that put the manufacture the the
owner of the manufactured home in terms
of the the economics of the situation in
a much much weaker situation vis-a-vis
the land the park owner than a tenant
versus
a landlord in the in the
non-manufactured home situation so I
would say that the tenant in a
multi-family housing situation is far
more vulnerable far weaker because at
the very minimum a manufactured home
owner who owns the home but not the land
underneath it at least still owns
something they own something there is
nothing that the renter owns in this
scenario now the idea that it's
different terms of feasibility is
absolutely not true because we've seen
multi-family homes go Co-op across the
entire country very very successful and
especially recently it's taken off all
this does is allow an extra time frame
for them to be notified that it's
happening so they have the opportunity
to do that other questions for this
witness yes representative Horan
I think this is an excellent idea of one
practical question and maybe we don't
have any data on this but as a practice
but in order to buy a property you know
you need a large need to be able to like
raise a large amount of a large amount
of cash it's usually usually at the end
of the closing process the the
seller you know gets a check for the
full value of the property so how are
how are these tenants who have been
paying rent which is not that much less
or some cases more than the cost of the
monthly cost of
owning a property how often are they
going to be able to like put together
the
the the financing in order to uh in
order to uh you know buy the prop buy
the property
um in place of uh the whoever the
um
landlord would find to sell to which in
most cases would be another landlord so
like where are they going to get the uh
Capital to to uh buy this right it's
it's a great question I touched on it
briefly but it may have been before you
entered the room so you're right the
biggest barrier to home ownership
especially right now is income and
credit for most people to buy a single
family home
what going Co-op does and we see this
with all those successful manufactured
housing co-ops is allow them to pool
their resources together and we have no
fewer than three but I think it's
actually Four organizations but primary
chiefly among them Community Loan Fund
who is that's what they do is they loan
to groups of residents that have come
together to pool their credit their
income all of those things and you're
very right because even it's it's a very
sad state that we're living in I don't
mean the state of New Hampshire I mean
the State of Affairs
in that
um it is almost always almost always the
case that your mortgage is less than the
rent because there's a landlord
intermediary that's taking some money in
addition to the mortgage so because
that's always the case it's almost
always cheaper for a person to own and
while they're making rents payments
um they could easily afford Less in a
mortgage payment and yet they're being
denied the ability to buy homes this
allows people to overcome that kind of
unfair hurdle
other representative trip
thank you Mr chair
um
thank you for taking my question uh
you're already going to give us the RSA
number for uh the the tenant
housing could you also provide the uh
RSA that permits uh uh co-ops
so there's that it's the same RSA it's
it's just one thing there's nothing
there's nothing permitting anything it's
just simply saying that a landlord
selling needs to give 60 days notice to
the tenants and the rest is just them in
their own gumption coming together to to
create a co-op there's there's nothing
in law that specifically allows co-ops
other questions for this Witness
all right thank you very much thank you
so much
um so I know I'm noting the time and I
know that we have I think seven
Witnesses who have signed up to test
find us so I'm going to uh and I know
some have signed up in support some in
opposition so
um in the interest of time I'm going to
ask uh each of the follow of the
succeeding Witnesses here please uh do
your best to limit your testimony to
three minutes all right I'm gonna call
on Jane hey
of Manchester please
uh good morning my name is Jane Hague
and I live at 1573 Union Street in
Manchester and I appreciate the
opportunity to talk with you this
morning my husband and I are fortunate
enough to own our own home in
Manchester's North End which is of
course as we all know a very privileged
place to live
having a place to live brings that
inexpressible peace of mind that we have
the security that no one's going to kick
us out that the rent isn't going to be
raised although the taxes might be
um but seeing homeless people over the
on our streets really gives me a lot of
pain it just pains me in my heart and
we're not really talking about
homelessness specifically today however
with our housing crisis that
representative Reed referenced many more
people are in danger of losing their
homes to a variety of
you know they could be kicked out
because their lease is up because the
landlord raises the rent that they can't
afford or
they could be evicted because the
landlord says they're going to renovate
or they have a relative moving in and
with the less than one half of one
percent vacancy rate it could be very
difficult for a person that gets kicked
out of their house to find a place to
live but this of course causes a lot of
stress
um and our current system if you're not
owning your home you don't own a condo
and you're a renter
um we we have a situation that sets up a
kind of a contest between a landowner of
course the landlord has rights it's
their property but we also need to
recognize tenant rights
and to try to level the playing field a
little bit so the tenants have a little
bit more security
um
and as representative Reid said this
bill would enable tenants in a
multi-family property
to buy a property and set up a co-op to
own it and as she stated this benefits
communities with more people who have
made a commitment to live in that
community and participate in community
affairs
and I just want to say I'm part of a
group called Manchester housing Alliance
and we're trying to set up a land trust
that would enable this also by
being able to provide the financing for
the land kind of if you in relation to
the bill that she said that enables the
manufactured home communities the land
trust could own the land and then the
individual unit owners could together
own the building or have rights to their
own unit and that way the amount of
money that they would have to come up
with to pay for the building they would
own the building but not necessarily the
land
and that would make it more feasible and
we have been talking to the Community
Loan Fund and
other groups about enabling this so this
could be kind of we hope a way to show
that this is actually feasible all right
thank you very much questions for this
win
seeing none thank you very much ma'am
I'm going to next call uh on uh can I
ring
good morning good morning uh thank you
to all of the representatives here for
allowing me to speak today
um I have a lot on my mind regarding
this this is um
this is a very troubling bill you know
we have
property is one of the foundations of
our liberties and freedoms in this
country
and this bill
will restrict we'll actually recreate
a separate special class of citizens
instead of having free market
we're a landowner in turn and offer his
property up for sale to anyone including
the tenants
who have an opportunity to bid on the
property and negotiate in good faith as
well as any other prospective buyer
this limits the ability of a landowner
to actually sell his property
because once he's gone through the
arduous tedious task
of negotiating of first putting
the property on the market there are
expenses associated with that
and then finding someone and negotiating
and finding someone willing
to purchase the property at mutually
agreeable terms
then that agreement has to be put on
the Shelf
for a minimum of 60 days
until the tenants have an opportunity to
then get involved in the process
and then have an opportunity to
negotiate whether or not they want to
purchase the property and then that time
can be extended
if they need more time to acquire
financing
if the goal of this is to notify tenants
so that they have an opportunity to know
that the property is on the market
that I'm fine with that
notifying the tenants period and then
it's up to the tenants to then turn
around and negotiate with the landlord
as well as anybody else who's in the
market for buying real estate I want to
point something out I know that you're
short on time but this is very important
someone asked about um
which types of properties
this will affect it'll impact almost
every property in the state
if
so let me let me
explain that
it says no owner
of restricted property is defined in RSA
540 colon 1-A
Roman numeral two shall make a final
unconditional acceptance of any offer
but the CL will transfer of the property
without first giving 60 days notice
tweet's tenant that the owner intends to
sell the property and of the price terms
and conditions of an acceptable offer
so let's look at what
540 colon 1 dash a Roman numeral two
what that definition is
restricted property means all property
rented for residential purposes except
for the property listed in paragraph one
so let's look at paragraph one
non-restricted property means all real
property rented for non-residential
purposes and the following real property
rented for residential purposes
a single-family houses if the owner of
such a house does not own more than
three single-family houses at one time
people go out and they buy
you're you're kind of running over your
time I'm sorry Mr chairman this is very
important so so you're saying I I I I
want to just finish this please there's
a b rental units in an owner occupied
building containing a total of four
dwelling units or fewer owner occupied
and single-family houses acquired by
Banks or other mortgages so if it's not
owner occupied
and the owner doesn't have three and if
it's a single family house and they own
okay more than three then every real
estate property this impacts and that's
not acceptable all right thank you very
much Mr iring questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir I'd just like to
remind everyone that you swore an oath
to the Constitution nowhere in the
Constitution doesn't allow a Bill thank
you thank you Mr Ivory next I'm going to
call on uh
a Kearney oh boy
powery am I my good try thank you not
even close but good try uh Kearney
pokorny from uh Derek I'm sorry you're
good it's a hard name I understand
um I'm just here because as a young
person living in this state already it's
so hard to keep your head above water
and pay your rent and have enough to pay
for all of your expenses already and
when you're kind of just blindsided by
oh we sold the place and now your rent's
going up by a hundred dollars that's
just not doable when you're just maybe
for you guys up here like yeah 100 bucks
is as much as it's nothing but for for
people like me who are barely your
salary huh it's a year's salary for us I
know I know but still you know you got
here for a reason uh for for someone
like me it's that's out of my budget
that's that's unattainable and when
you're not given any notice of hey
you're going to need an extra hundred
dollars on your rent this month then
what are you supposed to do you didn't
budget that in you had no notice and now
you're getting evicted from your place
with I believe Jane mentioned uh zero
percent vacancy rate now you're trying
to find a new place and it's extremely
hard to keep young people in the state
and I think that we've proven that
because the young people are fleeing to
Massachusetts to Maine to states that
have more transparency in what's going
on in their lives when you can't even
trust how much you're going to be paying
for rent here then how are you supposed
to continue on and and and plan for
yourself it I feel like it's just
basically giving the respect and
transparency to those people that are
living in that home that hey we are
selling it and hey your rent may come up
or hey you may have the opportunity to
buy this yourself and I feel like for
many people that that isn't really the
problem here it's just the transparency
of knowing that that hundred dollar
increase or that 50 increase is coming
so that they can plan and be responsible
for themselves and coming up with that
and maybe cutting their Netflix or
cutting whatever they need to to be able
to still afford it and stay in that
place but without the transparency of
knowing you're not giving them any room
to succeed so I just wanted to come in
and encourage you to support this all
right thank you questions for this
Witness
yes representative Perez
thank you for taking my question
so would you be comfortable with a bill
that said that all renters before a
owner sold had to give the renters 60
days notice that they were going to do
this
yeah absolutely I mean I definitely
encourage what the last speaker had said
it's not something that I know enough of
to be able to really speak on but I do
agree that there should be options for
rental renters to buy that property as
well but I know for a renter like me
it's more that transparency of knowing
what's coming in advance
I thank you uh representative Manos did
you have a question
all right any other questions for this
witness thank you very much sir thank
you
David Klein
my name is David Klein I'm a small
landlord I have 40 units in the Seacoast
area I'm not a lobbyist I'm speaking for
myself I'm going to try and avoid some
of the areas that have already been
touched upon
um but one of the things to note with
renters is one third of them move out of
an apartment every year they don't have
the foundation at in the or the interest
in the apartment building as do mobile
homes
mobile home owners
and that the point I think that the
chairman made is that the mobile home
owners have put down their life savings
or a good chunk of their net worth to
own these mobile homes they've been
paying for them over the years have
mortgages it is actually financially
devastating if they have to move those
mobile homes
apartment owners do not apartment
renters do not have that type of
um
interest in the building and second of
all we have renters that have all sorts
of different debt and financial
situations and Acumen for instance I
have a building where it's four units it
is restricted because it's not owned or
occupied and as the other person talked
about in 1A that you can single-family
homes can even be restricted if you own
more than three
um this one tenant is on disability
110 is section eight out of four units
how are these two people going to be
able to join in and get participate in a
mortgage to purchase this property where
the units are selling from 150 to 200
000 per so it's an 800 000 unit and I
don't see how they're going to do that
what I'm I'm not against the idea of
having co-ops or something like this to
buy for the tenants to buy out what I do
dislike is the structure of the bill
more than anything else if you look at
205a which I believe is the section the
statute that you were asking about for
mobile homes which this one is modeled
after there's language in there about
New Hampshire housing being involved
working with the tenants right up front
there's none of that in this particular
Bill and keep in mind with apartment
buildings there's all sorts of issues
that we don't have with mobile homes
because you have all of the heating
systems roofs common area maintenance
snow plowing things of that nature so
that in my opinion when these tenants if
they're going to take it over they need
a structure in place for the management
of these of the buildings and contrast
that to Condominiums where when a
developer puts it together he has to
form the Condominium Association get the
board of directors going have those
bylaws in place
so for this to happen and close within
the 60 days or 90 days or whatever the
time frame is that has to be in place
and if nothing else a bank won't lend
you the money if that isn't in place to
buy it
so what I'm suggesting is that this bill
has good Merit but not the bill itself
it needs more work I think a suggestion
I don't know if this would work is that
yes maybe notification or have New
Hampshire housing reach out to landlords
and let them know if you're going to
sell notify us first have them be the
buyer and set up the Condominium
Association and then sell back to the
tenants
and the only other final point is that
it says reasonable time to close on the
financing that's a very ambiguous term
if we have an offer is six months eight
months you know if it's a hundred unit
apartment complex you're talking 20
million dollars that takes a lot of time
to put together financing how long are
we supposed to wait as sellers in order
to close and that's a problem with this
bill that I have also all right thank
you very much for letting me speak thank
you very much sir are there questions
for this witness representative greeson
thank you Mr thank you sir for answering
our questions does current law permit a
new owner to increase the rents in the
middle of a lease no
leases leases carry over to the uh the
new owner as long as seven years or less
unless they're recorded
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
um next I'm going to call on Jessica
margason and you know I should say I'm
just just to everyone here whether
you've testified already or not uh you
um if there's other things that you want
to tell us you can submit your testimony
online I mean there's a there's a way to
do that so please feel free to do that
uh Ms Marcus
thank you
good morning
my name is Jessica marterson
I'm here representing myself but I am
also with Granite State organizing
project and I volunteer my time there
um and I do attendant clinic and I also
have Granite State tenants Association
and through this I have a lot of
um clients that I get to meet and a lot
of different experiences with Bill hb112
I have met many tenants along the way in
different areas that would have
um loved to have this opportunity I have
one tenant in Salem who actually is one
of the Westgate tenants
the 12 buildings is much too large for
him to buy but he is in a position to be
able to go and purchase a home instead
of going through the cycle of having a
landlord anymore
if he was in one of these homes it would
be perfect for him but what I wanted to
mention is those who normally live in
naturally occurring affordable housing
tend to live there seven plus years I
have met many many families that have
lived in these houses one of them 24
years Rachel Gagney of Manchester her
and her husband actually renovated their
building before the landlord sold it and
then she got renovation evicted
um insult to injury there but
she would have given the opportunity
looked into purchasing that house their
family had lived there groaned there it
was a home to them so these families do
live there and I'd like to point out it
doesn't stop
um I understand it may take a little bit
more time to give them that 60 days
notice but the building's still for sale
they're still getting their buildings
sold it's just giving a family an
opportunity that's already set down
roots to be able to maintain those roots
and carry on
um
thank you I feel that I'll be speaking
enough I won't take up too much of your
time no thank you well thank you very
much ma'am is there any questions for
this Witness
thank you thank you
um Nick Nick Harmon Norman Norm Nick
Norman sorry Nick Norman thank you very
much should I do the testimony that I'll
pass out
okay
Mr Norman thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak I will try to be
brief it's hard to do that on some of
these bills well we're going to try to
keep it just I understand thank you
um so I represent or I should say I'm an
advocate for landlords
I'm the government Affairs chair for the
apartment association of New Hampshire
and put out legislative updates to
somewhere in the neighborhood of 3 400
different recipients of property owners
landlords across the state of New
Hampshire
members of many associations of
landlords so in a landlord myself for 35
years so I'm very familiar with the
landlording
world
I want to make sure that you realize
that this is really not talking about 60
days so it's talking more like four
months
so you get 60 days notice but then you
get time reasonable time for financing
that's very vague as David Klein had
mentioned
I was certainly restrict an owner's
ability to negotiate a sales price
if you the Market's fast you know what
buyer wants to
wait uh four months for their purchased
as a condition of the purchase and then
not know if
you know there's just too much
ambiguousness with that time frame of
obtaining financing and so forth
uh
is it really realistic to think that
tenants of a large multi-family who in
the first place are often lower income
and don't have resources of their own or
savings are going to be able to come up
with down payments
and everything that it needs needs to
happen to to purchase the property
if they're going to
buy it as a group
then one of the choices might be make it
Condominiums
make it a trust make it an LLC
there's no time
uh
you know this this is a difficult
involved process you know are the
tenant's really ready for that
and
it takes a lot to be a landlord
an awful lot so is a group of tenants in
a 10 unit or a hundred unit really ready
to be a landlord and manage deal with
financing
um everything that it takes to get the
property
up and running and keep it running
this doesn't restrict to smaller
properties you could have a 600 unit
complex a subject to this so you're
saying we have to give six notices to
600 different residents
um I'm not sure that tenants in general
are
have really thought out and ready to to
handle everything it takes to be a
landlord
what about a sale of portfolio
properties
there are investors that come in and
they buy a investor May own five six
seven ten different property and say I'm
selling my whole portfolio someone comes
in to buy that portfolio they take an
offer
that they've agreed upon
and how are they kind of going to
compete with that finish up if you would
please
just many problems it restricts the
the rights of the property owner to a
fair a quick
uh sale it just restricts too many
options all right of the property owner
thank you very much so questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you
um Brendan Lemay
hey my name is Brandon Lemay I am from
Manchester New Hampshire I'm speaking in
support of house bill 112. and I myself
am a tenant I am a tenant organizer with
rights in democracy uh so I want to be
really short today because we have a lot
of bills to hear and a lot of speakers
um but I hope to provide some
perspective of tenants here
um we've heard a few of the previous
speakers talk about what landlords or
sorry what tenants want to do but I
think it's kind of interesting that we
haven't really heard you know
perspectives that have been tenant
focused and I'm going to give you some
of that
so some of the tenants that we work with
in our housing work group we have about
60 to 70 members so far and it's a
common occurrence for folks to say I
don't even know that my building was on
the market and then 30 days later I got
a rent increase
I think that this bill would help out a
lot of middle to lower income tenants
who are just trying to budget their way
through their lives and if you don't
even know that your building is on the
market how can you prepare how can you
budget how can you actually plan and
make sure that you can keep living in
your home
so I think that this is also it's a win
for landlords and for tenants landlords
get justly compensated for their private
property and then tenants get to have
control over their own housing
and it turns tenants into indirect
taxpayers into direct taxpayers it's
going to give tenants again the
opportunity tenants can say no I don't
want to be a homeowner and that's
perfectly valid we're only giving them
the option here
and in my opinion if this law is passed
it would encourage landlords to work
with their tenants when they intend to
sell their building
if you're thinking hey I'm thinking
about selling this property maybe as a
landlord I would want to then work with
them to confirm if they even want to
become owners of this building
so and maybe they'll find out that the
tenants don't want to and this is not an
issue at all so I think that this is
just a it's the right thing to do at the
very least tenants should be aware that
their property the building that they're
living in and their biggest line item
expense which is housing could possibly
be affected they should be informed so
that's it and open up to questions all
right thank you sir questions for this
Witness
yes representative Manos
thank you thank you for taking my
question is it your understanding that
under this post statute a an owner could
negotiate with the existing tenants and
then move on and accept another offer
absolutely in this case the landlord
might just find the tenants have no
interest and then there's absolutely no
delay whatsoever so again yeah it would
turn this into selling the building out
from under the tenants without any
knowledge to then at least being able to
figure out ahead of time before they're
even going to put it on the market does
that answer your question
thank you representative
uh yes representative
yeah just uh along those same lines is
is it your sort of uh testimony that it
would be maybe more effective to
include the the time of the listing as
the time of the notice as opposed to
just once a purchase and sale has been
arranged to sort of move that process
Upstream so that the tenants are
directly
part of the the
um cycle of of bids on the property is
is that sort of what am I pulling that
out of what you're what you what you had
said or am I overreaching uh no thank
you for that question representative if
I understand the question uh correct I
actually would agree with that
um and yeah just making sure the tenants
are involved maybe further up the
process and making this easier on
everybody is that kind of what you're
asking there I thank you representative
other questions for this Witness
all right thank you very much sir I
appreciate thank you for coming in
is there anyone else who who hasn't
testified who desires to testify on HB
112.
I'm seeing no one I'll close the hearing
on HP 112 and I'm going to ask the vice
chair representative
oh oh that's right yes I'm sorry that's
right
um sure let's take a minute three minute
recess yeah we'll take a three minute
recess and then we'll
great thank you
foreign
we will now open a hearing for House
Bill 117 and we recognize representative
Lynn thank you Mr chair
um members of the committee uh my name
is Bob Lynn I'm the representative from
Windham and I should note at the outset
that I am not a rental property owner I
had I did actually own some rental
property in Concord probably 35 years
ago or so but uh I am not a rental
property owner
um I guess I should say in the interest
of full disclosure I think I I believe
that I do have a an interest in a
nationally owned you know uh Reit uh
Real Estate Investment Trust that runs
run by Vanguard but you know I have some
tiny little percentage of the total
ownership of that
um so I have no particular interest in
in rental property one way or the other
the intent of this bill is to overrule a
case that came to my attention when I
was on the New Hampshire Supreme Court
it was decided long long before I got
there but when I when I first heard
about it saw it it really kind of
startled me because it basically says
that if you own if you're a landlord and
I should say it's reply it applies only
to restricted property so you've heard
the definition of restricted property if
you if you're a if it's a single family
home and you own more than three
single-family home or homes or if it's a
a rental uh if it's a multi-family uh
unit I believe it's over four so it
doesn't apply to you know your
particular house uh if you just rent out
your your house and that's the only
house or you only own two or whatever
um but for so I would say it applies to
somewhat larger
um uh landlords but basically what the
what the law what this case says is that
under the law as it now stands if you
are a landlord and you rent your
property to a tenant under a a year's
lease
the lease is not really for a year it is
potentially in perpetuity because you
cannot at the end of the lease you
cannot say as the landlord I'm
terminating this lease
um which uh when I first read that case
I just found it startling that that
would be the law because people have
entered into a contract that says uh you
have a lease for one year yet you can't
end the lease because the lease is up uh
to me that doesn't make
um a lot of sense
um and it's based on the the an
interpretation of the landlord tenant
statute RSA 540 that says that the mere
fact that the lease is up
and the contract is ended is not good
cause for ending the tenancy
um I have to say I just don't understand
the reasoning behind that and I have to
say that in that case there was a
concurring opinion uh by Justice Netto
and I as uh Joe jonetto who I I was a
person I knew for many many years a
wonderful judge a Democrat uh it's
hardly some you know sort of right-wing
uh judge who said this uh he concurred
in the in the Court's decision because
there was some there was a procedural
issue that that did not allow him to
vote to over to uh to dissent but he
basically said this the majority's
decision just doesn't make any sense
um I I want to just take a couple of
seconds to talk about the Practical
implications of of the law as it now
stands I I think it really reduces the
availability of housing to Marginal
tenants because think about think about
this
the landlord says to himself if he says
to himself now or the landlord let me
put it this way the landlord landlord
should be able to say to himself if
there's someone who the landlord maybe
has some reservation is this person
going to be a good tenant or not a good
tenant that kind of thing
the landlord
should be able to say well okay I'll
take a chance on this tenant because
I've only this is only a year's lease
and at the end of the year after China
turns out to be that you know my my
worst fears are realized then I can just
end the lease but under existing law the
landlord can't do that the landlord has
to has to say I could have this tenant
here for a long time so the landlord may
very well decide you know when it if
it's a close call the landlord May well
decide to say no I'm not taking a chance
on this tenant and I think it seems to
me that you know if that kind of
thinking is repeated uh uh on a number
of occasions that that that impacts in a
negative way the availability of of
housing to everyone
um it should be the law that that Elise
means what it says and let me emphasize
here I'm not talking about in any way
um you know discrimination on the basis
of race or sex or any other protected
class that obviously is unlawful and it
would remain unlawful
um under under
um this bill as it is now
um I did put in uh at the request at the
suggestion of uh representative I'm
sorry of attorney Elliot Perry who I
don't know if he's here today or not and
I don't mean to suggest that he supports
the bill I I know he doesn't agree with
with the bill but he did have a
suggestion which I thought was made
sense to limit the bill to uh uh to
circumstances where the where the lease
term is is more than six months or if
it's less than six months that the lease
term has actually that the the lease is
exact actually existed for six months so
if it's a month to month lease but it's
actually uh Gone on for six months and
my reasoning there was I think there is
a valid point that if you have a very
short-term lease of less than six months
it probably is the is the expectation of
both sides that this lease is not going
to end is not going to end at the end of
a month even if it's even if it if it is
if it is a month-to-month rent most
people do not enter into those kind of
agreements expecting that they're going
to leave in a month so I that that's why
the the six-month limitation was uh was
put in there there
I
there is a uh under the law as under the
law as it exists now which would not be
changed by this if you're you're
um going to
um
uh Institute eviction proceedings
on the basis of uh for a reason other
than non-payment of rent which which
this would be this this would be the
lease term has ended the law requires a
30-day notice uh in order to in order to
terminate the uh the lease and and evict
the tenant now there's been some
suggestion
um that that perhaps that that
provision that that notice provision
should be longer maybe 60 days
um I I guess I I guess I would say I um
I want to think about that a little bit
but but that might make sense I'm not
I'm certainly not you know uh adamantly
opposed to that I'm not quite sure why
you know 30 days isn't enough but if
there were some particular reason and
and again I I get I guess I would
emphasize here remember we're talking
about
ending the lease at the end of the term
so when the landlord and tenant
originally entered into the lease
obviously the tenant knows it's a
one-year lease
um but I can you know I can see that
that
despite that if the landlord is intent
on on not renewing the lease the
landlike and understand the idea of
requiring the landlord to give some
notice
um I would tend to say the 30-day notice
the existing law would uh would provide
for it is is okay but I'm you know if if
the committee thinks that it should be
something longer than that I'm certainly
open to uh open to considering that
um
I think that's really about all I have
to say and I know we're busy and I'm
happy to answer any questions
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
um when this decision came down
um do you have any idea what the uh rate
of available rental housing was as
compared with what it is today
I I'm sorry represent I I really don't
my my suspicion is that that it the the
availability of rental housing was
greater than than it is now that's my
that's my suspicion because I know we
you know we have a we have a serious uh
problem right now in terms of the
availability of Housing and I I and you
know two this decision was handed down
in 2005
um my suspicion is that the situation
was less
uh was not as as dire as it is now could
I follow up with one quick one so then
can you uh understand how difficult it
would be for someone who has a one-year
lease but really expects to stay having
no reason to believe that then not going
to be able to stay realize how important
it is to have as much notice as possible
to try to find alternative housing when
there's so little available and
therefore why for example 60 days is
twice as good as 30 days
that's a valid point I I I can't dispute
that that's a valid point you know the
the can I just make one other point that
I that I neglected to say before I I
think it's important that that everyone
understand understand this
I'm not here saying that this bill is
like you know this is It's critically
important if we don't pass this bill you
know the sky is going to fall I'm not
here saying that and the reason I want
to I want to emphasize that is in many
respects
this bill is for lack of a better term
it's sort of a truth in advertising bill
because what it what what this bill
really says is a landlord
should be able to to end a tenancy at
the end of its term that's what the
contract says but suppose you don't pass
this bill suppose it doesn't it you know
I would introduced it last year I think
it got through the house but it didn't
get through the Senate suppose you don't
pass this bill well
does that mean the landlord who wants to
get rid of a tenant
um who's a problem is not going to be
able to get rid of the tenant no what
the landlord will do is raise the rent
or you know or or or use some other
vehicle that the landlord is is able to
do legally under the law
um even where uh you know and it's in
effect that's sort of an excuse Bill
landlord really just would would would
not raise a rent would simply say you
know the lease is up and and I want you
to and I want you to leave
um and I guess I think it's not a good
thing
to put landlords in a position where
they need to find some other excuse
which they'll find and nobody's going to
be able to the landlord says I want to
raise the rent that the landlord can
raise the rent that's not that's
entirely legal but do you really want to
put a landlord in a position where they
have to do something like that where
they're really what they're really
saying is you know this I I don't for
whatever reason not a not a
discriminatory reason but for whatever
reason I don't want to renew the lease
with this particular tenant I think I
don't think you do want to I don't think
the law should encourage that I think
the law should allow you know people to
act forthrightly with each other
thank you
representative mcbeath thank you thank
you for taking my question so isn't it
um can't under the current law once the
term of the lease
um expires it's just a month-to-month
tent is tennis tenants today so both the
landlord and the um renter have
um you know Alternatives or you know to
to end the lease already I mean this
would take away
um really that
I mean I think the year allows the
landlord to recoup their expenses gives
the security to the renter but if the
renter is not
um you know for whatever reason landlord
wants to get rid of them as you said
they can but
um so there are um you know remedies
available under the current law it's not
like the lease continues really forever
it's just this lease to least a
month-to-month extension
no I have to respectfully disagree I
think that that's exactly what judge
Neto was pointing out in his in uh in
his in his uh written opinion it's not
it's the the landlord cannot can't that
when that lease is extended month to
month the landlord can't end the month
to month either just because the month
to month is over so as Justice Neto
pointed out if perpetually this is a you
know this is a I mean this is
theoretically a Perpetual lease now
obviously at some point you know uh
economic situation is going to be such
that the landlord even the landlord is
obviously going to raise the rent at
some point
um and maybe the tenant wouldn't be able
to afford to pay the pay the rent and
then would be able to leave but but no
it's not true that once this turns into
a month-to-month rent it can be a
month-to-month tendency it can be it can
be defeated the tenant of course can can
quit anytime but the landlord cannot
under the reasoning of this case
representative tur
yeah thanks
um and thanks representative Lynn um I
guess what I'm wondering is
is it your understanding that
essentially if the terms of the the
offer for the the lease change in any
way price or some other
um provision that this really wouldn't
apply this this really applies more or
less in this
sort of
an implied right of first refusal I
guess I'd call it that that whoever is
in in the property can continue and
essentially if any of the other terms
were to change like the the landlord
wants to change the the price or or
place other restrictions or whatever
that essentially they would already be
able to they would already be able to do
that this would only apply if they sort
of status quo but they have some other
reason why they want that tenant to
leave right I know I think that I think
that's a fair point I mean that the the
reasoning of the majority in that case
is sort of along the lines of what
you're saying basically what the
majority
um said in that case I think the
decision was written by just delanis who
for whom I have great respect she was a
great judge I just disagree with her on
this but I think her her the rationale
of the majority was well if you're
talking about only restricted property
so the landlords tend to be sort of
bigger landlords and if the landlord
isn't trying to change the sort of
economic or other conditions of the
lease
um uh which which the landlord could do
but if the landlord's not trying to do
that then it shouldn't really make any
difference to the landlord whether the
tenant is tenant X or tenant why and I
think the problem with that is that it
was what I alluded to before in other
words it you know the
you may have a situation where a
landlord
wants to get rid of a tenant because the
tenant is a problem tenant and sure
there are Provisions under the law that
would allow the landlord to go to court
and say you know the tenant is is uh
disturbing other other uh
uh disturbing other tenants or hurting
the property or whatever sure that's
true but
you can have situations it seems to me
where a landlord doesn't want to do that
kind of thing and just wants to be able
to know you know as I said before I'm I
this is I'm take I'm willing to take a
risk on this tenant even though I don't
even though I have questions about
whether it'll he or she will be a good
tenant because I only have to do this
for a year and if it turns out you know
they're the my worst fears come to light
I'm just going to end the tendency at
the end of the year and I won't have to
go to court and fight about did you know
it was a tenant being too noisy or was a
tenant uh you know the tenant's pet
causing problems I won't have to do that
I can just say it the years up you have
to leave
um but but under this case the landlord
can't do that
representative De Lorenzo
thank you Mr Chu and thank you for
taking
Senator nipple in so um
I'm listening to what you had just um
expressed and
well one with a bad tenant
now let me let me back up a bit
once Elisa has expired and you've given
the Horizon a 30-day notice that they
have to move
does not the case still have to go to
court for an eviction
well the case would have to go to court
but this decision says
you can't evict just because the lease
is up so if you gave a 30-day note under
current law now if you gave a 30-day
notice saying the lease is up I want you
to leave the tenant could say I'm not
leaving and and would prevail
may I found so the tenant would say I am
not leaving but the landlife still wants
the tenant out at that point wouldn't a
court case begin
well the landlord I suppose could still
go to court but the but the under the
law the landlord would lose so I I think
that you know unless the landlord wanted
to sort of
waste his time and maybe use money by
hiring a lawyer the landlord would
presumably would not go forward because
because the landlord would lose
why do you think the landlord would lose
because this case says because this case
says that this case says that if the
mere if if the only reason you're
looking to evict a tenant is the term of
the lease is up you can't evict the
tenant
that's what the law says
thank you
and representative Perez
I'm going to put this very simply as I'm
one of the few that are not a lawyer
here but so I own a home say I own an
apartment building which I do not and I
have a lease coming up at the end of
March
and my daughter for some reason is
moving here from Florida and is staying
with me and I can say to her well
there's a lease up at the end of March
we you can move in the first of April
under the current law I as a
landlord cannot do that
under this law I would be able to do
that is that what you're saying
I'm not quite sure I under if I'm not
quite sure I understand your example
so okay so I own an apartment building
yeah I have a tenant whose lease is
going to be up I want to rent that
apartment to my daughter yes no no I'm
sorry the current law I can't terminate
that lease and give it to my daughter
well no you know what the I think there
may I I'm I'm not positive about this
but I think the answer to that is yes
you could because I think that there is
that that that probably wanting to rent
to a family member okay let's say I
would be to a friend I'll
so I again I think it becomes uh the
friend makes it a closer question uh but
even there if if you have
some particular reason that you want to
evict the tenant uh you know beyond
there being just the the it's the end of
the term if you if you say you know
um it's a family member I I I'm almost
positive if it's a family member you
there's a provision that allows you to
do that if it's just a friend I'm not
sure but it might be that a court would
say well that's a you know that's a good
reason that that is good cause but if if
you just if you just said
the lease is up I want you know I want
you out for you tenant out
um uh that would not be that would not
be good enough
you would you you would have the the
tenant would have a right to stay
follow up
so but this
would allow me to do that
for a friend a family member or just a
different person this law would allow me
to do that right this love basically
says you made a contract when the
contract is over the contract is over
and you know that you you
the contract is over so the tenant has
to leave yes okay thank you
thank you any further questions for
representative representative Stapleton
thank you uh Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
um you cited the Supreme Court decision
of 2005. what is the title of the name
of that sure absolutely I'm sorry I
should it's called aimco aimco
properties
versus
dizzywits d-z-i-e-w-i-s-z
and it's reported at 152 New Hampshire
587.
thank you follow up
it sounds like if you want to terminate
this Elise you you have to have good
cause
if you have good cause then it sounds as
though that you've got a good chance of
being able to defend an acquire and
complete that termination without good
cause
um
you're inhibited from just an arbitrary
termination of a lease under the law is
that correct right I mean I think you're
right the question is whether the end of
the lease term is good cause and the
Supreme Court said in this case no it is
not good cause
um and that's what that's basically what
I have a problem with and the purpose of
this bill is to say
you know normally when a contract is
over
um uh the contract is over and so I
would think that would be good cause to
uh to evict the the tenant if the tenant
didn't want to leave
foreign
any further questions for representative
Lynn
saying none thank you
We Now call Representative Staub
and
good morning thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee for taking
my testimony my name is Kathy style I
represent Hillsboro District 25 which is
award five in Manchester
in the city of Manchester about 50
percent of the people who live there are
renters
this I'm my goal today is to give you
some information about who will be
impacted if this bill were to pass
um
currently the state has just cause
eviction which means you can't
um you can't evict somebody unless they
violated the terms of the lease they've
not paid rent you can ask someone to
leave if you're going to move into the
unit yourself or you have a family
member who is going to move into the
unit yourself and themselves
even with just cause eviction we have a
very serious problem with homelessness
in the city of Manchester and in a lot
of other cities in the state
um a lot of attention gets paid to the
people who are living on 10 intense on
the street corners but there's a lot of
hidden homelessness
um as families with children who are
living in hotels I have a new neighbor
who um with her husband and three
children was living in a hotel for over
a year and she just recently found a
place to live
I've also you know heard stories and
have friends who are elderly who found
out their apartment building was being
sold and they were told to leave so that
they could renovate the building and
raise the rent
and she ended up Couchsurfing for a
number of years and this is a woman who
was living independently who is now in a
nursing home
the other
group of people that are impacted by
this are young people usually with low
incomes this is their first place that
they're living and
um they're you know they struggle to pay
rent and um
they end up living in their cars because
they have no place to go the the
you know the lucky ones are able to
double up people move in with family
members
um you know it's it's very difficult and
it's it's hard to keep people who are
working in low-income jobs you know
people who keep at grocery stores open
the people who are working in the
nursing homes people who are cleaning
the hospital those are the people who
are most likely to be impacted by
something like this because they don't
have any place to go you've heard about
the low vacancy rates currently in
Manchester in New Hampshire
um average earned for a single family
apartment is twelve hundred dollars for
two pen bedroom it's fifteen hundred
dollars a month in the Hillsborough
County it's eighteen hundred dollars a
month for two bedroom apartment in order
to get one of those apartments if you
can find it because the vacancy rate is
so low you have to prove that you have
the income to be able to rent that that
apartment so for example if you're
willing to pay 50 of your income for
your housing the landlord won't rent to
you so it's really difficult it's a real
really serious situation that we have in
the city of Manchester and in other
cities around the state and I don't see
how this bill will do anything except
exacerbate the problem because you're
going to have more people who are being
evicted more people who can't find
housing and more homelessness and when
that happens you know we're a Humane
Society so we can't abide seeing young
families living in cars or on the
streets with their children so we put
them up in hotels and that the burden of
that falls on all of us in the society
and so I'm opposed to this bill I hope
you don't I hope you you declare it in
expedient to legislate and I'm happy to
take any questions I will say that New
Hampshire legal aid is coming forward
after me so questions about the legality
um
um what might better be answered by them
um thank you
question
questions for this Witness
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question I didn't catch that percentage
but you said if you if
tenants rent is such a percentage of
income they won't rent to you what is
that percentage again
thank you for the question it's nice to
see you again we sat next to each other
on organization day
um
um normally what um like the national
low-income housing Association says is
that you should be paying 30 of your
income for for your housing but if you
have to pay more than that landlords can
say no I'm not going to rent to you and
you know there are so many people
stacked up for every apartment that they
get to choose who's going to live in
that apartment
finally just aren't enough yes is there
a Red Line there okay 30 is a standard
requirement but you know does the red
line occur when it's forty percent fifty
percent higher
um I'm not sure
um I think you know maybe legal aid
might be able to answer that question a
little bit better but you know there are
people who are paying more than their um
more than 30 percent of their income for
housing if the landlord will allow it
but it's difficult to find a landlord
who will do that for you
thank you thank you for the question are
there questions for this Witness
thank you very much representative thank
you
nick uh Norman
thank you once again for the opportunity
to speak to you I introduced myself last
last time I advocate for landlords
across the state
a large readership of around 3 400
I believe that I can be fairly quick on
this I know we're short on time with
lots of bills to consider I want to
assure you that as a landlord of 35
years and in contact with thousands of
landlords that there is no landlord that
like gets pleasure out of evicting
tenants or wants to evict tenants a
landlord does not want to evict a tenant
it's bad business it loses money it
creates
hardship for the tenant we don't want to
do that and it creates hardship for the
landlords with more maintenance costs
advertising showing the property
there's no reason that we want to evict
a tenant
however as one of the previous speakers
did say sometimes there is a tenant that
you don't want the tenancy to continue
they may be causing a lot of trouble to
the neighboring tenants in the property
there's quite a number of reasons that
you may not want to con to continue a
tendency so if this bill were to pass
what you would see
I predict was that the only people that
would be affected by this
are those
bad tenants that are causing problems
or perhaps a friend's situation like was
mentioned over here that might be hard
to justify as a good cause
the tenants I mean landlords just don't
want to evict
the bill would as said create an actual
end to a lease and that's only
reasonable you enter a contract there
should be an end to the contract
there was a question over here about
where's the red line
in our company and I think it's common
for landlords Redline would be 50 of
income
like this really hard for someone to to
afford to live and make it work in a
long-term situation at 50 percent
but even in our company we don't say no
at 50 percent
what we say at that level is if you want
to live here and pay 50 or more of your
income then you need to prove to us that
you can do that right you can submit to
us a budget give us your history maybe
you're the kind of person that is really
good on saving and and can budget and
make it work maybe you have made it work
but when I would say a property owner
sees more than 40
then that's like we're getting iffy here
can they really do it and 50 is most
people can't actually
but there's a few that can so we
wouldn't say no there
I'm very happy to take any questions
questions for this Witness
yes representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair
uh
and thank you for taking my question
what
recourse do you have
if other tenants are complaining about a
tenant other than to uh
tell them they have to move out at the
end of the lease it's a very tough
situation for a landlord there's very
little recourse at all
so a landlord could attempt to evict the
tenant on bad behavior
it's possible that is legally allowed
but to go to court to evict a tenant for
that situation
you would have to prove the bad behavior
and usually I'm saying like almost
always there is nobody in the property
that's a neighboring tenant that would
testify in court and put themselves at
risk in that way
so
it's it's very hard to get rid of a
tenant that's causing disturbance or
whatever selling drugs or any of the
different bad behaviors that are are
there
one other answer to your question is
if if you feel like you can't prove the
bad behavior in that scenario an option
and a lot of landlords will take it is
to choose well I'm going to
renovate this property into a more High
scale apartment
that's a valid reason to to evict a
tenant because you want to do a large
renovation
and
personally I think that's a really sad
situation because now what you're doing
is you're forcing a landlord to take one
of those options that it reduces the
affordable housing
thank you very much other questions for
this witness yes
thank you for taking my question
um uh what con I hear you keep using the
term uh bad tenant and I want to know
what constitutes a bad tenant
bad tenants could be someone that has
animals that they don't take care of
their animals they're leaving dog poop
around the property and over their beds
in the apartment that they haven't
cleaned up or strewn throughout the
apartment or on the decks there's an
example of a bad tenant a bad tenant
could be someone that's constantly
causing noise disturbance and not giving
a place of quiet enjoyment to the
neighboring tenants
a bad tenant could be someone that's
selling drugs and creating a lot of
traffic in the building
many many other 10 bad tenant could be
someone that's busting holes in the
walls and creating damage
a bad tenant these are things that I
know of personally from myself or other
landlords a bad tenant could be a tenant
that's mad at the landlord for some
reason and they turn on all of their
Faucets in the apartment and stuff the
drains so that the sinks overflow
there's many many kinds of bad tenants
way far more bad tenants than bad
landlords
right
further questions further questions for
this Witness
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so you have a problem tenant that does
any number of things that you just
described
and the landlord says your route on the
termination of the lease or if it's
serious enough even before the
termination
and he says I'm and the Tenant says I'm
not going
so you have a recourse to take your
eviction complaint to the court uh how
costly and how long does that generally
take is that a difficult proposition for
a landlord thank you thank you for the
question there's two answers to the
question
um the eviction process fairly quickly
devised down in two scenarios one is
non-payment of rent
the other is all other sorts of bad
behaviors
if it's a non-payment of rent that's a
fairly simple eviction to win for a
landlord actually and that process
usually takes about six to eight weeks
if the landlord is diligent at following
every step you know right after the last
step ends and they haven't made any
mistakes clerical mistakes on the forms
if it's for bad behavior of any of those
different things the process takes an
extra 21 days
if you can actually prove those
situations in court and usually it's
very difficult to prove those types of
allegations in court so is it real
likely to actually lose the case after
all of that in terms of costs the cost
of an eviction can run if you're doing
it yourself
anywhere from maybe around two hundred
dollars to four hundred dollars
by the time you're done
there's a lot of factors that change the
cost
other questions for the switch
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much
David Klein please
thank you thank you to the committee for
allowing me to speak my name is Stephen
Quine again
um I just want to reiterate turnover
costs are very expensive for landlords
we have to go in clean the apartment
many times repaint it sometimes we have
to change the flooring we don't want to
be in the eviction business we want to
be in the renting business and it's very
rare we do it
second of all under RSA 540 colon 2
which is the landlord tenant statute
dealing with evictions you have
delineated certain things that are
grounds for evictions and the problem is
there are times when you hit that spot
where it doesn't meet one of those
grounds and this bill gives us an option
to get a bad tenant out who's not super
bad
I have one of those situations today I
use a management company to run the
apartments tenants are supposed to call
the management company out of the 40
units I have I have one who I never gave
a phone number to isn't supposed to call
me got it from an old attendant before
we turned it over and calls me his next
to last phone message starts hi dumb
slumlord
he calls me threatened to call every day
he hasn't he's threatened to contact all
my tenants to talk about how bad I am
trying to try and deal with me making
economic threats against me he's
degraded in many of the phone messages
our management company
uh he's a pain it's a part of mildly but
he doesn't destroy the property I can't
prove he's making these phone calls from
the property so then I don't have a
grounds for eviction that he might be
creating or being involved in criminal
activity of harassment phone calls and I
really am going to have trouble getting
him out and I need to get him out for my
own peace of mind I finally had to block
him sometimes so I could take care of
some of my own personal things
and the problem is I don't have a good
ground his lease is coming up we want to
get rid of him we have to find something
if this bill was in place I would be
able to do it another advantage of this
bill actually goes to the tenants that
in an eviction process the first step is
serving the tenant with an eviction
notice and in the eviction notice you
have to specify the grounds
non-payment rents easy
but in other cases we will have to
allege if it's bad behavior that bad
behavior that document is a public
document any new landlord can get a hold
of it any of the reporting Services
regarding tenants can get a hold of it
and it could make it far harder for that
tenant to find other housing in the
future an eviction on a tenants record
is grounds in my mind to reject that
tenant so that if we have this in place
lease is up he knows he has to get out
he doesn't want an eviction
he's gone helps him helps me
and I think it's worth it to have this
in place and we don't want to evict I
know we're going to hear that landlord
is convict if they would be able to
evict if they don't like the tenant but
it's very expensive it's not something
we want to do and just understand I lose
a month's rent right up front paying the
management company to re-rent it if I do
that and many other landlords are in the
same position or if you do it yourself
you have your time energy screening all
that involved so we're not out to evict
people we don't make money evicting
people we lose money and overfest right
thank you for allowing me to testify all
right thank you sir questions for this
Witnesses yes representative mcbeath
thank you Mr Mr chair thank you Mr Klein
for taking my question
um I think your testimony said that this
bill would allow you to get bad tenants
out where they didn't fit currently now
the good cause
um SEC sections are in 542.
um
uh you know unfortunately the tenant
you're referencing you know is a jerk
but jerks have rights unfortunately we
might not always want them to and um as
I think the prime sponsor of this rule
said maybe sometimes landlord tenants
need to I mean landlords should get
legal advice because instead of evicting
this jerk maybe a civil restraining
order which would not cost for 200 to
500 would give you peace of a mind but
it still protects you said he was a good
tenant right he said he's paying his
bills and he's not bothering anyone
there he's just bothering you so that
harassment could be
um
uh you know addressed appropriately
through the law and not through trying
to evict him yeah I I I looked at 540
first of all the reference is 540 colon
2 for the the grounds for eviction just
to make that clear then we have the I
call it the do's and don'ts of land
Lieutenant law 540 hyphen a he doesn't
fit in my mind the language of 540 hey
to give me that and in order to get such
a civil restraining order I'd have to go
to Superior Court and get an injunction
against him which gets very expensive
it's not it's not one of these these
little civil petitions that we can do in
540A
so it's it's more difficult than you're
saying
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir
um
Jessica margason
yes Miss Morgan thank you good morning
um Jessica Martinson again and I oppose
this bill
um for quite a few reasons I also
brought up with me and I would hope
everybody would take a look at RSA 540
colon 2 or colon 2 termination of
tenancy there's a myriad of multiple
different ways that they can as they
stated have an eviction
um many of the ones I listen to there
are plenty of reasons and someone asked
over here about
um when they mentioned a I would like to
close my apartment I'm renting it out
but I have a relative moving in well
whether it's a friend a relative
whatever it is that falls under other
good cause of Sound business decision if
it's a sound business decision for you
you can evict and it's a horrible fear
that tenants live under every day so
adding another tool to their box to just
casually evict someone in the state that
we're in right now would be very
devastating
um
under this one this bill would be very
unhealthy for our state it'd be very
costly and it creates instability and an
already unstable environment as stated
previously multiple times like
Manchester our vacancy rates 0.3 our
County Hillsborough is 0.4 not much
better it takes my tenants on average
six months to locate an apartment that
they can secure those at 30 Ami area
median income and up to 50 Ami have way
less options out there available to them
for renting a lot of them are stuck
currently in hotels in our state we have
roughly 72 individuals and families in
hotels majority of them because they
cannot find an apartment I have some
clients with vouchers even they just
can't find an apartment so we don't want
to take a situation as it is where it's
already hard to be housed and create
something harder when we already have
plenty of safety
um
plenty of reasons in here a landlord
could evict from anything from a safety
reason
um if the tenants not safe to be in
there either to themselves or others if
they're creating damage if they won't
let them in to do bug remediation
there's a myriad of reasons already
other than the horrible one of other
good cause so I strongly oppose this one
let me make sure I'm not missing
anything
um
yeah because if you look over it you'll
see rent due damage failure to comply
with lease terms on safe Behavior other
good cause removal dwelling unit even if
they want to just remove the dwelling
unit from there so I've seen many
tenants that this would affect extremely
adversely and it would affect a
marginalized portion of the society much
worse than another creating strain on
other
resources available to help them
such as the homelessness that's been
spoken about
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much mayor
Brendan Lemay
hey it's Brandon Lemay from Manchester
New Hampshire uh I am a tenant organizer
with writes in democracy uh but speaking
of my own behalf right here uh I'm
speaking in opposition of Bill 117.
uh and I want to put it shortly here I
think that this bill would make it so
more law-abiding and least abiding
tenants are going to get evicted
and so we've heard some examples here
and again we're all innocent until we're
proven guilty in a court of law at least
and if you can't prove that a crime is
being committed and you can't prove that
a lease term is being broken then what
Merit is there at all
again these are just like you can just
evict somebody on the suspicion that
they might be breaking a law or they
might be breaking a lease term I would
need to see something much more Concrete
in order to justify that
and one thing I wanted to add to uh for
extra context uh somebody asked here
about what landlords generally require
for income my landlord requires uh no
more than rent to be 25 of my income I
usually see it's between that and like
one-third of your income and just to
clear that up
um so yeah this bill would essentially
make it would increase evictions at a
time when housing is not very available
right now it's virtually a zero percent
occupation occupancy rate it should be
about four to eight percent
uh and I also want to add two evictions
make it harder to find that next
apartment so again we could be evicting
more lease and law-abiding tenants and
then affect their ability negatively to
get an apartment again all because they
followed the law they paid the rent on
time you know they picked up after their
dog poop and you know
um for For What and finally you know I I
wanted to imagine you know what is the
least
I don't want to say a bad landlord but
what if my landlord was a Democrat and I
am a Republican and my landlord can look
up my registration
like like could they could they then oh
I'm sorry well sorry could I could I
could I rephrase that yes let's say my
landlord has a different political
Association no what
this is not about anybody's political
party preference and I object could I oh
I'm sorry sorry
uh okay
um what if my landlord is a Jets fan and
I'm a Patriots fan and they want to
evict me just for that because of the
sports team that I that I that that I
root for
I mean that could be a grounds for an
eviction under under this law
so if you mean if if the term of the
lease was up it could be an aggressive
yes yes yes
um and also I want to say too um there's
a reference to saying that you know
essentially as just cause exists right
now leases are in perpetuity
in effect but I want to say that housing
is a human need and even if my lease is
up I still keep living in perpetuity
hopefully and I believe this bill would
increase homelessness and the and
negatively impact the ability of future
folks to rent all right questions for
this witness yes representative Wallace
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question
um you alleged that the evictions will
um will may go up as a result of this
bill because you're having an eviction
on your uh tenancy record wouldn't it
make more sense for everybody to get
along and say hey look the lease is up
we're going to go always individually
and separately separately on our own
accord then you don't have the eviction
the Orlando doesn't have to go through
it and then there's no problems
acquiring another property in the future
doesn't that make more sense yes uh
thank you for the question
representative I would say in a normal
housing market you know if we had a
vacancy rate of eight percent then in
effect yeah I believe that could make
the most sense for all parties involved
I don't believe that tenants want to
stay in a place where the landlord does
not want them to be there but
circumstances virtually you know dictate
that it's very hard to find that next
apartment and if I get an eviction then
you know it like like a previous uh
speaker said it could take up to six
months to find a new apartment
so you know renters are in a bind right
now
other questions yes representative Perez
thank you
is there not a a difference between an
eviction and not renewing your lease
I mean it it seems to me that if I don't
renew your lease I'm not evicting you
I'm just not renewing your lease and if
you are a good tenant and you do all the
wonderful things that you're supposed to
do and paying and picking up and this
and that why would and you think it's
it's going to be because you're a Jets
fan and I'm a Patriots fan
I I think that's going a little deep
because if I'm a if I'm a landlord I'm
not willing to have to put forward the
money that I would have to put forward
to find someone new just because you
don't like the Patriots Yeah
um I'm not sure well first thank you for
the question representative
um so I want to make sure that I answer
your questions so are you asking is it
not an eviction if you don't want to
renew the lease
so under current definition that is that
is an eviction
um that's also not good cause right
there
um
and I I want to apologize I don't know
if I fully understood the nature of your
question there
I just wanted to know if you know what
do you think would be the the motive of
a landlord wanting to
not renew your lease if you were all
these wonderful you know the perfect
tenant I mean do we not assume that that
landlord would want to keep you there
you know the W no is better than the
devil you don't or that type of thing
okay yeah no thank you for that question
and thank you for clarifying and I
apologize for my confusion there
um I would say yeah like a rationally
acting landlord
um would conduct in that manner and I
would hope that most landlords in this
room would generally agree with that
sentiment unfortunately
um the majority of the landlords that
you know the the problem landlords
um are not necessarily the most rational
actors in my opinion there and sometimes
just personal disputes just get in the
way of a rational business decision
other questions yes representative
greeson thank you Mr chair and thank you
for answering our questions the purpose
of a contract is to establish mutually
agreed terms
and they protect both parties it's
designed to protect you the tenant and
the landlord
both parties are supposed to abide by
the terms of the contract this bill is
only dealing with the end of the
contract okay so after the contract is
up
what obligations does the landlord have
to you the tenant
once that contract is lapsed
are is the landlord are you is the
landlord still required to abide by
whatever those terms of the contract are
if you aren't
uh thank you for the question
representative um so the answer is both
parties are still like their their
obligations are still to uphold both
ends of the contract so me as a tenant I
would then have to keep paying my rent I
would have to keep respecting the
property the landlord still provides you
know a basic quality of housing I would
also say two that I want to emphasize
that housing is a human need and I would
argue too it's a public good so I also
want to emphasize too that there are
broader implications outside of just
this contract but also in again such a
low vacancy rate I mean there are
negative implications for tenants there
are negative implications for the
community at large and sorry about that
I'll no go ahead no I I see yeah hang on
representative Smith
um thank you very much
um uh sir you tell us that you're
representing rights and democracy here
are you um a registered lobbyist uh I
believe that I am not registered as
lobbyist right now thank you other
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir all
right thank you
uh uh Kirsten Cornell
good morning thank you for taking my
testimony today my name is Kirsten
Cornell I'm an attorney with New
Hampshire legal assistance and I'm here
today in opposition to this bill I will
try my hardest to answer some of the
questions regarding a eviction process
that seemed to have come up over the
past few minutes we've been discussing
this and my colleague will be passing
around a couple of handouts which
include the eviction form that landlords
can use when they are seeking to evict a
tenant and it lists uh both the reasons
and the time frame that's required just
so that you have an opportunity to look
at what they're working with
I want to start by saying that on the
face of this bill it looks pretty benign
I think that if we were living in a time
and a place where there was sufficient
housing all landlords were good actors
and landlords and tenants had equal
bargaining power
I think that many of us would be
hard-pressed to disagree but we're not
living in that time and place
we're living in a time and place when
housing prices are at an all-time high
vacancy is at an all-time low you've
heard the statistic so I won't go
through them again the one I will add is
that over 30 000 households in New
Hampshire are spending over half their
uh half their income on rent
it is harder to get an apartment right
now which makes it easier for a landlord
to require a greater income
so let's say a tenant has been renting
for the past five years
and when they got that apartment there
was a much higher vacancy rate a healthy
a healthy housing economy has about a
five percent vacancy rate that's a rate
in which people are able to move
relatively seamlessly from one place to
another without disrupting their lives
as you've heard we have a basic a 0.5 to
a point three percent vacancy rate in
New Hampshire right now
so four or five years ago you could get
an apartment with having you know fifty
percent of your income going toward your
rent that's not possible anymore
so a person who was able to get that
apartment has been able to make that
work has been paying their rent has been
complying with lease terms has been a
good neighbor this bill would make it
possible for them to be evicted for
doing nothing wrong and then place them
in a housing market where they're simply
not going to be able to find a place to
go
I have clients who have looked for
apartments for six months to a year and
then ended up leaving the state because
they couldn't find anything
in the last three weeks I've had two
clients tell me that they're not going
to bother looking because they can't
find anything
the good cause law that was passed and
that was used in the case that was
referenced uh and that was the formation
of this bill was meant to balance the
risks and
the rights of both the the interests and
harms of both the property owners and
the tenants it was to find a way for
tenants to have some rights and some
protection some stability
and also allow Property Owners the
ability to
for good reason be able to use their
property in a way that they desire
which is why good cause exists because
any legitimate business reason economic
reason
constitutes good costs if you want to
take the it off the housing market you
can do that if you want to rent to your
uh your your daughter you can do that
there are very many reasons that you can
evict a tenant
this is just making it so that you don't
have to give a reason at all
Cornell you're you're kind of over your
time so can you can I ask you to sum up
please I sure can so
in an effort not to reiterate what
others have said I'll just say that this
bill will essentially create a practice
or could create a practice of a series
of six months
tendencies that are essentially
probationary
a stable housing is not going to become
available for folks who are not
fortunate enough to own property in this
state and that the detrimental to
low-income tenants and a detrimental to
renters overall
I'm happy to take any questions that the
committee may have questions for this
Witness
representative cutoff
under the current law couldn't a
landlord just
raise the cost of the rent exponentially
to make the tenant leave anyway if they
wanted them to leave yes
they have to give 30 days notice for a
rental increase
as the law currently stands
thank you
other question representative Greece
Greece okay
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
answering our questions
if the landlord wants to raise the rent
when are they allowed to raise the rent
they are allowed to raise the rent
outside of a rental period so let's say
that the termination say there's a
12-month lease and that 12-month lease
is up in January so and this goes to the
perpetuity issue as well so it is true
that it's a contract for 12 months the
terms of that contract renegotiated at
the 12-month Mark so if you're 12 months
is up in January you can say to the
tenant if you want to stay I want you to
sign a new lease and the new lease calls
for this amount of rent and the Tenant
can say okay I'll pay that amount in
brand or any other lease provision you
may want to add or or change or they can
say no and they can move on on their way
without having to go through the court
process
follow up please sir yes follow and and
with that though what what you've
omitted is the fact that if the tenant
you you say if if the tenant agrees they
can stay they can sign the new lease or
they could say no and they can move out
but that's the end of the of the of the
lease agreement what if the tenant just
says I don't want to sign a new lease
but I don't want to go and that's what
this is dealing with the the landlord
does not have any way of saying I don't
want you to stay I don't want to renew
the lease why do I have to provide a
different reason other than we're at the
end of the lease and there are no terms
by which I want to sign a new lease
I mean I got lost at the end of your
question there's no terms that so you as
the landlord I can't raise I can't raise
the rent until the end of the of the of
the of the lease yes I can't change any
of the terms of the lease during the
term of the lease correct so I have to
wait until the end of the lease period
to do anything at all the only thing I
can't do
is kick you out at the end of the lease
period because it's up so to be clear
you can evict a tenant for cause Okay
this bill is only dealing with the end
of the lease term only
you're talking over each other so you've
asked a question I apologize finish your
answer all right so this yes this is
about the ending of a lease term at the
end of a lease term at the end of any
contract you can renegotiate terms
there's a distinction between
renegotiating terms and ending the
contract there are reasons that you can
end the contract and so far as this that
are provided by in RSA 542 if you want
to raise the rent if you want to
renovate if you want to do any of those
economic reasons you can terminate the
contract if the tenant won't agree to
the raise fund the attendant doesn't
have to agree to you being able to
renovate the property there are many
ways that you have the ability if you
have a valid reason for wanting that
tenant out if you don't have a reason
it's true because tenants need some
rights also they need to have some
protection that if they're doing what
they're supposed to do if they're being
a good tenant as keeps being referred to
they have some protection and under the
law to ensure that they're going to be
able to keep their job keep their kid in
the same school district live a stable
life that everybody I believe deserves
to have
question representative Horgan
you mentioned tenants are moving out of
States
um
rather because of the housing crisis so
where are some of the other places
they're going uh I've had tenants
telling me that they're moving to
Pennsylvania to Maryland
many of them are moving to Massachusetts
uh had a couple tell me they're going to
Maine so it's kind of I think either
where they can find a place or where
maybe they have another family member
someone who can help them get a place
there all right so there's a follow-up
so they're so desperate they're willing
to forego the fact we're ranked number
one for Freedom have no income or sales
tax is that a question yes so they're
willing to foregro all the wonderful
things we like to talk about here in New
Hampshire in order to live in one of
those States I would say that they're
put in a position where they have to
forego not that they are willing to
representative Macbeth you had a
question I believe thank you
thank you for taking my question I just
want to be clear regarding your
testimony the um the bill would not
remove landlord's requirement to find
good cause not only in the 13th month of
the end of the lease but from the 13th
month
to as long as the tenant was in the
building that's correct so a good any of
the enumerated reasons for eviction or
good cause has to be given at the in any
circumstance whether or not there's a
lease the way the law functions now is
that if nothing happens at the end of a
lease term then it presumes a
month-to-month tendency thereafter the
same lease terms as were originally
agreed to continue to apply as do the
same requirements under the eviction
statute thank you other questions for
this Witness
oh I'm sorry a representative
yeah and thanks for taking the questions
uh this has brought up something
interesting
um I think in the preview from what I've
heard from previous uh Witnesses
this there's been a lot of talk about
that this law would basically preclude
the need for an eviction
um and that there would be no eviction
put on record
um
my understanding if I read this is that
this is predicated on a tenant that does
not want to go voluntarily at the end of
their their lease term and so
is this creating a new cause for
eviction or is it removing eviction
because it seems like even if this were
in place you would still need to go
through an eviction process because
you've still got a tenant that doesn't
want to leave is that correct yes that's
correct so the way that the eviction law
in New Hampshire works is that you can
negotiate with the tenant which I always
encourage all of my clients to do to
come to an agreement if the tenant does
not want to leave and the landlord wants
them to leave they have to use the
lawful eviction process which requires a
notice depend of a period of time
depending on the reason for the eviction
and then if the tenant has not vacated
at the end of that notice period Then
the court process begins and that's when
an eviction goes on a tenant's record so
can I ask one quick quality of course so
in the form that you gave out which
lists the existing reasons for eviction
would this in would there need to be an
additional step where this actually gets
added as a further
um cause for this form so that you could
say all right these are the other
reasons you could evict and now the new
cause is the lease is lapsed or
something like that so yeah it would as
it would as a cause it would add a cause
for eviction
um at the end of a lease term
okay because I'm not sure that I
understand that that that's what's in
the law
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much man
thank you very much
um Elisa Mar uh I'm not sure if it's
Margolis or margolin
marvelous okay
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Alyssa margolin
Marlin I'm sorry that's all right um and
I serve as director of housing action
New Hampshire uh we are opposed to House
Bill 117 our members include many
landlords of affordable housing and
we've been very active as an
organization in setting up a lot of
housing stabilization initiatives
particularly with the pandemic relief
funds that have come to the state arpa
cares act the December relief package
and we've been able to have a coming
together of a lot of landlord and tenant
interests to create that stabilization
in our state
um and so we feel like we've played a
role in making sure that the kind of
business of being a landlord uh stayed a
very strong business throughout the
pandemic and we avoided that
um perfect storm or the eviction tsunami
that so many experts were predicting
um
as these programs are starting to wind
down now we urge policy makers to avoid
making any policy changes that would
exacerbate as you know a very fragile
housing landscape in our state
um I had the opportunity to have a kind
of preview of the new housing Statewide
needs assessment that has been funded
and I will say that all the data here is
just the the new set of numbers coming
out are much worse the the data is very
sobering there's virtually no rental
housing available for the typical renter
near the job centers and so we believe
that a policy like this as policymakers
kind of putting your finger on this and
and opening up a new door for evictions
will undoubtedly challenge the New
Hampshire's economy and increase
homelessness
and has been said many times you know
RSA 540 already protects a lot of
landlords interests now note that the
chairman articulated
um you know a desire to overturn
established precedent and and as um New
Hampshire legal assistance just
testified on its face there there seems
to be it seems to be benign there seems
to be a sense of fairness a sense of
contract law we entered into this
agreement it came to the end
um but as you also noted Mr chair
um there are practical implications to
to this and we even heard practitioners
in the field say that they would use
this law to open the door to evicting
tenants that they just don't like and so
we don't encourage our policy makers to
be making this chain change particularly
at this time of crisis
you know inexpedient to legislate is a
term of art but it does seem like now is
really not the time to change uh the law
given the crisis that our state is
facing thank you I'll conclude my
testimony happy to take any questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much ma'am
is there anyone else who desires to
testify on HP 117.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that and we will turn to the
hearing on HB 235
um hang on one second let me find that
give me one second tap right and
um
of course we will
chair representative recognizes the
prime sponsor of the bill representative
dilorenzo
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the Judiciary Committee
I'm representative Charlotte dilorenzo I
am from Newmarket and I represent new
marketer newfields uh in Rockingham
District 10.
so the bill that we have before us
is to establish a commission to study
the expansion of the landlord tenant
mediation program in circuit courts
Now The Spill
um
has come back we um
it was heard
last session and um
as formerly SB 216
and it was voted voted ought to pass on
a senate floor on a Voice vote
and house Judiciary Committee it was
voted itl 11 to 9 on the house floor the
the vote was itl on a Voice vote
now this bill would create a commission
to study the landlord and tenant
mediation pilot program that has been
ongoing in the circuit courts the
program was developed by the circuit
courts to help landlords and tenants
work through issues to avoid an eviction
mediation is not mandatory in both the
landlord and tenant must agree to
mediation the pilot program has been a
great success and has kept 80 percent of
tenants facing eviction in their homes
the study commission would provide the
general court in all relevant
stakeholders with an appropriate venue
to analyze a program
assess what has and has not worked in
recommend changes going forward the
mediation approach is conciliatory
rather than punitive and could lead to
preservation of tenancy and prevent
homelessness
in short the landlord tenant mediation
program was a temporary Circuit Court
pilot program in conjunction with the
office of mediation and arbitration and
implemented as an emergency
Leyland tenant mediation pilot pro
project in Concord in the Claremont
district courts
mediation cases in which the tenant
files and appearance were referred to
mediation on or before the trial date
the pilot program was very successful
and benefited landlords and tenants
during the pandemic
of 36 cases that reached mediation 79
percent were settled
under mediation for non-payment of rent
cases the parties work out a payment
agreement to pay the current monthly
rent in to pay their average over a
limited time period
tenants eligible for emergency rental
assistance are referred to social
service agencies in agency payments are
paid directly to the landlord
do the success of the pilot program I
would like to see it placed into statute
and establish a
study committee
study commission will help with shape
out the prop process
the vote for this bill is for a study
committee only
it does not change any statutes at this
point
and I'm open for questions
uh questions uh for representative di
Lorenzo uh representative Wallace thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question this uh pilot program was this
only for uh evictions
yes okay thank you other questions for
this witness representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you my friend
taking my question
um so it seems to me like this program
like with the pilot program works I mean
if you're looking 80 like settle
why aren't you putting in a bill just to
fund it why are we studying it again
number one and why is it a commission
instead of a study committee I
understand that commissions typically
cost more money and like why aren't we
just funding it
well I just uh use the term commission
and committee interchangeably and I may
be in error on that
um
we wanted the study committee we wanted
to evaluate you know
um what the successes were and what the
failures were
so I've actually worked on the initial
bill with uh Senator Perkins qualca so
this was initially her bill and it was
she and I together that decided we
wanted a study Commission
follow-up do you mind no but please go
ahead would you be opposed of just doing
a legislative study committee on that
instead of a commission I understand it
costs more absolutely and I know that
we're having a committee on commissions
and about how there's a lot of
unnecessary commissions that the general
Corps passes so would this be something
where you know you and I and maybe a
couple people could sit down this summer
and talk about in the housing area and
maybe come up with solution that way
well I wanted
um some stakeholders to weigh in
because it does involve landlords and
property owners and we want to get their
their take it involves um
Legal Services Community we'd like to
get their take so we want it to be sort
of like an inclusive process thank you
yeah and I completely agree I think we
have landlords stakeholders we have the
court system in the back
would you be opposed to changing it just
to a committee
uh could you I don't understand you a
legislative study committee that's all
I don't know I need to think about that
thank you representative Smith if you
have a question I just if I could just
follow up on representative Alexander's
suggestion
um uh if in fact there was language that
indicated
um that the intention was to include
uh stakeholders in the process of
evaluation and deciding where to go from
here would you then feel
um that you would be able to support
that
yes thank you absolutely other questions
for this Witness
yes representative Perez thank you
how were people referred to the study
uh the mediation program how were they
referred to the mediation program do you
know
oh how would they get referrals right
how did this this these 30 some odd
people 36 cases how did they get into
this through the circuit courts through
the Circuit Court yes so if it was
expanded to
more circuit courts you'd see a lot more
people come in sure it would be part of
like a um landlord tenant intake during
the court process and
the um
the court would offer mediation for the
landlord and the tenant at no cost and
there are services available for
attendance like if um
let's say it's a non-payment or rent
issue and perhaps it's a child's they're
not receiving child support then the
mediate made it mediator could refer the
tenant to services to
get that Charlotte support money so they
can pay the rent thank you all right
other questions yes representative
Macbeth
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you for taking my question
we have to look around that speaker
um so my question the expansion I'm
curious if um your intentions of
expanding it across the state and maybe
put a priority in for Rockingham County
I had heard I was on a CLE last week and
I heard how great this program is
landlords and tenants and as far as
referring it usually happens that day of
the hearing um where the people come to
court and they're resolving issues right
in the lobby so um so is the expansion
you're thinking going to be Statewide
and is there a priority for Rockingham
County I would think for all of the um
circuit courts
other questions for this Witness
representative Horgan
um
thank you I'll make this quick because
it's sort of a would you believe but
would you believe that I'm also a
co-sponsor of the bill and then I think
the inclusion of the court system and
these other and these outside
stakeholders
um improves the bill and also that this
commission is in fact extremely
necessary it's not it's not a commission
that's dealing it's not it's not an
outmoded commission that hasn't done
anything in years but this is a new
commission and it's a very timely topic
uh yes I believe it all right are there
questions for this Witness
thank you very much representative De
Lorenzo oops oh I'm sorry you know
representative uh representative Wallace
yes thanks for taking my uh question
um the one stakeholder that I see that's
absent from this list is a any
representative of the landlords
um can you speak to that
I believe that's it I see I see two
senators four of the house one judge
representative New Hampshire legal
assistance representative the bar
association representative New Hampshire
Apartments Association
and they represent all the lands okay I
stand corrected okay
great all right other questions for this
Witness
thank you very much representative De
Lorenzo you're welcome uh uh next I'm
going to call on uh Richard head from
the judicial branch
okay
good morning Mr chairman member of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch and I have to
apologize to representative De Lorenzo I
did not have a chance to catch up with
her before I'm regarding my testimony
today in the grand scheme of things we
uh
uh enthusia enthusiastically support our
program we think it's a great program
we'll tell anybody and uh who's
interested in learning about it so we
would be happy to either have a
commission a committee
um uh
set up in which we could talk about a
program that said I do want to give a
little couple more pieces of information
that are recent that may also influence
your decision on on this bill one is
um so this bill is set up there two
phases to the landlord tenant mediation
one is a pre-filing process in which
the parties are notified of a pre-filing
eviction a mediation process
through various forms that have been
created that identify specifically this
process we've reached out or I'm sorry
in in the course of that process in 2020
uh end of 2021 through calendar year
729 parties contacted the courts of
those 199 went into mediation pre-suit
we don't yet have data on the successor
failure of that 199. there's the second
part of it is uh is in Concord and I'm
sorry in in Nashua in Manchester that's
a post-filing mediation program in that
program there have been 120 mediations
um in those two courts 75 percent of
those have settled so that's more
updated that's calendar year through
calendar year 2022.
um
the other aspect of this is that we have
uh retained uh resolution systems
Institute to do an evaluation of this
program so they are undertaking a
process evaluation of the entire program
at this point and that's new
um that is we're expecting a report for
that not until October of 2023 end of
October beginning in November
um so that would not inform a committee
if it was established it may be just
this may be a year too early because
this may provide important information
we would of course be happy to share
that with the legislature as to what the
findings are of that but we are
undertaking sort of a detailed process
evaluation of our program it's a program
we're very proud of we wanted to
continue the other aspect that is also
very recent is we have received
additional Federal grant funds to
continue this we anticipate that would
continue the program for another two
years
so our existing uh coveted related money
would expire mid mid year this year and
then I think we have another two years
of funding now available through this
new grant that we have obtained and with
that I'll conclude my comments but would
be happy to answer any questions
questions for this Witness
uh yes uh representative testerman
oh I guess I'm just trying to figure out
why with all the activity
we just don't have a program
why are we continuing to study it when
it appears that there is a mechanism
it's
reasonably successful
yet we're trying to keep to study this
now is that coming out of your office or
or what
um so thank you for the question no I
mean our office is implementing the
existing program we have a Statewide
pre-suit and we have the two courts that
are that are doing the post Suite
mediation program we've implemented that
we're hoping to continue it we are
evaluating it to make sure that we're
doing it well that we don't need to make
process changes in in our in our program
so the the the further study of it is is
being done internally to make sure that
we're doing it properly and that that we
have we couldn't you know that that
either more improvements to be made
we're hoping to learn about that in in
this process whether or not the
legislature wants to have its own study
we you know we're obviously proud of it
we're happy to talk about it but it's
not original donating from us
necessarily
yes representative divine
thank you chair
thank you for taking my question when it
comes to the Federal grant funds that
are supporting this commission
um
how is that being spent and how is that
being utilized and you did say it was
being you um you had funds up until 2024
is that keeping this going just to
utilize those funds or should we be
making you know passing this and saying
okay we have we have a good set
um
uh
a very good Set uh implementation of
mediation if you already have it in
place so so uh we think we have funding
through 2025
um and the so we would get through the
current year or mid-year this year with
the existing funding and the new Grant
would go another two years
um
in terms of of
I guess maybe I don't understand fully
the the
foreign
I'm just wondering how this the the
federal money is being used to keep it
going so um the federal monies in in the
current upper monies are being used uh
in two ways one is we fully fund the
mediators themselves so the the cost of
the mediators is being funded through
the program and then we also have
um a court staff who uh coordinates the
mediations and and scheduling and making
sure parties are aware of it and also
doing Outreach and uh and making sure
the availability of this mediation
program is uh is known
thank you other questions for this one
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr head for taking
my question
um so it seems to me so you're funded
through 2025
um through Federal grant funding um and
you're already studying it through the
judicial branch it's already doing their
internal investigation on that
um based on your current
um
the way you see this program already
would you come back maybe in 2025
request to fully fund this program based
on its success initially so that's a at
least a possibility
um it would depend on whether or not
additional funding is available through
grants through federal grants um so we
would probably continue to apply for
federal grants but
um it may also become a future budget
request
representative Manos
Mr chair
um in the
action to enforce the party's agreement
uh so thank you for the question any
sort of agreement
um is itself sort of a contract so those
by by their nature settlement Agreements
are executed and and ultimately become
an enforceable agreement between the
parties
but does the court schedule a follow-up
how does the court does the court retain
jurisdiction and or is it necessary for
the landlord to come back for example or
the tenant if the agreement isn't
followed um so thank you so you know the
the mediation would conclude that open
case
um and that that would be the settlement
would be the end of that case and if
there's any further proceedings a new
case would get filed
other questions for this week yes
representative tur
yeah uh thanks and and thanks for uh
providing the Insight from from within
your uh Branch
um
I guess what I'm wondering is in what in
what you've said recently would you
clarify whether or not you think this is
uh in some way redundant to the work
that you're doing internally or ready to
um study and evaluate the program this
looks like it brings together a variety
of of different stakeholders and parties
and I understand the the the interest in
sort of understanding what parts of the
program are working well and what parts
maybe aren't is is is is is this
duplicative or interfering or do you
feel it adds to what you're working on
um so thank you for the question I I
would not
um just it wouldn't necessarily be
duplicative the the evaluation we're
doing now is uh entirely internal
um just in terms of of How It's Working
internally to the extent a committee or
commission reformed that had additional
parties brought in
um that would be a different process
than what we're currently undertaking
other questions for this witness I guess
I just had one uh representative Mr head
is the um am I understanding correctly
that both the priesthood and the post
suit
mediation are those are entirely
voluntary in other words both sides have
to agree absolutely absolutely it's
entirely voluntary or so I guess I I
have to sort of follow up on I think on
rep representative Alexander's question
and and I I completely understand and
applaud representative De Lorenzo for
for the sort of go slow be careful
approach I think that's that's entirely
appropriate but I'm wondering if
if this is completely voluntary
and if nobody and I don't you know I
haven't seen anybody hear from the
landlord Community for example or the
tenant Community coming saying that this
is a bad idea I'm sort of wondering
putting the funding issue aside for the
moment I'm sort of wondering why we need
any study whether it's legislative or
broader why don't we just
yeah why don't we just say let's expand
this program I'm uh again subject to
funding United Finance you know is is
cursing Down on Me Maybe but but why not
I mean in terms of the policy issue it
sounds like to me every nobody seems to
sees a problem why don't we just do it
and so thank you for the question one is
um I agree the feedback we get is
positive from both sides so landlords
and tenants have provided positive
feedback on the process it's a way of
resolving disputes
um as to making a permanent or or
expanding it we are interested in doing
that we want to do it efficiently so
let's we'll look at what we're doing we
started this to make sure on a on on a
well we've expanded the pre to Statewide
and then the post is is primarily in
those two courts and the goal ultimately
is to expand it let's make sure through
this internal evaluation we're doing it
right and then and then look to to
expand it to the other courts I may have
gotten a text that tells me one thing
and I apologize for that I did not never
mind
right right that's a good point that's a
good point okay yeah
I'm sorry yes you were you I'm done
you're done okay all right other
questions for this witness yes
representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you sir for answering
our questions uh the
the current program for the two years
was 733
490.58 what is the new funding that I
mean according to
but I'm assuming that's the appropriate
I don't know information I don't know
the answer to actually how much the
current whatever that was how much is
the current funding for the next two
years and does that seem like a
reasonable amount going forward so that
uh if we were to expand it
permanently uh we wouldn't get the
ticking Time Bomb of it costing 10 times
as much
um so thank you for the question the the
next Grant is roughly and and to hold me
specifically to this number somewhere in
the 500 to 600 000 range I think
[Music]
um
whether you know and and that includes
Statewide in the pre
um and more restricted in the in the
post filing
um sort of what the cost is Statewide I
don't have an answer to that but it is
something that given the experience we
have I think we would have the ability
to to provide a pretty
uh accurate estimate of of the cost to
go Statewide if we if we go there and
again if there are additional Grant
funds available we would seek those out
also
right other questions for this Witness
thank you very much Mr head appreciate
you testimony
um Elise Morgan please
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Alyssa margolin and I serve as
director first I butchered your last
name this time of your first time I
apologize I'm sorry a service director
of housing action New Hampshire and
we're in support of this proposal I
mentioned earlier when I was testifying
about House Bill 117 that our
organization has been active in the
housing stabilization efforts during in
coming out of the pandemic and this is
one of those gems
um one of the Silver Linings and so we
too have heard really good feedback on
the program if you if you uh feel the
legislature should have a commission
that brings in interested parties or
committee that invites interested
parties to testify it's also really good
to learn that there's a formal
evaluation if you feel that the
legislature has a role in formalizing
that review to establish some education
but for hopefully you know budgetary
item is proposed next budget cycle to
support sustaining such a successful
program I would say we're flexible and
appreciate your consideration
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much ma'am is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill 235
I've seen none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 235
um
all right I'm gonna turn then and we're
I know we're behind I'm gonna turn to
house bill 261.
um
and hang on one second
find it
uh authorizing residential tenants to
terminate their lease uh in instances of
domestic violence or following a
disability uh a disabling illness or
accident and I will turn to uh
representative Reed for uh the prime
sponsor of the Bill thank you again Mr
chair and honorable members uh 50
through after this with me
so um this is pretty straightforward
it's allowing victims of domestic
violence as well as stalking
to be able to leave situations that are
a danger to them by releasing them from
their lease obligations it also is
saying that if a tenant develops a new
disability that makes the enjoyment of
the property impossible so for example
if someone's living in a third floor
walk up and then loses their legs in a
tragic accident that they would also be
able to leave their lease without
penalty
so there are real world examples for
both of these both are
well it's modeled I originally put it in
modeled after a Tennessee law that
passed I'm originally from Tennessee and
I'm friends with a couple Tennessee
legislators that had worked on this and
and you know when I heard that they had
said that I wanted to to put to figure
out if this was already happening in New
Hampshire and if not put it in
um after I put it in a not just a
constituent but actually a neighbor of
mine who lives in the apartment complex
I live in
um did in fact acquire a new disability
the loss of her legs she is on the third
floor of the building next to me and
um she's been working with legal
assistants to try to to get out of that
situation but she's essentially
homebound so these are based on real
world situations I've
um and by the way in the bill that
requires documentation for both you
don't just say that you're a victim you
have to have police reports or a order
of protection from a judge that has
declared after hearing that you are in
fact a victim of stalking or domestic
violence
um and obviously medical documentation
in the case of a new disability that
you've acquired since signing the lease
so that's the basics of the bill I have
struggled internally about presenting
this bill
in terms of how much do I say because I
have a story to tell
but I haven't been public in terms of my
life at the State House in the last six
years about it I am from Tennessee I
grew up in the in South Memphis a very
poor neighborhood and I was pretty
isolated and not
really socialized into what red flags
would be for a relationship and so at
the age of 17 when a boy took interest
in me and I just thought the world of
him I got involved in my first serious
relationship he turned out to be
extremely abusive had multiple warrants
in other states
um he held me captive for three days he
hit me with a car the FBI FBI got
involved at one point when after I got
out he continued to stalk me for 16
years and sent death threats across
state lines
um he finally stopped in 2016 when he
committed suicide uh the year I got
elected
when I got when I escaped from him I had
nowhere to go
and was forced into a series of kind of
like shacking up with different friends
and and relatives and things
I'm glad that I didn't I wasn't on the
lease the original lease because I would
have had an impossible time finally
finding renting rental housing which I
was able to find because I didn't have a
history of an eviction on my record but
if I had been on that lease I would have
been forced into an impossible situation
I would have been forced to stay with my
captor or have an eviction on my or have
a um
essentially be evicted or have the the
non-payment on my history and being
unable to find a place to live
so that's my piece of the story and why
when I found out that my Tennessee
legislator friends had put it in I
really wanted to make sure this got in
but as I said it's pretty
straightforward you have to have legal
documentation of either the domestic
violence or stalking or the medical
documentation of a new disability
and it just lets you leave without
penalty so that you're not forced into
essentially into a situation a
relationship that can lead to you dying
I don't think we should penalize people
for for surviving
and that's what I have and I'm happy to
take questions questions representative
page
thank you representative and thank you
for sharing your stories as hard as it
might be
I have a question that relates to and my
knowledge of the federal
laws in this area are minimal at best so
bear with me you're probably much more
expert than I am I doubt it
so my understanding is a federal uh
similar law that applies to public
housing situations that has a lower
standard than this bill would propose in
terms of
providing documentation or reason and I
think itself attestation
um so my question is could you if you
know about that what that would look
like self-attestation in terms of making
sure there's um a unanimity across
private and public housing situations
for these same situations so what would
that look like for uh private leases and
then
um second second to that on the
protective order piece uh that this bill
requires could you describe how that
might implicate the landlord would the
landlord be a witness to this that sort
of thing so so do you see my my point I
think in terms of the two-tier kind of
idea let me yes I do and let me try to
address those in reverse order so
so no in fact the reason the bill is a
little bit longer than you would expect
is because there's a piece of privacy
that landlord's not abled once a tenant
says this is the reason I have to leave
my lease you can't penalize me
um they give that documentation but the
landlord then is basically has to hold
that as confidential so the landlord
doesn't enter into the picture
I mean unless for other reasons that you
would right like if there's some reason
if the landlord happened to be present
and witness something then anyway
regardless of this bill you might want
to call them in as a witness but there's
no reason that the with this bill that
the landlord enters the picture before
the order of protection either the
emergency order of protection or the
hearing so that it's just it's not part
you would get that order of protection
first and then give it to the to the
landlord for the other piece so I'm like
I said I modeled this after the
Tennessee law and the Tennessee law is
probably a little bit
um less aggressive in terms of
protecting tenants than maybe the
federal standard so me wanting to just
get something passed I went with what I
thought would be the easier thing to
pass but
um it does make sense to match the
public housing piece so if the committee
were so inclined to match that level in
terms of attestation I understand it is
something along the lines of an
affidavit it so I'm signing I'm telling
you you know that this is a a legally
true statement that I have been a victim
of domestic violence for example so
um so yeah so that's a is a lower bar if
this committee were so inclined we could
go to that and make it uniform between
public housing and private
um but what is before you right now is
the easier ask once again
other questions for this Witness
yes representative D Lorenzo
my question um
while representative page was speaking I
was
distracted a little bit uh because
someone sent me a text but I wanted to
know if you are aware that um the
Violence Against Woman Act
um applies to any husband with federal
funds
so I think that's probably similar to
what was just brought up but again
housing with federal funds is different
than all all rentals in this state so
that's this is again modeling after
Tennessee and other states that have
passed this would apply to all housing
in this state
thank you another question
representative
yeah thanks and and thanks uh
representative Reed uh I just want to
draw out sort of underlying purpose um
it seems as though like with the
examples and such I wasn't totally clear
is one of the underlying causes for
something like this the ability to
um
remove the uh knowledge of that person's
address from sort of the the abusers
um uh awareness so basically the
breaking your lease essentially because
just having knowledge of where you live
is a danger to you through the stalking
piece for the stocking person correct
yes right
other questions for this witness thank
you very much ma'am thank you so much
uh David Klein
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is David Klein I'm not
against I'm speaking against the bill
but it's more of a structural issue than
anything else
um
as a practical matter if we have a
tenant that is in the situation of the
type that are alluded to that that being
stalked or a victim and they can't live
there
those problems will permeate through the
whole building incidents may happen it's
in our interest as a landlord for them
to go also perfectly willing to work
with them
and what I do like about the way the
bill is worked now set up now in the
first section is that it's clear
documentation we have a 173b action
where a judge rules that there is a
problem or you have a real police
department report with criminal action
may be brought against stalker
or or the perpetrator of the abuse so
that we have some protections from the
landlord so we know that this tenant is
real where I'm having problems is the
second half of the bill would be dealing
with the person who's disabled if you
look at it it doesn't say medical
provider it just says documentation it's
very unclear as to what's going on or
what they need
and also the standard the rental
property is no longer enjoyable for use
of the tenant I don't know what that
term is supposed to mean and I think
that term has to be Rewritten and
thought out doesn't mean they don't like
the color of the bathroom paint so it's
no longer enjoyable
and obviously if someone is disabled and
not working cannot afford the apartment
the best is for everybody for this
person to leave avoid any of the
eviction process don't even have to deal
with mediation although that's not
mandatory but you know this is the type
of thing that would work out in
mediation
so what I'm suggesting to the
um committee is that
have this the second half of this bill
Rewritten make it so that there are some
real standards that we can hang our hat
on and understand that this person is
disabled not just someone coming in and
saying hey I got in a car accident I
can't walk and no doctor is opining on
it
and get some medical and get some real
reasons that there's a causal connection
between the injury and the inability to
use the apartment
thank you for allowing me to speak on
this bill
thank you sir questions for this Witness
yes representative
I'm thinking of the uh of the case of a
uh friend of mine a fellow rep who
moved to a uh one of the large rental
communities out on the Heights and I
don't think she had any problems working
things out with her landlord but she was
her disability became
worse over the several years as she's
living there and in the last uh
that she she was in that case the
apartment had some handicapped
accessible uh units and they they placed
her at once so like uh with this bill
would this bill make it easier for a
tendon whose landlord has
handicapped accessible units to uh
you know be on the have higher priority
for moving into one of those when um if
he or she becomes disabled while living
there
I don't think the bill does I mean
because the the op the option for the
tenant is to terminate if if you know
once we set up the standards of what it
is now if the landlord has an apartment
or office it of course it's up to the
negotiation between the landlord and
tenant but the only thing in the bill is
termination that's the only option
that's given
yes uh I think representative De Lorenzo
was next and I'll get to Europe
representative Lorenzo thank you Mr here
and thank you for taking my question Mr
Klein
um you mentioned
um said a verification of disability
for a tenant who wants a change right so
there is a federal reasonable
accommodation form that's um used for
housing and that would be in the house
HUD handbook I could get it online but
that has the right the right questions
to ask and the right standards and it
goes to a person's health care
professional generally a doctor or a
nurse or whatever thank you
all right a representative page I think
you had a question yeah thank you thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question
um I have a question related to the
verification it's the question I was
asking representative Reed earlier on
the federal standard which seems to be a
lower standard let me just and bear with
me
um and that required for cases of sexual
violence and domestic abuse that require
basically the person to sign an
affidavit and you had mentioned that you
thought that a strength of the bill was
that verification requirement I'm
wondering if you would agree with me
that the chances are probably low that
someone would sign an affidavit on their
own
claiming to be victims of sexual
violence or domestic abuse in order to
get out of a lease would that be fair no
I disagree with you
and thank you all right all right other
questions on that Mr chairman just
briefly very briefly I didn't
um I'm retired now but it did represent
a number of people in divorce actions
when I was practicing law and there were
a number of instances where to gain
advantage on custody and things like
that people would sign affidavits even
though it was perjury
uh to get that Advantage so I can see
somebody once out of a lease just doing
that all right very easily other
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir
all right uh uh Pamela Kiley and Rachel
Duffy
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Pamela kylig
and I am the public policy specialist at
the New Hampshire Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence uh the
Coalition is the umbrella Organization
for our 12 community-based crisis
centers who provide free and
confidential services to nearly 15 000
survivors of sexual and domestic
violence annually I'm here to speak in
support of HB 261 but have some
recommendations for some amendments that
we would like the committee to consider
um and I'm also here with my colleague
Rachel Duffy who is the coalition's
housing and economic Justice manager who
can provide some educational background
in terms of housing rights for survivors
and protections for survivors
um so again we support the overall
intent of this legislation but some
similar to some of the points that have
already been brought up by the committee
we just want to make sure that the
standard is the same regardless of the
type of housing that a survive driver
lives in and so that we're not having a
two-tiered system when it comes to those
rights regardless of whether someone is
in public or private housing
um and so I I think just briefly um and
then I'll let my colleagues speak
um we feel that
um
we'll just we feel that the um the
threshold is really high right now and
again goes against the standard on the
federal level we're worried about
potential confidentiality or safety
risks that could come with this policy
as written and there's a couple tweaks
for the definition section that we feel
need to be addressed just to make sure
everything is aligned with current
statute
um good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee uh thank you so much for
your time today I am Rachel Duffy the
housing and economic Justice manager for
the Coalition and um the Coalition has a
particular interest in HB 261 as we
interact with housing survivors in
multiple capacities the Coalition has a
HUD funded rapid re-housing program as
well as a victim of crime acts housing
first program which is administered at
our 12-member programs and we also
provide support to Sheltering services
for our member programs and oftentimes
Advocates are supporting those sheltered
clients and entering a variety of
different Housing Programs whether that
be public or private housing
everyday crisis center Advocates across
the state work with survivors and
support who are fleeing domestic
violence or trying to create safety in
their own homes and Advocates know and
understand that when housing survivors
there are exceptional considerations
that need to to be made including safety
and confidentiality
so as previously mentioned
there are some current federal housing
Protections in place specifically for
those who are in public housing and that
is uh vawa and I'd like to speak a
little bit more to how that was
structured So currently survivors of
Domestic and Sexual Violence who reside
in Housing Programs have protections
through vawa such as
bifurcation of lease they are able to
break their lease and request
essentially a transfer to a different
apartment through a public housing
agency
as mentioned too there's also the
ability to provide a self-attestation So
within this this particular bill it is
requesting for a police report or
potential restraining order and many
Survivor situations don't actually rise
to the situation where a protective
order order may be granted and so we
just feel that that threshold is quite
High vawa really is the standard
of housing practice and it was created
through the extensive input and
collaboration between victim Advocate
Community
survivors housing Advocates as well as
government agencies such as HUD so we
really do feel that there should be an
alignment between the state and federal
policy
um additionally I would like to talk
about
um
no no go ahead but just bear in mind
we're kind of getting close on time okay
yep thank you
um I think to summarize we also you know
to the point uh part two section uh B
just on the amount of time that it takes
or sorry the amount of time that a uh
Survivor has to provide notice um it's
60 days that the crime had to have
occurred within this bill and um a lot
of times survivors just need a lot more
time to accumulate evidence and they
need to seek additional Services before
that they can move forward uh to um to
go through this process and HP 261
doesn't clearly Define
confidentiality policies to the extent
that vawa does and so we would ask that
that be taken into consideration
I'm charged or something else yeah just
one more thing I'm sorry thank you Mr
chair
um just again just to speak to those
definitions um we're concerned that the
definition of household isn't broad
enough to consider roommate or
cohabitation situations if in cases of
stalking by a neighbor where only one
roommate the victim would be eligible to
break the lease and that could cause
housing Jeopardy and then additionally
we just ask that the committee consider
using the definitions that's already in
statute under RSA 540 when referring to
domestic violence in in RSA 173b there
is actually no definition for victim of
domestic abuse they're defining the
crime of domestic violence so we just
want to make sure that everything is in
alignment thank you so much questions
representative pay
yeah thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question
um this relates to the affidavit or
self-attestation requirement
um in your experience and I'm assuming
you have experience with the federal law
to what extent or what degree or what
percentage would you say when a person
is coming to you and willing to sign a
affidavit indicating they're a victim of
domestic abuse or sexual assault what
percentage of those do you believe are
truly cases that sexual assault or
domestic violence well I would say just
from the coalition's perspective we
always believe survivors we work the ad
Advocates that work directly with
survivors
we we take their word
um and we
oftentimes work with them to develop
different types of evidence that they
can put forward such as a letter of
support from an um a domestic violence
agency or a medical provider or
um you know a therapist for example so
um if it's not you know exactly a police
report or restraining order there are
other forms of self attestation but yeah
we come from the perspective of yeah
thank you representative Smith
thank you do you think it would be
possible before the end of the week for
you to provide this committee with
specific language
um that you will believe would put this
legislation in line uh in such a ways to
answer your concerns
I believe that we could do that and we
are able to submit some documentation
just around vawa and also with the soft
attestation of vowel looks like just so
that we can thank you instructure other
questions for this witness I I I'm sorry
did I no so I do have a couple of
questions
I wonder if you could you tell us
anything about
um
your knowledge of it strikes me I could
be wrong but but it strikes me
particularly giving
the housing situation right now where a
landlord is not going to have any
trouble finding a new tenant because
there's such a
can you give me some
some indication of how often does it
happen that a tenant wants to break a
lease for domestic violence and the
landlord says no
yeah so I think it it's something that
the state currently does have the um
those protections that you know once
provided a restraining order
um I don't know that I can provide
specific statistics on like the for the
survivors that may not be able to
provide that proof but I will say that
we work with thousands of survivors a
year that are needing to move and break
leases and we're needing to navigate
that
um right but you know what I just want
to make sure I'm understanding are are
you saying
um that even with private housing there
is something in the law now that says if
you provide some proof of domestic
violence you can break your lease I from
my understanding I believe it needs to
to be a protective order or a police
report of something but does that apply
to private housing if you have a
protective order you that you can break
your lease from private housing
um right now I believe that with a with
a restraining order or police report
provided to the landlord right now in
private housing that's that's the case
but yeah I know in statute there is a
provision around evictions specifically
in domestic violence sexual assault or
stalking but we can definitely Circle
back with the committee to make sure
that any new uh Provisions would be in
line with state law I we believe this is
a gap
um currently in state law
okay because I I mean I have to say I I
was not aware of that for private
housing and I guess the other question
that that raises is
you say there's a gap but I'm not if if
the law now is that if you're the victim
of domestic violence you can break your
lease even with private housing then I'm
kind of questioning what do we need this
for yeah no I think um I apologize for
the miscommunication I know in fact that
the RSA 540 refers to eviction
um protections for domestic violence
survivors in eviction cases I do not
believe it's currently in statute so we
apologize for the confusion around that
okay all right and then I just have one
one final question the other question
I'm I'm not clear on or I guess I have a
question about is to the extent you're
trying to draw an analogy between
public at what the law is with regard to
public housing and private housing I
guess
I have a question about whether that
analogy really sort of should hold
because if it's one thing to say
the public as a landlord should bear the
cost of
of you know someone who has to break a
lease because of domestic violence it's
another thing to say that a private
landlord should have to bear that cost
and
um particularly I mean the landlord
presumably is not at fault any more than
the victim is at fault so I guess my
quest why should why should the landlord
bear that risk
um and should we have should we provide
some Public Funding for that when the
landlord has to uh lose money because of
breaking of a lease being broken
the we all should pay for it as opposed
to just the landlord
thank you so much for that question and
I think that's a really um good thing
good question to unpack our position is
just that that the policy be standard
across so that survivors regardless of
their situation have the same rights
afforded to them
um but we can we'd be more than happy to
discuss um that exact issue
um so thank you thank you other
questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you thank you
both very much
um Nick Norman please
thank you
thank you again for letting for
providing me the opportunity to speak I
will attempt to be brief I know our time
is short
my David Klein already mentioned several
things that are our concerns
I want to point out that there's two
sections in this bill one is for victims
of domestic abuse and stalking and
violence and so forth and the other one
is disabling illnesses or accidents and
the provisions in those two sections are
different
if you notice that in the disabling
illness or accident section a tenant
could give as little as one day's notice
and and satisfy the con the condition
there uh we think that's you know
completely unreasonable
and I agree exactly with you Mr chairman
that we don't see why it is that the
landlord should pay the the cost for
providing
you know for for this situation and if
there is a cost we do think that there
should be some kind of Public Funding to
support that
um
we are very sympathetic to victims of
domestic violence and stalking and all
these other situations I just don't feel
like it should fall necessarily on the
landlord to pay the the costs
there are certain costs that a property
owner inquire and incurs like paying for
a management fee to place a tenant
turnover cost to get the apartment ready
and those need to be advertised over a
year
at least we should be saying that the
tenant should be required to cover the
vacancy or if the tenant can't cover the
vacancy then have the public
housing or city or or some other agency
cover that
there's the tremendous
ambiguity about what's enjoyable
I think that's
yeah
how can you have something like that in
the law I do absolutely believe that we
have to be very careful that we don't
put into law
situations that give tenants rights to
abuse the situation
and you will see unquestionably tenants
take the law and abuse it for their own
purpose I think that was asked over here
we definitely see that so I wouldn't
want to set up a system that so lacks
the tenant just hands in a document to
the the landlord and then their leases
is terminated essentially
you know right now if someone wants to
break their lease for any reason they
can just leave
they leave there's nothing really a
landlord can do about that
in fact if they leave then there is a
small provision for abandonment which
maybe they could take the apartment back
and re-rent it but small claims and
going after a person if they just break
their release and leave we call it a
midnight move out there's practically no
consequence for that on the tenant side
um
so I guess I would oh there's a couple
questions
um
now I guess what we covered it I'm happy
to take any questions any questions for
this Witness
uh I'm gonna I guess I oh I'm sorry
representative De Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Mr Norman so um
when a tenant abandons an apartment
wouldn't you use the security deposit to
cover some of the vacancy
you can use the security deposit but
it's far below the cost
when our tenant abandons an apartment
you're likely to have turnover costs
repainting maybe replacing some flooring
freshening the department up
you may have to start an eviction
on a vacant apartment just to get legal
control over it because the state does
not give us any method for retaking an
apartment that's been abandoned except
for this tiny little window of
conditions that's fairly hard to meet so
very likely you start an eviction so
there's the eviction cost that also
probably means two months vacancy
so it's a large loss that the landlord
Bears when a tenant just does a midnight
move out
thank you representative page thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question we heard prior testimony that
in situations like that involve domestic
abuse or sexual Survivor systems there's
there's a cost to the landlord when that
situation remains in the building or the
or that is that correct that is true
thank you in fact it's in the interest
of the landlord usually to work with
that tenant to to find a way to to make
it work and that's usually what happens
someone says I've got domestic violence
situation come on and so the land how
can we make this work let's work out a
deal you cover the cost let's have you
leave we'll start searching for a new
tenant you know that would be usually
the case there would be I I can't
imagine
any landlord saying no I want you to
stay in that violent situation
it's not going to happen
other question yes
but can I say that
um would it
do many victims of domestic violence
have to leave immediately
are you asking do they have to leave
immediately
face that situation where
um you've had a person that has been in
that situation and they had to meet to
leave immediately yes yeah I've been
managing for 35 years I've seen a lot
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir
uh uh Carney uh
again I got it I know
I'm talking one more time oh that's fine
um Karen pokorny from Derek and
um I hadn't originally planned on
speaking on this one but I saw it when I
arrived this morning and just felt like
it was needed to humanize this a little
bit where when you find yourself in a
situation where you're in abuse and you
finally have The Bravery to say okay I
need to get out first that that takes so
much bravery to say okay I need to leave
because a lot of the time in these
situations the person that is being
affected there's the psychological
manipulation of that no you're worthless
no you're you're you can't do it without
me no you can't and just understanding
that I know you say that landlords of
course want to help but there's a
difference between the empathy of
understanding this person's at their
last string they've decided okay it's
gone too far I really need to get out
right now and having the ability to do
so I think it's our responsibility as a
state and as a society say we're going
to limit the red tape around how they do
that and the cost to landlords shouldn't
Trump the safety and protection of the
people that are being faced with this
problem and I I find it kind of
laughable that you're saying the The
Empty Apartment is more so important
than the safety of a woman's life or a
man's life or a child's life and I think
the limiting the red tape that is needed
to be able to get yourself out of that
situation
I think it's our responsibility to do
everything that we can to make that as
easy as possible for them I'll keep it
short I just wanted to kind of humanize
this a little bit these are people's
lives and these are people who want it
it takes a ton of excuse me
um it takes a ton of Bravery to get to
the point where you're saying okay I I
need to leave and having the state be on
your side in that I think is vital and
not having to worry oh I'm going to have
an eviction on my notice or I'm going to
have this legal cut back if I do decide
to leave just having that even on your
mind you could be that one step that
prevents you from getting yourself out
of that situation and your kids out of
that situation so I just hope you keep
that in mind and I'm in support of this
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you uh uh
Brandon Lemay please
uh yes my name is Brandon Lemay from
Manchester New Hampshire representing
myself uh and I'm just here speaking in
favor of House Bill 261. I'm going to be
really brief I think a lot of others
have already gone over a lot of great
points particularly from the Coalition
so I just want to reiterate what they
said or just kind of um acknowledge that
you know the concerns that they have are
very similar concerns as to what I have
um I just wanted to point out two quick
things one is that when we're talking
about
um what I like to call Ma and PAW
landlords I feel like the landlords that
we've heard speak today are the type
that you know look their tenants in the
eyes and have real conversations with
people but I also want to mind that we
have an increasing number of corporate
landlords that are very much by the book
and are not able to really give much
leeway when it comes to things like this
they're going to want to follow the
lease they're going to want to follow
the law they're are not going to want to
make many exceptions so I just kind of
want to emphasize that like somebody
renting from again a big Corporation
I've rented from a place like Colonial
Village and there's just not a lot of
leeway that you can do when it comes to
smaller landlords
um the second point I want to make two I
just really want to emphasize the
following disability illness or accident
I feel like that's really important we
are all at risk of becoming disabled if
we're not already either through birth I
believe it's birth accident or age
so I've particularly worked with a
tenant who had a stroke
a couple years ago and he was on a third
floor walk-up and a walk-up just means
there's no elevator
and it was really difficult for him to
be able to navigate his situation there
he was told that the fire department
could pick him up three flights of
stairs every time he wants to go back
into his house
um and thankfully after a little bit
more stress than what was necessary he
was able to work something out this
landlord but again if he was renting
from a corporate landlord they might not
have been able to give the exception
that he needs in order to get out of
that lease thankfully he had a good
landlord but I like to think of tenants
who may not have you know
I think you know compassionate people as
landlords or people actually
so I'll keep that short um and I'll open
up to any questions
for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you uh
Jody Newark
or Newark Newark I guess sorry
representative Jody Newell actually
I need to improve my handwriting we'll
put it that way
um I think I'm last I like going last
because everyone else uh I got to cross
off my entire checklist of points that I
wanted to make so I'll keep it very very
brief I just want to Echo the difficulty
and the importance of reducing barriers
excuse me reducing barriers for people
leaving domestic violence situations and
how easy someone can fall into a
financial tailspin I work at a
transitional housing shelter and there
are a lot of people who come in there
who are dealing with domestic violence
situations and people who have become
handicapped and can no longer work so I
I just think it's it's important to
remember that on a human level people
fall into this very quickly and as much
as we can do to reduce barriers to
people being able to make that move when
they need to as soon as they need to I
think it's really important and I Echo
everyone else before me
all right thank you very much questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
is there anyone else who desires to
testify on House Bill 261.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that bill and um we're going
to the next bill up is 283 which is
scheduled for one o'clock I'm gonna in
order to give members of the committee
an opportunity to get some lunch I'm
going to uh uh res I'm going to postpone
that hearing until 1 15 uh pm and that
should give everybody at least at least
some some reasonable time to get
launched uh thank you all very much
we're recessed
all right
um it's uh one
it's 1 17. I said we're going to start
at 1 15 so we're going to start
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 283 and represent recognize
representative uh Reed the prime sponsor
of the bill
thank you again
welcome Mr chair and honorable members
for 75 through my bills for today anyway
um so this is a super simple uh Bill the
uh there was a bill last year that was
more complex and
um objectionable but this simply limits
and there's an extra piece that I will
speak to but this limits the application
fees that landlords charge for
prospective tenants to 35 or the cost of
running the background check whichever
is less
um 15 at least 15. I think there might
be more now other states have passed
similar uh similar laws ranging from
like 10 or 25 dollars to like 55 dollars
so 35 was really a good in between
there's some states that don't that
absolutely prohibit
application fees the reason that this is
a problem now
is because of the situation the housing
crisis once again there's really
no uh real reason that someone even has
to rent out their property at this point
because there are credit or not credit
but application fees that are going into
the hundreds of dollars and if you have
some pretty pictures of a property up
online you can just sit back and take in
those application fees and be happy as a
clan without ever having to worry about
a tenant or anything else in fact
there's anecdotal stories of this very
thing happening so really simple just
limited at 35 are the cost of the
background check a lot of other states
have have limited to it to cost as well
so I just did an either or situation
to kind of kind of get right in the
middle of what other states are doing
then there was a last minute Edition
because I and I think we'll have
testimony speaking to this but I became
aware of a phenomenon that's been
happening recently
um of holding fees so holding fees are
in addition to the application fee and
can be from what I understand north of
even a thousand dollars and talk about
not having to rent out your property at
all so the holding fees are not only
exorbitant and increasingly so but also
um not refundable so what I said is that
any additional fee so you know whether
you call it holding fee or whatever
other fee you might call it any
additional fee is capped at 250 and has
to be refundable but the actual
application fee is not refundable that's
a major difference between my bill and
the previous bill
um having said that short simple sweet
and I'm happy to take questions
for this week representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative I'm looking at so I know
the 35 or cost of conducting a
background check does the background
check have to be conducted at all or
would you just so so with that in mind
could you just you know have 20 people
you know I'm thinking 20 times 35 that's
700 a month that wouldn't necessarily
solve the problem of there's nowhere
going for 700 at least not my neck of
woods you would be hard-pressed to find
a place going for twice that right now
so um so yeah 35 is is pretty reasonable
but I mean pretty safe to prevent that
problem that I was describing but 250 is
not so if you had 10 people apply a
month for your place you would have
twenty five hundred dollars a month and
never have to do a single thing
other questions for this Witness
oh this was the easy way
it's so close very close
my only question was this in the um
in the scenario you you sort of posited
about a landlord who decides to
that they don't really care about
running the property they're just going
to sort of
you know propose like they want to rent
it and then collect all these fees if if
if so if a landlord were actually to do
that couldn't they be sued for fraud
that you that you've you've had you've
said you want to rent this property but
you really don't oh I I imagine that
they could be sued for fraud but I mean
again you have to realize that those
types of legal recourses are available
to people who usually aren't renting
anyway they're homeowners that never
encounter this sort of thing if you're
in the rental market if you're trying to
find housing by renting first of all
that's a lot of bandwidth that you're
already expending you're not looking
into secondly how would you ever know
that they didn't rent it out like you're
not continuing to pursue that place
you're you're actively looking for a
place to live and if you're not getting
accepted there you're looking elsewhere
and once you get a place to live you're
no longer looking anymore so you'd be
very unlikely to be able to prove that
they intentionally were you know not
rinsing the place out and then thirdly
then you'd have to go get and hire a
lawyer and then you'd have to prove some
sort of standing of like well how did
this actually hurt you just because you
didn't get this place so I it would be
it is I would say a fairly safe practice
although probably illegal or maybe
illegal or maybe subjected to criminal
or sorry civil action it's still pretty
safe for landlords to be able to get
away with something like that
other questions for this representative
Perez
thank you
do you have any idea what the fees that
the actual landlord would incur if he
was um
if you had people say we have we have a
management company so if I'm a landlord
with management company what are the
fees that they would incur I mean 35
dollars I mean I just had a background
check for Second Amendment stuff and it
was forty three dollars for the
background check so that could be
separate and then I had to fill out some
paperwork that was additional money so
do we know what how much the landlord
landlords are paying each time someone
applies for an apartment so I'm not sure
about the kinds of like maybe federal
level or multi-level background checks
that maybe gun stores might require
um but or if they're charging an
additional administrative fee if they're
charging that fee on to you but uh in
general anyone can kind of use a number
of online services and they usually
range between 10 and 15 online in my
experience
um however people who are in the
business of having to run frequent
background checks usually have a
subscription to a service which makes it
cheaper per person
well other questions for this Witness
oh
yes representative stapled
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
that's quite something
um that you mentioned a new phenomenon
of holding fees
I suppose there could be option fees the
phenomenon of fees today is they pop up
with all kinds of nice names and I see
from your text to your bill you say any
other fee charged by the landlord as
part of the rental application process
shall be refundable
so any other fees could be anything
fee nature other than security deposit
or first month's rent or so is that
right
right I don't know how that got turned
off
um so that's the thing is that this
whole new phenomenon of holding fees
just kind of crept up and or you know it
may have existed in some limited form in
the past but it's become again was zero
percent vacancy all of the power is in
the hands of the people who own the
property and not the people trying to
secure a roof over their head and
because of that they're able to kind of
take advantage of any number of schemes
like a holding fee and charge hundreds
and like I said in some instances it
sounds like over a thousand dollars so
the whole point is that yes you can
charge an extra fee if there's a
reasonable you know reason to need to do
that but it needs to be beyond the
actual background check and credit check
it needs to be refundable so we're not
trying to remove anything you know
everything and everything from landlords
but we we after some discussion we
decided that there's really probably no
situation where 250 dollars wouldn't
cover whatever they might need to have
in terms of a holding fear any other fee
but yeah the idea is that's any other
fee because we understand that they can
name things whatever they want to name
other ques yes representative
yeah uh thanks and and thanks uh
representative Reed quick question on
the fixed dollar amounts um it just
always sort of worries me to have fixed
dollar amounts and things that hopefully
will stay on the books for a long time
and
um what are your thoughts on that versus
like a percentage and and I guess that
would also in my mind open the door to
if this was a very high dollar you know
unit that was being rented could they
potentially charge more because maybe
there's a higher higher process involved
in in vetting so I I guess I'm saying
you know percentage versus as fixed
dollar amount I mean I'm fine with the
percentage if that's what this uh
committee would prefer like I said I
looked at the 15 states and they're
probably more now that had already
passed something and this seemed to be
right in the middle of the the span of
what they were doing some states do do a
percentage I would suggest something
like five percent in our current housing
market that sounds about right
um but there are percentages there are
some states that ban the application fee
altogether there are states that have uh
25 their states that have 35 dollars
fifty five dollars
um and then there are states that just
say the cost you cannot charge more than
what it costs so I wanted to kind of be
in the middle and cover all my bases so
that's why because I also hesitate to do
fixed dollar amounts or fixed numbers at
all in any of my legislation for the
very reasons that you suggested I like
formulas better so that's why I said or
the cost of actually doing the
background check
other question yes representative
Andrews
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question do you have a link
that you could send the whole committee
so that we could look how different
states go out I'm very happy to send
that along in fact I do think that you
already for one of my co-sponsors since
along that information to the committee
already with the comprehensive list of
and there are also a bunch of cities
across the country that also do this if
home rule states where the cities are
allowed to do it
um that have already that do similar
things but just for those 15 states that
I I mentioned that list is already
should be in your your testimony already
yeah other question representative
Oregon
yes thank you you uh you testified that
the actual cost is
much less than 35 dollars in most cases
and I've seen ads to that effect um but
do you feel that perhaps this 35 is
actually more than the cost so that
should be a regionally inflation proof
uh price at least for the next few years
obviously if inflation goes well if it's
too low then at some point this
legislation will have to raise a fee
which of course is virtually very very
difficult to do but does happen
sometimes but but you think in the short
run this is a reasonable reasonable
amount to a set as the limit indeed I um
I do especially not only can you find a
number of services right now just by
Googling that provide it for a very low
cost less much less than 35
but uh the the so you could triple that
number over inflation and still be
capped at that 35 and still have the
cost covered
other questions for this witness I'll
just add to that that you know at some
point there is a cost of doing business
for every industry right there's just
costs of doing business and while you
find you want to make sure you recoup
those costs but sometimes you can't
recoup it you know one for one you just
have to absorb it in the overall
um business that you're conducting so
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you
and
um again I'm just coming at this as a
young person that's trying to survive in
this state and as someone who's
personally gone through trying to find
an apartment in the state and and it's
nearly impossible guys like it you
really for the cost of living that we're
at in the amount of savings that you
have to do just to get that first month
second month security deposit and then
if you have to put in for 10 11 15
different apartments and the cost to put
in these fees are fifty dollars it's
just not doable for someone my age like
singly trying to find a place we're just
not making an attainable for young
people to stay in this state and last
time I checked you guys were elected by
the voters of the state and not the
landlords and it seems like you're
protecting the landlord's rights more
than your constituents and when 50 of
the youth are still living at their
parents home because they can't afford a
place to live and we question why the
raising rates of age in the state is
going up and up and up where are we
going to be in 15 years when we've
pushed out every young person that wants
to stay in the state I was raised here I
love this state more than anything and
I've worked my butt off to try to stay
here because I do love it but it it's
the legislation that we have in now is
not protecting people like me it's
protecting landlords it's protecting the
business it's not protecting your
constituents and frankly I'm getting a
little tired of it because it just at
the cost of living where we're at now
with the vacancy rates that we're at now
you're not just applying to one place
it's not 150 application fee it's 15 and
when you're getting a profit from that
it it just doesn't seem fair and for me
it feels like what you guys's job is is
to make sure that you're protecting your
constituents from misuse from
corporations and that's not being done
right now it seems like your interest is
in protecting the landlords and I just
really hope that this does pass because
I I really do feel like this is
something that's really preventing young
people from having a fair share a fair
shot at finding a place especially with
the vacancy rates that they're at now
um I mean I live with my mom in my 20 my
31 year old sister lives there my 39
year old brother lives there because we
can't find a place to live and I've been
looking for the last two years and over
the last two years I put in over 25
applications that really does add up and
when you're barely keeping your head
above water I worked three jobs guys
three jobs and I cannot afford a place
to live in this state
that's not right it's not right so I
just honestly I beg of you just we got
to put in more legislation that's
supporting the working people of the
state because right now there's no
protections so thank you questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir uh
nick uh Norman
thank you very much again for an
opportunity to speak
and the landlord community no probably
not surprising to you would be against
this bill
the testimony that I just handed out
looks to me like there is a cut and
paste error in there so I just want to
highlight that in the second paragraph
it starts out saying this bill is
clearly a restraint on service right to
sell property that's got to be about a
different bill I don't know how I ended
up in there
so the 35 dollars is appears to be an
arbitrary number it doesn't reflect
necessarily actual cost it could be
actual cost in some cases but it
certainly would not take into account
the amount of time effort
spent on processing an application a
landlord can easily spend a few hours
processing an application
and besides the credit report you know
the landlord would also get a landlord
tenant report some landlords get a
criminal report Which is far more money
some landlords hire a professional
service
realtors that might property manage for
them and that that cost could be greater
there's only a portion of the
applications that could get denied
so on personally I don't see what you're
hearing being testified in terms of this
gigantic
wave of people applying for apartments
it's people standing in lines I don't
see that in my company at all we manage
48 units I do see that the market is
strong I do see that
um
there's greater demand than there is
Supply
but I would say it's unusual that I have
more than one or two people applying for
an apartment when we do have someone
applying for an apartment we process
that application within one day
and one of those people gets the
apartment
it would be really rare for us to deny
um
an application or to deny multiple
applications unless the tenant is
actually falsifying the the application
and that does happen it happens quite
frequently
and so I certainly would not want to put
in a law that says the tenant that's
falsifying their application
once the landlord discovers that then
gets their money back
and this says additional fees would be
returned
and there could be certainly additional
fees for discovering all of that um I'm
verifying what what's false and what's
true
the term background check is very
ambiguous we're not sure what that means
there's a portion in there that talks
about penalties
the penalties are completely
unreasonable or what we're talking about
we're talking about application fees
that could range from what I commonly
see
certainly below fifty dollars
and we're talking about penalties of a
thousand dollars and court costs and
attorneys fees it's just totally
unreasonable
I think that covers the bulk of what I
wanted to say let me just look
you know if a tenant is having trouble
with losing application fees they can
talk to the lender they're applying for
and go over their situation find out the
landlord's criteria
and see if they're a match before they
apply
there should be no reason to be wasting
application fees
we usually do that all right our
applicants I think he's really happy to
take questions questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you uh David Klein please
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is David Klein a
couple couple of points I do reiterate
uh what Nick said about the actual cost
the 35 is arbitrarily picked because of
the states are doing it it really does
cost more to do it depending upon the
reports in the time of staffed to
confirm employment and confirm prior
landlords we have had
in our instances people who put down
Employments they've never worked there
landlords they've never lived with
I do have a real problem with this not
being indexed for inflation any of us
who lived through the Jerry Ford Jimmy
Carter years know how hard that
inflation got we have this horrendous
situation in Ukraine we don't know what
the future is going to be to lock us
down to a number now that may take years
to change if at all would be impossible
we've tried to change the 15 fee for
service the demand for rents and
eviction notices no one's you know the
tennis groups yell and scream the 15
doesn't cover the cost of the labor just
preparing the forms anymore given what
how what labor costs are
um this statute because it's part of
540A violations of 548 become violations
of the consumer protection statute I
apologize I don't have the number four
and it's in the 300s 358 358. thank you
carries 350. hey I guess I should say
I think you're right Mr chairman it
carries a minimum penalty of a thousand
dollars up to three thousand dollars and
attorneys fees so that if a small
landlord doesn't know that this is in
fact and and that happens a lot and
that's one of the reasons why landlords
try to band together you make a five
dollar error you could be stuck with a
three thousand dollar fine and plus the
attorney's fees that's worse than uh if
you shoplifted the five dollars except
for you don't have face jail time so the
the penalties are pretty severe for what
this is and I think it that they should
be toned down at least maybe just make
it a flat 500 all fee if you're going to
do that but I think that incorporating
in the consumer protection statute is
way above board
also that same statute if you have these
holding fees and you're taking them
fraudulently a prospective tenant could
probably use that and get their
attorney's fees from the landlord who
did that because I don't know what
holding fees are I mean our practice was
a deposit toward the security deposit
and all of it we've paid over to the
security deposit
now the management company is just
taking the security deposit in advance
for
finally Mr Carney I have trouble with
this name also he said something that I
just want to correct we are prohibited
from taking anything in terms of rent
and security deposit more than one
month's rent and one month's security
deposit in the rsas he talked about
taking two months rent I don't know
where he came up with that but that is
not a legal practice in the state of New
Hampshire
I'm open for any questions questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you
um next uh viola
katsamine am I pronouncing that
correctly
I got I got it right all right
[Laughter]
thank you for the opportunity to speak
uh for the record my name is Viola
katsina and I'm here
I'm here representing the granite state
organizing project we are a graduate
organization that's based in Manchester
and we bring people together to work
towards uh social justice and economic
Justice and he had expressed our support
for HB 283 and the reason why we're
supporting this bill is that gsop opened
up at tenant Clinic uh after the
pandemic hit and we've been helping
tenants on a daily basis deal with
renovation evictions which is the bill
that's going to come up later but I just
wanted to share that we hear stories on
a daily basis from people who uh whose
application fees range from 35 to 95 and
these are people that are already
struggling to put together money for
rent uh they already have housing costs
that include moving and also like
struggling to make basically so I'm here
to share that that amount is pretty high
for a lot of the tenants to deal with
and if you are going through the
application process this money is
required before the application process
even has already gone through so you
have to you have to pay the money before
it's processed and in most cases some of
them do get rejected because of their
income qualifications and that triggers
them to apply to another place which
requires another application fee so at
the end of the date adds up for families
and for renters with a high cost of rent
that we've had all day today uh with a
cost of moving and just the basic living
costs in New Hampshire I think this is
uh a right thing to do to protect tennis
and also to make sure that the landlords
get covered for the course that they
have to in car but also uh basically
tenants are not
um charge excessive fees so that's all I
have to say and thank you for the
opportunity are there questions for this
witness yes representative Devine thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um
are applicant application fees in other
states generally prohibited
I actually I'm not quite sure about what
other states are but I believe that
previous speaker who's the uh Reverend
sorry representative uh Ellen reads uh
don't worry my friend but uh
um she spoke a little bit about that and
she had some information to provide so
I'm not I can't speak to that matter
okay maybe we could get some information
sent to us on that matter thank you
right other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you uh Jessica
margason please
foreign
good afternoon my name is Jessica
marteson I'm a tenant organizer with
Granite State organizing project I am
here on my own behalf though to speak
out on this bill
um I am completely for it a lot of my
tenants that come in the tenant Clinic
they are faced with having to apply for
multiple Apartments as we know about the
um
sorry the word just slipped my mind we
know about the tendency rate being low
when it concerns an apartment that's
under 1600 when you're looking at
affordable what I hear from real estate
agents or landlords is that they get
multiple calls multiple applications
it's normally the apartments that are um
much more expensive that are out of that
realm of being able to afford for low
income they get fewer applications they
get through the process a little better
but when you have a few hundred people
applying for only a few apartments that
can get up there I've had to teach my
clients to when they're looking on
Zillow or these other sites just scroll
down and take a look at how many
applications have been put in on that
one apartment you'll commonly see you
can see some zeros but you'll see 15 17
and sometimes up to a hundred
so when you're charging an application
fee on one apartment you got one spot
and you take in a hundred applications
you start to start making money on this
part of the application process when it
becomes an amount sometimes us tenants
feel that these apartments are just
there to generate income on applications
because the numbers climb so high when
you're faced with having to do
five to ten applications in one month
that takes away from money that you're
going to be able to move with honestly
we wish that there was some type of
process you could go through and
get your verification done and then you
could take that from place to place and
use it someday hopefully that bill will
come along but one thing that should be
added into this bill is clarification on
time of the return of the deposit the
250 dollars that was mentioned as a Max
and it would be applied to the deposit
or refunded clarification on that time
needs to be in there so that
um both sides have an understanding of
when to expect that money and when to
return it by
thank you very much questions for this
Witness
thank you seeing none thank you very
much uh uh Brandon Lemay please
hello uh my name is Brandon Lemay from
Manchester uh and I am here speaking in
favor of HB 283 uh I just want to
clarify a question that was brought up
earlier
um about uh other rental application fee
laws uh in the country in Massachusetts
it's actually illegal to charge an
application fee
however a landlord could not run to the
apartment under the basis of wanting to
submit a background check first
so the way that I see this is that
application fees could be avoided
altogether if this included language
saying that hey a tenant might have to
pay for a background check once they're
approved for the apartment depending you
know certain terms
um so
yeah I just want to emphasize that there
are other New England states that do
regulate what you can actually charge or
can you charge an application fee at all
um the second thing and my final Point
here is uh I work with a lot of low to
Middle income tenants uh there's one
tenant who's actually unfortunately at
work today I wish I could have brought
her up
um but back in 2021 she had to apply for
no fewer than 12 apartments and had over
300 in application fees
and it's really demoralizing when you
have to Shell up money that you probably
don't have to get a place that you might
not even be able to live in
so it's really prohibitive and you have
to selectively apply to Apartments
especially when the uh the vacancy rate
is so low
so
I think that there's a huge problem and
there have been other stories of
landlords who show empty Apartments
uh for the prospect of charging them
application fees so
in my belief I believe that perhaps
there should be some sort of fee maybe
after you've been accepted pending any
sort of like serious uh any sort of
serious like things on the record or
previous evictions
uh but I feel like this is a reasonable
Bill uh 35 is a reasonable amount to pay
for an application fee that can get you
most of a background check and a credit
score check uh so I don't find this to
be um completely out there so I hope
that you uh vote ought to pass and I'll
take any questions all right questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir all
right thank you
that's the last card I have is there
anyone else here who wishes to testify
on uh HB 283
oh I'm sorry yes please
did you
okay well you why don't you you can
testify and then would you just submit a
card after you're done thank you
hi everybody hello this is really
uncomfortable for me so I'm going to
read my um testimony I hope you don't
mind
um
I feel very strongly about this so I'm
here and willing to testify
um my name is Julie Smiley um I'm a
housing Advocate and a property manager
with the front door agency in Nashua New
Hampshire and I also serve on an
advocacy committee that the agency has
so we assist individuals and families
who are struggling with housing
stability most of them on the brink of
homelessness we provide financial
assistance some case management and run
a transitional housing program for young
single mothers all to help prevent
homelessness
in the past few years we have seen this
housing crisis Skyrocket when people
talk about it a housing crisis it's it's
no joke
in a typical month our agency receives
about 10 applications for assistance in
December this year we received 45 and so
far in January we've received over 35.
both the number of applicants and the
level of Crisis we see is worsening
significantly those on fixed incomes are
hardest hit especially those forced from
their homes due to a property sale
people are facing multiple barriers in
securing housing one of those being
application fees and or hold fees there
are not always refundable I've received
reports from clients of fees up to 250
dollars generally we do not have the
capacity to assist with those fees so I
contacted rep Ellen Reid and requested
some help on the legislative front and
you can imagine that with a .06 percent
vacancy rate for rentals property
managers are receiving upwards of 20
applications per apartment we work with
landlords all of the time and they're
frequently telling us they are
absolutely inundated with applications
for every single unit they're renting so
they can make quite the income from fees
that they charge
um while it's just another one of many
significant barriers for our low-income
neighbors we're regularly seeing people
in New Hampshire forced into
homelessness through no fault of their
own but for the rising costs of property
shelters are full funds for hotels are
limited and people are being evicted
from encampments passing HB 283 would
allow property managers to recoup some
of their costs for doing business with
minimal negative impact while it would
have a significant positive impact on
one of the barriers to housing stability
um I do want to mention that refereed
did email you all info on fees in other
states many states do not charge fees
many limit them and I can attest to the
fact that many people are prohibited
just from applying for an apartment
simply because if they can't afford the
fees never mind the rent so happy to
take any questions questions for this
witness yes representative Qatar
so you stated that this Bell would still
allow landlords to recoup some of their
fees but I'm a little bit confused
because the way that I'm reading this is
that
these fees have to be refundable so how
are they recouping the fees if they have
to give them all back so the um
background check fees are not refundable
it would be hold fees I believe
um I don't have a copy of it it's the
hold fees would a refundable the
application fee for the background check
which is at 35 or the cost of the
background check is not refundable
according to this bill
other questions yes representative Perez
thank you
why are these people when they apply and
they do not
obtain the apartment are they told why
they didn't qualify for the apartment
not necessarily no not when landlords
are receiving up to upwards of 20
applications they they don't even reach
out to them if you apply for a job you
don't always get a you know a reason why
you were turned down it's the same with
when you apply for an apartment so it's
simply it's business one apartment and
there's multiple applicants with the
vacancy rate being virtually zero right
now
so it's not that they're not able to get
the apartment or afford the apartment
they're just lost in line yeah so you've
got one apartment 20 30 40 applicants
and only one person is going to get that
apartment
thank you other questions for this
Witness
oh representative mine yes thank you
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um when a landlord I'm just trying to
get this wrap my head around this when a
landlord is receiving maybe up to 10
applications with a 35 dollar fee and
they start to run through it this person
qualifies this person qualifies this
person qualifies do they just stop do
they stop at the first one and then go
through the process or do they go
through all 10 applications with the 35
dollar fee and then you know
take that and and then do they give the
money back if they decide on one
person to take the apartment sure so I
think that probably varies from landlord
to landlord as to how much time and
effort they want to invest in vetting
their various applicants
um but the fees can be upwards of 35
sometimes it's fifty dollars
um so this bill is sort of it's trying
to put a limit on what the fee what the
limit on the fee is
um was there a second part to your
question well I would move to change
that you know like I'm thinking about
this 35 fee and I'm I'm thinking that
you know the landlord is is taking in
this income they're they're offering a
rental property if they do vet the
person shouldn't they be doing their due
diligence to kind of look through the
the applications first before they use
the 35 to pay for you know something
that maybe
um a potential renter cannot afford and
they're just seeing seems like this this
I don't know it does it just doesn't
work for me I'm thinking take take away
the whole 35 dollars take away the cost
put the put the um the um cost on to the
landlord for that fee because they're
offering a service to the community and
to me that bill might work a little bit
better
so you're you're suggesting no fees no
fees at all so we were trying to appease
I believe landlords and allow them to
recoup some of their costs but I would
be in favor of no fees and I believe
other states such as Vermont
um do not and possibly Massachusetts do
not charge fees at all for this reason
so and then the last part would be as an
alternative to landlords they would have
to be if you kept the bill in place as
it was the landlord would have to have
some sort of accountability as to how
many applications they would be seeing
and viewing and using that 35 or more
whatever they're charging there has to
be some accountability here and this
bill here does not demonstrate that in
my opinion
I think there's definitely room for
amendments in the middle
um
other other questions for this Witness
uh so I guess I just have a question are
do you have any concern that to the
extent you this bill limits
the um
the the the ability of a of a landlord
to charge fees for rental applications
to the extent landlords feel as a result
of that they feel less secure in who
they get for tenants that the way they
will account for that insecurity is that
they'll just raise the rents the rents
the rents will just be you you're you
can't charge more than 35 dollars for a
rental application and the landlord says
uh well not now I feel less secure in
who I'm going to have for tenants so the
rent goes up I'm not sure that I
understand that the cost of the
application equates to a quality of the
applicant
um they would be able to submit a
background check and the cost for the
background check whatever that is is
covered in the bill and there's always a
cost to doing business and right now
landlords have their pick of applicants
and are generally taking the people with
the highest incomes and so those people
on Lower incomes people who are
receiving housing vouchers are
effectively blocked from from renting on
the market quite frequently and then
this application fee that's charged
um on top of that is another barrier and
I think the 35 of the the bill covers 35
or the cost of a background check so I
think that should give the landlord
whichever the bill says whichever is
less so 35 is the cap okay okay
um I think that that covers the general
cost of a background check we serve as
property managers ourselves I manage
eight affordable housing units
um and we pay 25 for a background check
and I would also like to mention that
herd has recently issued guidance that
background checks should actually
they're recommending people don't do
background checks
um which seems a little bizarre to us as
property managers but that seems like
the way things are going and that was
their guidance at a recent training
so I think there's plenty of
opportunities for landlords to properly
vet their applicants and given their
vacancy rate they can cert they are most
certainly doing that very well thank you
other questions yes representative
greeson thank you Mr Sharon thank you
for answering our questions ma'am
would it be acceptable
that if uh
fees no fees may be charged unless an
application has been accepted for review
and then the lease would be tentative to
awaiting the results of that background
check which can include a credit check
criminal background check their tenancy
record then collection of those fees
would occur at least signing
and then the landlord would have to
disclose the amount of those fees prior
to receipt of an application so that the
tenant is going to know going in it's
going to cost me X number of dollars to
eat to apply I'm going to have to pay
for it at some point in time so they
decide I'm going to fill out the
application I'm going to submit the
application the landlord takes the
application does the background checks
and now they can charge that fee
so they would charge
not only the person they're renting to
but whoever they might consider the
people whose application they accept no
only the person they can only collect a
fee from the person who you've accepted
the application from and are going to
lease the unit too
so somebody goes out and puts out a
thousand applications they're only going
to pay
one fee to wherever they sign the lease
I I think from a somebody that
represents tenants that would be
favorable as a property manager
we may want to not incur the cost of a
background check on three or four
applicants wow it's one or the other
isn't it
sorry it's one or the others let's not
turn this let's not I'm not debating I'm
just it's one or the other it's either
the landlords or the tenants right
representative Horgan did you have a
question
um yes
I guess based on uh
since you've your experienced on both
sides that the landlord tenant divide
also renting out of affordable
apartments which are probably still not
not all that affordable but still
um but uh obviously less than what the
market rate Apartments do you find find
this difficult to cover all the various
overhead charges that are you know part
of your business or do you find that
you're able to pay for it fairly easily
out of the rent and
we receive various grants and funding so
um we the rents that we charge which are
minimal and they're usually monitored by
Hud under the home program so they're
very closely regulated but yes we I mean
we would be happy with a very nominal
fee charged I'm concerned that landlords
will oppose this bill in Force if they
are prohibited from receiving any
recompense for the fees they incur
um but I do there's has to be something
done because there are so many barriers
right now two people finding housing
this crisis I've spoken to three people
in the three hours I was in my office
this morning that was sleeping in their
car
today it's snowing and there is no room
in the shelters and they can't afford a
hotel
and if whatever we can do
to ameliorate this crisis needs to be
done and whatever it is it's a little
too little too late at this point
um you know I speak to people daily who
are in tears
and it's really frustrating that as a
state we're seeing this level of Crisis
and we need to do whatever is in our
power to help alleviate the crisis
There's real people today sleeping in
their cars who have jobs and who are
working and have lost their housing so I
would just ask that we do something to
make this process a little easier what
the specifics are like being put on the
spot at the very minute I'd need some
time to really kind of consider it
um I'm not I don't write legislation so
I don't know the legal specifics of it
but happy to answer any more questions
because this is a really really really
important issue right now questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
oh yeah and you're going to give us the
pink card right thank you
anyone else who desires to testify on HP
seeing none I'm gonna close the hearing
on HB 283
and open the hearing on HB 340.
cash
action okay
and hang on
let me just
look up here three all right and I'm
going to call on representative aguton
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
rep Josh hatcherton I represent the town
of Enfield and the New Hampshire house
and I'm here today excited to bring you
HB 340 a bill that I have dubbed the
save our homes act and I'd like to
explain the bill on a cosmic level by
reading from an op-ed that I submitted
to New Hampshire Business review about
it last fall
on June 11 2021 you know we can I mean
we can read the editorial if you want to
I'm not sure that it's not that's not
word for word okay all right go ahead
uh on June 11 2021 the Fox News YouTube
channel posted a clip of their host
Tucker Carlson talking about a
little-known but very impactful
Corporation BlackRock Tucker a man I
disagree with 99 of the time spoke about
how BlackRock is slowly but surely
gobbling up homes in many parts of
America by outbidding families looking
to buy them why would a venture capital
firm offer two hundred thousand dollars
over the asking price for homes
guaranteeing they win the bid once they
own the home they can rent it forever
making far more in profits and they do
according to an article posted in the
Atlantic a quarter of all single-family
homes went to landlords aspiring Airbnb
tycoons and other types of investors all
told nearly a third of American house
sales last year went to people who had
no intention of living in them
this type of manufactured scarcity and
consolidation drives up the cost of
owning a home inflating selling prices
leads other Home sellers to raise their
prices to pull in more money and who
wouldn't want an extra two hundred
thousand dollars when selling their home
but there's something else that we're
giving away by allowing these massive
corporate conglomerates to buy up all of
America's homes and rent them to the end
of time and see American Dream
for the last several Generations
Americans have relied on single-family
homes to build a nest egg for retirement
and nowadays I wouldn't count on a
social security check given what a fit
Congress through about veterans benefits
last year
they allow you to build equity they're a
place to raise a family they allow your
kids to stay in the same Community long
enough to make friends get involved with
their local community center and save
them the experience of moving every year
as often has to happen with Apartments
they provide family stability homes
build communities
if you're hearing this ask your kids if
they or people they think or people
their age think that home ownership will
ever be in their grasp and the answer
you're probably going to get is no
this is a tragedy in the wealthiest
nation in the world where we are blessed
by abundance and opportunity but it's
our responsibility to defend that
opportunity
that's why I brought this bill before
you today the bill is simple
real estate on which single-family
housing including single-family housing
with one or more accessory dwelling
units on the same parcel of land or
multi-family housing is located may only
be acquired in whole or in part by
natural persons subject to the following
exceptions in basic terms the bill will
require single-family homes to be sold
to a real living breathing person not a
venture capital firm not a venture
capital firm putting on the Groucho Marx
disguised and pretending to be an LLC
nothing
there's a grandfathering exception
provided that the next buyer is a
natural person
there's a development exception provided
that the property is sold to a natural
person within two years and there's a
clarification that this will have no
impact on mortgages or trusts
I and the other co-sponsors believe it
is important to keep family homes for
families we believe that passing this
law will help reduce and eliminate
homelessness in our time we will not
allow soulless conglomerate corporations
to deny anybody the American dream we
feel now is the time to do this for if
there were to be another 2008 style
housing crash Banks would be desperate
to make up their money making it
extremely convenient for companies like
BlackRock to swoop in overbid take the
homes and rent them forever
when New Hampshire makes the save our
homes Act of 2023 the law of the land we
will be saying loudly and firmly that we
prioritize real people over corporations
and we believe in a New Hampshire and in
America where home ownership is a
reality and that the American dream May
so endure for another generation
so that is this legislation on the
cosmic level I would encourage the
committee to move it to the house
Florida to pass or with an amendment if
you see fit and I'm happy to take any
questions questions for this Witness
I don't see any I guess I have only one
question sir have you given any thought
to the issue of weather if I mean if we
were to pass this it would be
constitutional to say basically
corporations who are citizens can't own
property
I I I I I would struggle to
um
argue constitutional merits with the
chair given your background
um but what what I would say to that is
as I thought of that
um
when making
constitutional arguments you are able to
call them whether or not something is a
um public policy priority
um and I would say like based on the
scope of the issue that we're dealing
with which I believe is in essence the
American dream
um that a court would find it
constitutional
um based on those kind of broader public
concerns thank you other questions
representative Devine
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um when you're referring to like Airbnb
properties you know like you have a
house it has you know maybe three
bedrooms it has bunk beds in one room
you know it's all set up for somebody to
come and rent especially up in say you
know the Lakes Region of this or by the
ocean somewhere how do you think this
bill is going to affect that you you had
mentioned Airbnb and I'm not I'm not
sure I can follow you on that so so I
just I didn't want to break the quote in
that article so that's the only reason
why those words were in there because
the quote from the article is
um all told yada yada yada a quarter of
single-family Household Sales went to
landlords really I could have cut it off
there but I just wrote the rest of that
in their aspiring airbn tycoons and
other types of investors all told nearly
a third of American house sales last
year so that was the only reason why
that little snippet was in there just to
get that whole Atlantic article into
quote uh without having to break that
but it doesn't really apply to this okay
I have a
um so how would this affect like you
know property management companies who
are taking care of maybe
um second-hand homes that are being
rented out
um in this state how would this Bill
affect that
property management companies well if
they're only maintaining it they're not
owning it then that would be a separate
distinction uh well if they do own it
well then I mean if it's ownership then
if they're if they're currently owning
it its grandfathered provided that the
next buyer of that home is a natural
person but the point here and I this
bill was a long formula process there
were a bunch of us that met last year in
order to try to find a way around this
and the problem that we ran into with
situations like that is why I haven't
hear you know the LLC
um or the conglomerate pretending to be
an LLC like if if you really try to
narrow cast exceptions that far down
then you're gonna create more
opportunities where the bill is
essentially swiss cheese like there are
so many holes in it that it doesn't
really match up
um so that's that issue there
other questions for this Witness
yeah yes representative Tripp oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'll get you I'll get to
you next representative representative
Tripp
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question uh
I the bill is basically to prevent uh
corporations from buying uh buying up
homes is that correct yes uh
is an aspiring short-term rental Tycoon
it's probably a family are they uh
Corporation
is a family Incorporation
yeah
no so would this bill prevent a family
from buying two or three houses
for uh no because they would be
considered a natural persons
under the definition
I I think I'm confused by the question
well I
I'm just trying to clarify you know what
is
you know if if a family is is looking to
to build a company you know by buying up
homes and renting them out you know does
does that qualify them as a company or
as a family if they did it under an LLC
then yes
Mr chair while I have the opportunity
can I provide a little context as to
where some of this language came from
sure so uh there was legislation
um that this is largely modeled off of
that came out of Iowa
um that intended to stop
um International corporate entities from
purchasing homes you have a lot of
problems in cities like New York and San
Francisco and other High real estate
areas where foreign Nationals
um are just buying a property and
they're not owned by Americans they're
not
um
they're not owned by American entities
um so that's where a lot of this
language came from this wasn't just us
kind of freewheeling it
um we did pull it from there with some
obvious uh changes
um but that's sort of the background
here uh natural persons was defined in
that statute uh and we would be looking
to carry that over here all right
representative Turner you had a question
uh I do thanks Mr chairman uh thanks
um for taking questions
um I guess my question relates to sort
of the presence of the home versus the
sort of livability of the home in my
town we have Route 125 which is you know
rapidly becoming a highway but it also
has many residential homes and many of
those that are on that road are
you know have an old home on it that's
clearly not being used anymore and
someone is holding that property waiting
for you know conditions to be right to
develop it most likely as you know uh
retail or or some sort of corporate
space What would this do in that in in
the case of of a property that has a
home on it but that home is really not
livable or occupied any longer
um I'm not sure that well it's no longer
occupiable I'm not sure that they would
be able to sell it
um
trying to find we are in the legislation
I mean as as far as it pertains to
development we do have
um one of the exceptions in here being a
development Clause
um so companies would be able to
purchase purchase those provided that
they register with the Secretary of
State
um and that they're sold within two
years
um
but as far as just a random property
could you pay me a little bit of a
picture
um as far as it's like a property on the
backyard
now that this is a you know a property
along a busy highway what's now I
consider a highway you know and it used
to obviously be a much smaller road that
has you know single-family home sitting
on it that home is no longer occupied or
occupyable I guess
um and someone is holding that property
probably for more than two years waiting
for conditions to be right to develop it
into something this seems like it might
preclude that and I'm not sure in that
situation whether the goal of sort of
preserving the the transfer of housing
or development of property I wasn't sure
how it would affect that because I think
it might there might be a number of
properties around the state that look
like that yeah I hadn't considered a
situation like that
um so
um I could get back to you on that other
questions for this witness
representative Horrigan
um yes so how does this uh
he said this bill protects trust so how
does it protect uh
individuals and families who have their
real estate and you know a revocable or
irrevocable trust and
I'm looking
where in here we wrote the line that
says nothing in this section is to be
concerned to alter trust in any way okay
um that was about the language but I'm
trying to find this specific line you
guys saw that yeah
uh should be under exceptions in the
last section I think
okay yeah I say yep yep and uh
follow a question and maybe this is an
unavoidable consequence of it but well
here in New Hampshire we're often
obsessing making tax policy that
attracts rich people from out of state
um one of the things rich people like to
do is you know put their
property you know under an anonymous
entity so you don't know exactly who
owns the property so is there a question
here yes so is that is that still
possible or is that actually probably or
is that something that's uh forbidden by
the language of the bills and perhaps
deliberately
I don't think it really was deliberate
I'll just kind of I'd like to re-center
the conversation a little bit and just
say like the the overarching goal of
this legislation was to stop
consolidation uh within the housing
market
um under a few
um corporate conglomerates there have
been a lot of stories over the last
couple years of 25 30 45 percent of
communities uh especially in the trailer
home Market uh just being owned by the
same company
um and when you talk about an issue like
inflation yes there's the monetary side
of inflation but there are also specific
points in the market where inflation is
worse and one of those is housing
um so it's an effort to go after that
it's an effort to make sure that you
know the next generation of Americans
have the opportunity to own a home and
build that kind of equity so that's
really the overarching purpose of this
and I'm open Nanny
um amendments that the committee May
deem necessary in order to make that
work but I would hope
um that on that higher level uh that's
an agreeable position all right other
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you
uh Brendan Lemay please
hello my name is Brandon Lemay uh from
Manchester New Hampshire representing
myself here uh and I'm here to speak in
favor of 340 here
uh and I just want to say uh that in my
experience working with low and middle
income tenants some of the most
problematic landlords that we've had
have been corporate landlords from out
of state
uh particularly they are going after
multi-family homes as a means uh because
they tend to have a lot of potential
rental income
and these corporate landlords are
pushing out the more Ma and PAW
landlords who have to look their tenants
in the face every single day
and this is irreversibly uh changing the
character of the neighborhoods in
Manchester because we are having
corporations by these buildings and
they're not owned by real people and as
a result we have tenants that stay for
only two years at a time so it's my
opinion that house bill 340 would be
able to make sure that low and middle
income tenants aren't competing with out
of State Corporations to buy property
for their own one day I'll keep it
really short but I'll open up the
questions
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you
representative uh uh Alexandria Murray
please
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
committee for welcoming me today
um my name is representative Alessandra
Murray I represent Manchester Ward 9. I
actually just wanted to share a little
bit about like my personal experience
with this
um last in 2019
um the landlord that for the apartment
that my fiance and I were living in let
us know that he was going to be
renovating and we needed to move out and
rent is so high in Manchester that it's
about the same as paying a mortgage so
my fiance and I were like we should look
for a house
um we spent months looking for a house
in Manchester he's lived there his
entire life I've lived there my entire
adult life we were literally the example
of like a young couple trying to stay in
the area that we grew up and lived in
and couldn't find a house that could
meet our needs um because we kept
getting outbid by out-of-state
corporations there was one instance
where we put an offer on a house and we
are outbid by a hundred thousand dollars
when we had already bid 20 000 over the
asking price and within a week that
house was up on Craigslist available for
rent so it was extremely discouraging to
be a young person that is trying to stay
in my home stay at my hometown
um and feel like we're not wanted like
there isn't space for the people that
are already here and I think at this
point when our housing crisis in New
Hampshire is so bad that it makes sense
to pass legislation like this because we
frankly don't have housing despair to
give to corporations for them to you
know just Garner more profits we need to
be able to house the people that already
live here in the state and have been
here for a long time but I just wanted
to share my personal experience I'm not
a co-sponsor on the spell but you know
it touches my circumstances so I'm open
to questions if there are any questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you uh Chris Norwood please
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Chris Norwood I am
the 2023 chair of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors public policy
committee and I'm a real estate broker
and practitioner in the state of New
Hampshire the Realtors are opposed to
House Bill 340. uh specifically the two
components of this bill are prohibiting
corporations from purchasing
single-family homes and multi-family
homes I will say that there are cases
albeit rare when an individual would
request to purchase a home be it a
primary home or a secondary residence
within an LLC be it for liability or tax
reasons and I would defer to their
accountant and their attorney as to why
that exception May and should exist in
this uh as perhaps a carve out
the other broader piece is
um I I don't disagree with some of the
uh challenges in the market currently I
think the Realtors broadly would say we
need more Supply by by artificially
prohibiting the transfer of property I
do think that that's going to do more to
damage the uh the real estate market
specifically in the multi-family
development Arena a lot of the the
larger complexes whether or not we
want to see them in our communities but
these larger complexes that are doing a
lot of good in terms of adding Supply
are only feasible to have a large
corporation do that be that an in-state
Corporation or an out-of-state
Corporation a lot of times the way that
those get done is there's a conglomerate
of individuals that are put together by
either an LLC or some sort of Syndicate
where there's a lot of equity being
raised and to put that on the burden of
one person as an individual to create a
10 20 or 30 million dollar 80 unit
apartment building is I don't believe is
feasible and I understand the carve out
on development where it says yes you can
raise all that capital and have a
corporation but then there's a window by
which that property has to be
transferred to an individual and I just
don't think that that is practical in
the market to say that individuals are
the only uh entities that can own
multi-family housing it's just the
nature of the Beast that you need to
have
um you need to have cash and Equity from
a number of different sources to
undertake these larger developments so
uh the only other piece that I'd like to
offer that's a little bit of a a
different piece of testimony here is uh
the National Association of Realtors did
does have a a survey where they took a
look at specifically institutional
buyers of residential homes so this is
on the single family side in 2021 and
I'll share this with everybody out of
all 50 states Vermont did not for
whatever reason did not register any
data so let's take it out of 49 states
uh New Hampshire had four percent of all
their residential home purchases uh as a
institutional buyer and I think where a
lot of the data is coming from is from
the south particularly the you know
Texas where the transactions of
institutional buyers exceed 20 percent
uh I know New England the worst state if
if I recall
um is Rhode Island but again we are very
very low in terms of having the
so-called institutional buyers coming in
and buying our inventory and I'll leave
this map with uh with you representative
if you could hand that out and I'm happy
to take any questions questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much Mr
Norwood thank you representative uh Kate
Horgan from the New Hampshire
Association of counties
thank you Mr chair my name is Kate
Horgan and I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties who is opposed
to this bill uh I don't spend a lot of
time in front of this committee so just
to give you an opportunity to learn
about the association all 10 members or
all 10 counties are members of the
association and that includes your
Commissioners your County uh attorneys
register of deeds and all of your
appointed and elected officials so uh we
did review this bill we do have major
concerns one being that the chairman
already pointed out about the
Constitutional uh
ability of this bill and it what our
review says is that this will not pass
the Constitutional test also there are
very big concerns from your register of
deeds offices about the confusion and
delays that this could cause at the
Deeds office specifically around
um RSA 647 colon 46 2 that allows the
two per year period for a non-natural
developer to relinquish property uh
unless they prove that they have the
property for sale and on the market for
the perceiving 12-month period that
could cause major delays at your
Register of Deeds office and your
registers of Deeds did reach out to me
to highlight that I am happy to take any
questions but overall the association
feels that this is going to hinder the
housing market in New Hampshire and not
increase it
questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you uh Nick
Norman please
thank you very much Mr chairman for
another opportunity to speak
again I advocate for landlord property
owners and we are
against this bill
uh to me it doesn't make any sense
first of all a natural person is not
defined anywhere in this bill to my
knowledge
is
been the situation that for many many
reasons
you may want to have a corporation or an
LLC or some kind of a partnership a
general partnership a limited
partnership many different forms of
ownerships corporations C corporations
as corporations to own property
if you're making something this large
it doesn't make any sense for an
individual person and this day and time
to be taking on personal liability and
signing for personal guarantees on loans
for a large development of multi-family
housing and we don't need to discourage
investors from creating more housing
that's exactly what we don't need
so this bill would discourage investors
from investing in New Hampshire I'm very
concerned about that I mean who who
would who would invest in in a large way
in New Hampshire if they can't set up
the legal structures that are common to
own real estate not only for owning the
real estate and protecting the asset but
just even for the estate planning right
you have an LLC that has individual
members and a manager and it's common
it's in my situation in many is that you
have a family LLC where the ownership
interest of the individual members are
passed down to the children over the
years and then that does not end up in
um you transfer
Probate Court probate
um and so now you've saved all of those
probate fees and inheritance fees and so
forth and so on there's many many
reasons and whatever it is a couple
hundred years of history of setting up
corporate structures LLC structures and
all the various reasons that that whole
thing exists and Jesus will throw it out
doesn't make any sense to me at all
right questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
and uh David Klein please
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I know I'm one of the last
speakers in a lot of what I was going to
say
um other people have covered I'm going
to try and skip it very quickly but I
find this build the most
anti-development bill that I've seen
this legislative session
um we all have heard how bad the
shortage of how losing is we need more
built we need big projects
we met with a my son and I met with a
contract to convert a third floor of a
building we have that's four units add
two more units he told us construction
costs not land three hundred dollars per
square foot at 850 square feet per
apartment which is not a big apartment
that's going to be 25 million dollars to
build individuals do not have in general
25 million dollars as the person from
the the real estate person talked about
earlier that you needed multiple
investors you will need a corporate
structure an LLC structure to put this
together to put together a Consortium to
do that
this legislature has recognized over the
years that we should have corporations
we have corporate bills we have limited
partnership bills we have an LLC Bill
and those will put in to attract
businesses of all types to the state
this bill goes exactly against that
the in addition I have questions on the
constitutionality of the bill too both
into the Commerce Clause and other
clauses
and if you look at the fiscal note the
judicial branch even talks about
potential litigation running up the
costs of this bill although they put
indeterminate so they the people who who
helped with the fiscal note realized
that it was going to be a lot of
litigation
yeah
I also look at the penalties they're
pretty severe if someone doesn't follow
it and I think it's a taking without
just compensation which raises another
constitutional issue
finally
from my point of view you want to work
around this bill and make it useless
have a straw
and I know the chairman knows what I'm
referring to you find an individual be
very happy for a certain sum a year to
hold the real estate in his or her name
have all sorts of documents that are not
recorded Deeds whatever to transfer it
out of that person's name
have all management in the hands of some
other person separate the beneficial
interests from the ownership interest
which is what trust documents do
and you can negate the effects of the
bill the bill is basically
it's unconstitutional and useless in my
mind and I would really say to the
committee let's work on things to
increase supply of housing we're not
going to get out of this by decreasing
it we've got to increase it and put our
efforts there and not on a bill like
this that won't help us all right thank
you very much sir questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr chairman anyone else who wishes
to testify on HB 340.
seeing none
um I'm going to close the hearing on HB
340 and I before we turn to HB 379 I'm
going to take a seventh inning stretch
for about five minutes if that's uh
it's really just
wow look it up no no
I guess we're going to take a short
break
is
between Republicans
excuse me senator
okay
people
thank you
foreign
attention
forgetting important things
fortunately I have a history of
remembering it
and going back to the location before
someone
all right
foreign
so if I have multiple people applying
I'll tell them this is how much you
leave I will do everything that I can
that's free to help creating the reports
right and then I can return to you if
you don't get it all right how many
times
picked up applications
from my own home
in Massachusetts
30 years later
luckily
I was at a meeting a few years ago and
there was two meetings happening we were
in the basement and the other meetings
upstairs people coming people coming at
us
so are they going to the meeting
upstairs or something a little more
function and the Overcomers how do you
know their landlords
they're dressed for me that's a landlord
these people go upstairs they look
really wow
right right
okay
yeah
the screen brightness
79 and representative Reed the prime
sponsor we'll hear from you please
once again thank you Mr chair and thank
you honorable members and this is it for
me and today with you I know that is
exciting news uh this is the last one
uh for the record my name again is Ellen
Reed and I represent Rockingham 10 new
market and new fields
so this bill creates a bucket
into which we have placed one dollar
um that sort of kind of but not exactly
mimics the uh the criminal defense
system that we have in place that most
everywhere in the country has in place
which is to say that Indigent in this
case tenants instead of people accused
of crimes and tenants who cannot afford
legal representation
in eviction proceedings would be able to
get attorneys
I've never before put in a bill that had
a significant appropriation and so I was
very hesitant
um and considered greatly this issue
when I was putting it in
um however I'm going I'm spoiler alert I
was going to save this for the end but
I'm going to tell you right now we very
very very likely my constituent is
Maggie Hassan she's in my district we
very likely have three million dollars
from federal money for this I have
already met with the Maggie Hassan's
aides they're very excited Maggie Hassan
has indicated her desire to want to get
federal funds for this program and I
have a meeting this upcoming Monday
another meeting with them as well so
when we're creating the bucket it's an
empty bucket but it's the idea that we
actually will likely be receiving
hopefully be receiving federal funds for
this program but I want to talk about
the reason why we have to have the
bucket to begin with so as it currently
stands when there is an eviction
proceeding there are two sides one is
the landlord who frequently has to show
up to these eviction proceedings very
frequently will have a lawyer that he or
she works with on a frequent basis
they're very familiar even beyond having
a lawyer they are very familiar with the
process by which evictions happen
they're familiar with the laws they're
familiar with the court system they know
this from experience they are prepared
the tenant on the other hand has very
frequently never stepped foot into an
eviction Court proceeding doesn't
understand doesn't know any of the
players doesn't know the law doesn't
understand what the Motions can be and
so what we've heard and the reason I put
this in as requested by New Hampshire
legal assistance
excuse me
is very many tenants judges have told
New Hampshire legal assistance
repeatedly that they really really
wanted to find for the tenant but the
tenant was just lacking the magic words
in court didn't know the right motion
didn't know the right thing to say or do
but it was very clear to the judge in
those cases that the the tenant had
Merit to their argument but they just
were not saying or doing the thing that
needed to be done in that moment for
what they needed so they need like
anybody going through a court proceeding
legal representation
so we've provided a right a conditional
right to legal representation it's
conditioned upon having money in the
bucket
the bucket can be filled by federal
funds as I already mentioned are
hopefully coming should we pass this but
the bucket can also be filled by
donations or if we ever have a general
court that is so inclined through
General funds so that's the basic gist I
I while I was hesitant to put this in
when I didn't realize we might have
money coming
I understood the need for it and I knew
that the argument would be uh but the
money you know and and just so you know
I I crunched the numbers with New
Hampshire legal assistants and we think
it would cost for all of the evictions
the percentage of evictions that um are
are challenged in court I guess would be
the uh term and then the complexity of
those cases having broken those numbers
down with New Hampshire legal assistance
we estimated the fiscal notes may be a
tad High we thought it was closer to a
million a year the fiscal note says one
one and a half million that was our high
figure our low figure was much lower
than that so
um so I when I was talking with Maddie
Hassan's legal aids I asked for a
million a year and they said absolutely
it's completely doable it's a drop in
the bucket for federal numbers so
that's kind of the gist of why and and
the Genesis of this uh but uh when I was
considering putting it in I thought that
the main argument would be the money
um it would be really hard for me to
imagine someone coming before you and
saying but I don't want the other side
in court having a lawyer like I have
access to that seems like a really bad
argument to me you very well may hear
that argument I don't know but I just
it's it's an interesting like how like
how can you be against people having the
ability to have a lawyer
like the opposition does in court that
that seems to go against the general
fairness
I will say that I believe the judicial
Council has um is here in favor we've
talked about them wanting some extra
specifics uh when I was putting the bill
together I had consulted them and I said
how will this be easiest on the court
for
appointing lawyers to people the method
that I have here takes some of the extra
labor out because we put a 200 percent
threshold 200 of poverty line threshold
on it so automatically any tenant that's
under the 200 percent of poverty would
qualify should we have funds for a
lawyer whose experience you know if
they're experiencing eviction anybody
over that then you go through the normal
process as we currently have with
criminal representation of a judge
determining their ability to pay and
whether or not they qualify for free
representation
so that kind of cuts down on some of the
uh the the labor involved there but
um I am in conversations with them they
want a few more specifics in the bill
about exactly where the pool of lawyers
would come from probably an expansion of
New Hampshire legal assistance
um and some other details which I'm
happy to work with them on and happy to
to kneel those details down as much as
they would like to feel good about the
bill but so that's kind of everything I
think I have to say about this and I'm
happy to take questions questions for
this witness representative Horrigan
yes um in in the fiscal note they
they figure 355 dollars per case times
4499 landlord tenant cases so is that
which comes out to a little less 1.6
million dollars some set
well it's rounded up to four thousand
five hundred is that the number of
evictions that were filed in New
Hampshire in 2021 yeah we we uh when I
was working with New Hampshire legal
assistants we used the number 5000
um and then we use the percentages that
we knew were challenged versus not
challenged complicated versus simple
um based on what New Hampshire legal
assistance experience has been yeah and
if I understood what he said that and
not all of those individuals are going
to qualify for this program anyway
exactly
um although uh you can imagine if you're
being evicted most evictions happen for
non-payment most of the people who can't
pay are lower income so there would be a
high rate of of people who qualify but
you're right absolutely right not
everybody would
representative Smith I believe you had a
question
uh thank you representative Reed as you
well know this committee is dealing with
the policy not with the funding sure but
when we say it's not the money it's
always the money it's always the money
um
and with all due respects to
um to the senator
um is there any indication that
um the governor and the executive
Council would accept the money and is
there any indication that
um uh the finance committee would agree
to put this in this budget because
otherwise we're talking about two years
from now
I appreciate the question representative
so no I don't have promises from the
governor or or the senate or anybody
else in the in the process of of
legislating
um but free money is usually a good
thing we are a donor State we send out
more federal tax dollars than we get
back and so it's kind of like well you
know what do you what do you want for
nothing right you get it for free so
um and again the language of the bill is
self-limiting so if we don't have those
funds then this is not a program when we
have the funds we do why not have it
thank you very much thank you question
representative tur
yeah thanks
um uh you brought up the the issue that
I was going to ask about which is the uh
term Indigent versus uh 200 of poverty
um terms I sort of work with in my my
other world a lot um
I I know it goes at the heart of the or
the naming of the of the fund itself
um I'm wondering whether you feel like
Indigent is the right term or 200 which
is we typically use the term low income
for for up to 200 percent of federal
poverty whereas indigen sort of implies
poverty and unable to meet basic basic
needs so I didn't know whether taking
out Indigent from the language and just
leaving it at a low income 200 of
poverty or or if you think the other way
or or if you can reconcile those it's
because that's the precedent and current
statute for criminal defense so it this
very closely but not exactly as I
already mentioned mirrors How We Do
criminal defense
um in the public defender's office so
that term is understood in the legal
realm for our statute to mean inability
to pay an inability to pay you can be
well over poverty you can be making
basic needs but still be unable to
afford a lawyer which is very expensive
so while
I mean I had actually I I can tell you
personally when I was going through this
bill with the lawyer at OLS I kind of
associated the term Indigent with people
who were unhoused and so I was like you
know there was a lot of confusion I'm
like no not Indigent just unable to pay
and the lawyer had to explain to me well
no legally speaking in our current
statute that's exactly what it means
I don't know if I I don't have the
reference to the other legislation that
might be helpful but uh
does it reference 200 of poverty no so
that's the way I changed it so that's a
shortcut that's a labor saving uh move
that I made a change that I made to this
specifically So currently if you're
accused of a crime and you say I need an
attorney I can't afford one a judge has
to determine your ability to pay before
you get that attorney assigned I didn't
want to overburden
um the judicial clerks or Judiciary
clerks in having to go through all that
and have all the the judges having to
determine say 4 000 cases and whether or
not they were able to pay so I gave a
shortcut if they are under 200 percent
boom they can't afford to pay already it
doesn't have to go before a judge if
they're over 200 percent a judge will
still make that determination
so one last follow-up if you would just
I'm wondering whether or not cleaning up
one or the other would be because I feel
like it is mixing two different
definitions in in the same
um so Indigent contains anyone under 200
percent but it's not so everyone who is
under 200 percent is Indigent period if
you're under 200 the poverty line you're
Indigent you you are for lack of a
better word poor you cannot afford an
attorney if you're under if you're at or
under 200 of poverty line
um if you're over it you may still be
Indigent but that's going to be up to a
judge to determine
I didn't mean if I didn't mean to
interrupt you if you want to I was just
gonna say but you're definitely Indigent
if you're under 200 so there was no
reason to put the judges through all of
those cases most of the people applying
for this will be under 200 percent
other question for this witness
um oh representative Perez okay
thank you
I just say if you're
under 200 percent you are Indigent where
did that definition come from is that
the definition as opposed to as as
proposed here yes that's so proposed
here yes the idea is so in the current
criminal defense World Indigent means
unable to pay for a lawyer you cannot
afford a lawyer we're saying in this
bill if you're under 200 of the poverty
line and just to be really clear the
poverty line something like 24 25 000
for a family
so if you're 50 000 for a family you
can't pay you cannot afford a lawyer a
lawyer is very expensive so that's what
we're saying
yes and you're saying the tenant
but you're talking about a family as
opposed to a tenant
um
that's different who's on the lease
maybe you and not your family who is
this so you qualify for the pot where
you are on the poverty line is based on
whether or not you live alone or with a
household so that's kind of separate
this is well understood and I understand
very public and also private
institutions for calculating if somebody
qualifies for example my local hospital
provides uh financial assistance for
medical bills if you're 250 percent of
poverty or under so it's understood to
be if you live alone I believe the
number is twelve five twelve thousand
five hundred I could be wrong it's
somewhere in that ballpark though and if
you are in a family it's something like
twenty five thousand
other questions for this Witness
so I guess I I do have a question and
I'm I'm really not I actually have two
questions and I'm not sure you if I'm
understanding correctly you said that
there's Federal money
available to pay for counsel a good
promise of federal money
um very specifically Maggie Hassan is
very interested in kind of prioritizing
housing and her team as I said this is
something I want to do and I have a
second meeting with them that they
reached out to to make about this so I
guess what the thing that I'm not clear
on though is that's if that's the case
I'm not clear why we need this bill
because the uh
I I don't fault you for for this at all
but but you should understand that a
person has the right
to an attorney in almost any judicial
proceeding so so the question the the
when we use the right to counsel
um what we're when we talk about the
right to counsel in this bill you're
talking the right to have Council paid
for by the government and so what I'm
really asking is
if the government is has got this money
that it's for the federal government has
got this money that it's willing to pay
for counsel for people to be represented
when they're being evicted
they can just give that money to Legal
Aid and legal aid can can come in and
say when somebody is being evicted
legally Aid can come in and say we'll
we'll pay the bill for this attorney and
the judge would have no choice but to
appoint counsel for them because they
have a right if if the judge doesn't get
to ask who's paying for the for the bill
unless it's the state that's paying so
why do why do we I guess I'm really
asking why do we need this why can't the
senator Hassan just you know get the
money appropriated and it gets sent to
Legal Aid in New Hampshire or whatever
the the lawyer groups are and they
provide legal representation thank you
there's there is no Administration like
with all federal funds that come to the
state we are in charge of administering
it so while you're suggesting that they
just go through a private non-profit
legal assistance I suppose that's
possible but in terms of giving it to
the government because that's what
they're allocating they're got like
hitting it to New Hampshire the new
Hampshire has to decide what to do with
it all of that is Administrative so we
need that structure in place in order to
provide those systems if they just hand
US money we don't know what to do with
it and we have to decide what to do with
it and we name those systems just as
they do as I understand it and you
correct me if I'm wrong but as I
understand it the federal government
gives money to non-profits for all kinds
of things why couldn't they just give
money for this representation to Legal
Assistance New Hampshire legal
assistance and other you know and and if
there are other groups that provide this
assistance without the state being
involved at all
I suppose I mean yes you're right they
could do that as I already said but I
think in terms of having a structure
whereby we guarantee a right to counsel
and if you cannot pay a Ford Council we
provide one which is what we want to
achieve that requires an administrative
structure
well I guess I I mean I I okay I don't I
just I'm not gonna I'm not gonna argue
with you about that but I guess what I
was saying what I was trying to say
before was there is a there is a right
to counsel that a court if somebody can
pay for a lawyer a court can't say no
you can't have a lawyer I mean unless I
understand so so that's what I'm really
saying there was the second part that I
emphasized but I'll emphasize it again
as we all hear in like every cop show
since forever you have a right to an
attorney and if you cannot afford one
one will be provided to you we want that
kind of assurance so long as there are
funds for it we want that kind of
assurance for tenants experiencing
eviction because housing is necessary
for life
all right other questions for
representative Smith it's not actually a
a question but I do want to clarify the
difference between a civil and a
criminal proceeding in court and
um watching whatever you're watching
um that's criminal no I'm very well
aware that guaranteed does not exist in
civil but that's why you have the bill
exactly that's I'm exactly aware of that
that's why I keep saying we have this
for criminal we want to have something
like this for people's ability to live
that's the point
and while I'm not going to to say that
you you just have to guarantee it like
we do with the criminal side we
guarantee it and we just put money
behind it and then you have overburdened
public defenders and all that what I'm
saying is we're guaranteeing it as long
as we have the money the empty bucket is
made if the bucket is full we're going
to provide that same guarantee that we
provide people I mean I would argue well
I think that the right to an attorney
and to be provided in turn if you cannot
afford one is absolutely necessary for
our criminal system that we should
absolutely guarantee that on a whole
other level these are people you know
accused of crimes
versus people who need a place to live a
roof over their head and then on some
level that is more basic that is more
basic so yes the whole point of the bill
as I tried to answer with the chairs
question and try and answered with your
question is to have a mirror more or
less a mirror of what we do for
assurances for people charged with
crimes but experiencing
possible homelessness
yes Richard head is here I'm not sure if
there's someone else uh let me see well
I was told
all right hang on thanks I have your
legal assistance uh
and he called me this morning no I I do
not see anyone here from the judicial
Council Richard head is here but but uh
no one's from the judicial account
um
uh no legal system someone is here from
New Hampshire legal assistance yes yep
um so I you know I guess in light of the
the your your the in the interplay
between you and and uh representative
Smith you have one other question is um
the way this bill is worded it doesn't
seem to make
the the rights of counsel that you
create by the bill contingent upon there
being Federal funding and so my question
is would you have any objection if there
was an amendment that said
essentially the right established in
paragraph 3A parenthesis a
comes into effect only if there's
Federal money to pay for it
um I'm almost positive I put that in the
bill uh in fact I am positive I put it
in the bill and this may be an error on
ols's part that it didn't make it into
you know through some some redraft if it
is in fact not there but I very
specifically had exactly what you're
referring to which is there is a right
to counsel a right to paid Council for
Indigent tenants experiencing eviction
but it is contingent upon uh there being
money in those funds
I I can I can keep looking for it yeah I
didn't see that as I looked at it but I
you know I looked quickly too so I could
be wrong line 13 the judicial Council
said shall administer the fund and Shout
to the extent available of available
federal state or private funds pay the
cost of council and investigative
experts or other services la la
okay
right right it's not only but I mean you
and you and you wouldn't you would
interpret that to mean that that's a
limit if they if there's no federal
money then they don't have to do it
I do interpret that to mean that but I I
very specifically remember a different
section that we put in that the right to
an attorney
paid for asterisk as the chair has
rightly uh pointed out
um was in fact contingent on on money in
the funds so I'll need a second to look
over the bill but if in fact it didn't
make its way into this particular
version I'm happy to put it in all right
other questions for this Witness
yes representative testerman
we keep hearing in here that
this is not
real money this is
yeah could you just get closer to the
microphone please thank you we keep
hearing that this isn't real money this
is federal money
yeah I consider Federal money real money
uh but Deuce this paragraph or sentence
that they talk about in here says
federal state or private funds I don't
care about private funds I really care
about private and federal and state
yeah it to me if I go down to
Appropriations it brings Appropriations
back after that one if I don't have
Federal money I'm going to pull this out
of the state thing and I think this is
crazy it's crazy money to begin with to
think that oh this is free money but
but to say that there's not some State
pile of money right behind this whole
thing is just wrong so it's a couple
points there and I mean I presume you'll
say don't you agree because that wasn't
a question but a couple points so first
of all it's not made up money or federal
money or you know that's you know
whatever money it's our money it is the
taxpayers money of this state that pay
taxes in their paychecks going to the
federal government we are a donor state
which means we pay out more than we get
back in So for us to get our money back
is a good thing
um secondly there's nothing in this bill
that says if we don't get Federal money
it automatically is going to come out of
the general funds absolutely not it is a
one dollar bucket if you want I will
give you a dollar right now and it just
creates the bucket that's all there is
so if if it's unfunded because we don't
get federal funds or whatever other
funds then it just sits empty
I just agree with you completely but
well that's not the process
all right other questions for this yes
representative Grissom thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking our questions uh in thinking
about future funding for this if it were
to come into existence because when
something comes in it never goes away uh
and So eventually we're we as a state
will be on the hook for paying for this
program at some point down the line so
would there be a possibility of having
establishing an Indigent tenant fee that
could be charged to tenants at the
signing of a lease collected by the
landlord that would be sent in to the
treasury and that would help to pay for
however much the dollar amount would be
we can figure that out but based on 4
500 cases at 100 bucks a piece there's
450 000 but at least the tenant now has
skin in the game they they're at least
contributing toward their own defense
they're at least providing some means uh
so it's not completely on
taxpayers in general but they are
actually contributing part of that
themselves so first of all they are
taxpayers that is their money coming
back to them secondly we're not on the
hook if it's an empty bucket it's an
empty bucket we're not obligated to fill
the bucket
um thirdly I would while I am very open
to a whole host of creative ways to fund
this bucket I would
I would caution against saying that
Indigent tenants by their definition
they are low to maybe moderate income
um don't have skin in the game already
it's the roof over their head they are
fighting for they definitely have skin
in the game and they've already paid for
it through their federal taxes so
um they asking in the game the idea of
charging an Indigent person even more
money for a program that we're trying to
help them with doesn't seem to make
sense to me but I'm open to different
ideas I appreciate the creative thinking
and I'm open to having that discussion
and having more ideas about how to fund
this in the future
thank you all right representative
Horrigan
um
first of all um first of all I point out
that the idea we just heard from the
member from Wentworth is a new fee so
but um
[Music]
but is if if this if for some reason
there's a lot of uh so much this program
is such a success it's so popular it
benefits uh not just the tenants
themselves from usually a whole
um such a way that perhaps we're tempted
to keep it going even if the federal
funding draws away is that necessarily a
bad thing if we decide that's a good
thing to spend 1.6 million dollars a
year of our limited State funding on
it's it's as is every biennium when we
pass a budget it is a the truest
reflections of truest reflection our
budget is the Jewish reflection of our
values as a legislative body we
determine what we are willing to fund
based on our priorities based on our
value system if we have a general court
at some point in the future that
determines that this has been so
successful with federal funds that it's
worth continuing with State funds and
that's up to that legislative body in
that term as as is every other budget
decision I will say that this does in
the long run
um very frequently help landlords too
because what frequently happens when you
have legal counsel for both sides is a
mediation process process so that you
can avoid the expensive eviction
proceedings
other questions for this witness thank
you very much thank you so much that's
it for me thank you
Eric Gallagher please
hi so I'm Eric Gallagher uh
we're the representative for Concord
Ward 6 which is Merrimack County
District 20 and I am a co-sponsor on
this bill here speaking in support of it
um
so
the Sixth Amendment to the United States
Constitution
guarantees a right to council and the
U.S Supreme Court upheld that right in
Gideon versus Wainwright
um
for criminal cases so yeah
representative Smith was bringing up the
criminal versus civil distinction before
this extends it to
civil cases
where a tenant is being evicted
which
I think tenants would very much
appreciate
um
a bit more about the criminal civil
distinction
um
so
even though that might exist in the
course part
from the tennis point of view
so
police will still come to evict you if
you're getting evicted that was
something
um
where our County Sheriff here in
Merrimack County David Croft has made
news for trying to
do that in a more humane way of
you know collecting other good people
with services and whatnot but still the
fact is that it's the police do it so
from
the tennis point of view
the criminal civil distinction
might not really be that visible to them
it it often will feel like you're
getting criminalized when you're getting
evicted
so
um that's what one of the reasons why I
think it's important for
uh tenants to have counsel
um
so and then also
um to address a point about
uh Federal funding
um
about why the money can't just go to New
Hampshire legal aid specifically
so um
I'm not entirely sure about process
here since
um
the federal government changes their
budgeting procedure every term it seems
like but to me it sounds like that would
be
um what's referred to as earmarks which
um or t is the fancy terminology that
um Congressional offices will sometimes
put out I think they use the term
constituent directed funding request
um
and whether or not earmarks are allowed
is something
that um
keeps
changing depending on
what the federal rules committee decides
and they're only just getting organized
now after
um
some confusion asked as to how exactly
this Federal
um this town's Federal Congress
is going to be organized so
um
whether or not it is actually possible
for the money to go directly to New
Hampshire legally
um I I don't think
that's a
question that we have a certain answer
to yet
um
but it is true that
there is supposed to be Federal support
for this General principle I haven't
spoken to Senator Hassan's office myself
about this but I have seen just
from the news that um the buy-in
Administration
recently
announced a set of
principles for
renters included a right to council and
eviction proceedings
among them so um
that's a sign that the federal
government would back us up on this but
the reason why
I think we should do this through state
level
legislation rather than just depending
on the federal rulemaking is because
um well Federal Executive Branch rope
making isn't quite as permanent it can
change with administrations and
um
I think just showing that we have that
same commitment
to that principle on the um
at the state level here too would just
give tenants in
this state a greater sense of security
um and would be helpful for them
um
so
uh yeah that's why
or though that's what I have to say
about this bill
um and I'll take any questions questions
for this week
seeing none thank you very much sir
Brendan Lemay
there we go hi uh Brandon Lemay from
Manchester New Hampshire uh speaking in
support of House Bill 379. uh yeah I
just want to be really brief once again
here because you are going to hear me
for one more bill today
um
I see this bill as primarily
defending those that are of the lowest
income think of those who are disabled
think of those who are elderly those who
are working multiple jobs with children
and then throw them an eviction notice
and expect them to understand what a
discovery period is
ask them to know what is and isn't okay
to say in front of a judge it's just not
something that the average person
I can really comprehend without many
years of law school behind them
so I see this bill as just leveling the
playing field and it's making sure that
regular people are protected through a
very complicated process which is
landlord-tenant law I have been an
advocate for low and middle-income
renters for a couple of uh two years now
almost three and I can tell you I still
don't understand many of the legal
nuances that go into an eviction hearing
and when we consider just how important
housing is I believe that adding the
right to defend yourself in front of a
judge and to have qualified legal
representation is Paramount to being
able to be in a functional member of
society quite frankly
um so I'll keep the short uh and I'll
open up to any questions questions for
this wish
ing none thank you very much sir thank
you a representative Reed could I just
ask I think we don't have a pink card on
this bill don't I mean when you get to
it it's that that'd be fine next I'm
going to call on uh Sophia Hyatt New
Hampshire legal assistance
foreign
my name is Sophia Hyatt I'm a housing
attorney at New Hampshire legal
assistance I'm here to talk about nhla
supporting this bill as a concept I'm
mostly here to talk about the fact that
I among other nhli nhla Advocates have
been working in the courts the last
couple of years not for the courts but
at the courthouses in Manchester and
Nashua doing eviction clinics I think
I've done about 75 myself where we show
up and meet tenants for the first time
look at their files talk to them about
what's happening and talk them through
you know what their legal defenses might
be but we also help them Reach
agreements with their landlords so a lot
of times the landlord and the tenant in
the in the situations that we see I'm
not saying this is always the case but
are frustrated with one another aren't
able to communicate effectively don't
want to listen to one another and it
really helps to have someone step in and
be able to calmly talk through things in
a rational way explain to the tenant
what their rights are explain what the
law is help them try and negotiate with
their landlord oftentimes we're able to
get an agreement reached before an
eviction judgment is issued against a
tenant yes an eviction being filed in
the court still shows up in the landlord
Reporting System but there's no judgment
on the person's record if they reach an
agreement and submit that through the
courts and and follow it so nhla does
support the concept of right to counsel
I just realized I didn't hand out but I
have letters from
uh letters from the National Coalition
for civil right to council that they
support uh the right to council and
eviction proceedings as well I'm happy
to answer questions about kind of what
it's like and how it helps having
someone there uh at an eviction case and
working through that process with the
tenant and a landlord
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Jessica margason please
foreign
good afternoon my name is Jessica
marjason again with Granite State
organizing project
I am here and I support this bill my
work
as I've stated before and I'll state for
clarification now I have a tenant Clinic
that I run weekly I'm missing it to be
here today it's normally Wednesdays from
one to four
um
and during this I see I get to be that
person in the middle of the tenants and
nhla because when they come into the
clinic I help them find some rental
assistance they may need I help them
learn their rights and I also help
direct them to free legal assistance
teach them how to sign up and go about
that what I do run into unfortunately
and why this bill is so important is
nhla is the only free legal help we have
in our state currently they are very
very busy and due to that sometimes
um
people want questions right away or
they'll fall through a crack but one big
thing that happens is a conflict of
interest because they are the only
organization that does this sometimes a
conflict of interest will exist in there
to where that tenant can then not get
free legal assistance so there are a
portion of tenants in our state that
would benefit from this who couldn't
benefit from the current the way it is
so if they had representation and they
were able to get it elsewhere they could
still then be covered um
I don't know why certain ones exist but
it's something within the company and
the majority of the ones I do help with
are able to get assistance luckily
another reason is why it's so needed
there is no safety net a lot of times
people assume there's a safety net for
those who are either elderly or disabled
and there is no Universal safety net as
I'm sure you've seen sir
um for instance Michelle Marr who I
watched nhla defend and core and keep
housed had recently had brain surgery
and her head was still healing as I
watched in court as she sat in her
wheelchair and the other lawyer tried so
hard to get her unhoused so luckily she
was able to stay house because of those
services like I said no safety net Doris
bomba who I was able to connect with
them also because of no safety net he
had
limited capacity so for him to
understand what was going on and make
his way through that the judge doesn't
have time to sit there and say well
you don't seem to understand what's
going on let's do this instead that's
not his role then so having nhla there
to be able to help them is huge
um so this bill is big and one thing I
did notice on it when reading through
the paperwork is
um
page three oh it's labeled page two but
line one and two authorized to draw a
warrant from said some out of any money
in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated would this then be similar
to how City Welfare operates that when
their bucket runs dry it can be
replenished
and that's I had a question on that
right questions for this Witness
yes representative Perez
question would anybody be opposed to
since it appears there seems to be two
or even more mediation groups out there
working would anybody be opposed perhaps
to adding into this if mediation is not
able to be work because it appears we
have a bill that mediation is working we
also have testimony that other mediation
is working
would anybody be opposed to having part
of this say that if mediation is not
able to be reached that's a good idea so
that people aren't just saying well I
don't want to go through mediation I can
get a lawyer just a thought it is a good
idea because uh mediation is a choice
you don't have to go through so if both
parties don't want to go
um so say the tenant did want to go to
mediation which would be a cost saver
um and the landlord says absolutely not
um that would be another reason it would
be good for it another thing too I
almost didn't mention is that in the
state of New Hampshire it's a
discrimination women and women with
children are more likely than men or men
with children to be given evictions
um so that's another big reason because
of that discrepancy existing and
mediation like as you said the
communication sometimes breaks down
between landlords and tenants over
arguing and sometimes they do need that
person there just to start the
communication again
putting some money into keeping people
housed also is another way to save money
because if we don't keep them housed
we're going to have to pay for them to
be housed and it's a lot more expensive
monthly like at the hotels right now
it's five thousand dollars a month to
house someone in a hotel where we could
put them in an apartment for 1200 to
1600 rent so keeping them housed saves
US money down the road so if we have a
little bit of money to throw to this it
it will save us money all right
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you um Richard head please
thank you Chad good after Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Richard head I'm the government Affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch
in general we support anything that can
help any party whether it be a filing
party or or defendant have legal
representation
um but the reality is in landlord tenant
as in family as in a lot of of the areas
of that that we see in the circuit
courts there are a lot of unrepresented
parties
we do and we have taken a lot of steps
to make courts more accessible to
unrepresented parties
um but it is clearly a a more efficient
system if there are attorneys in in the
system
one of the areas in in the uh
uh in representative Reed had mentioned
that you know I did talk with her this
morning I there are a number of new
members on the committee and I do want
to clarify one thing that's a common
source of confusion the judicial council
is unrelated to the judicial branch the
judicial council is an executive branch
agency
that is the funding the The Source or
receives the funding that ultimately is
used to pay for uh engine Indigent
criminal defense attorneys that is not
managed through the judicial branch
um what this bill would require is that
for anyone who meets the definition of
indigent in this bill whether it be in
other bills low income it's called
Indigent uh in this bill
the concern is is
what I think representative Reed said
she was hoping to have created in in
this bill which is a lack of structure
so the the if we take the criminal world
we have a robust structure around
criminal defense lawyers we have a
public defender system that is
throughout the state when when the court
uh
says that somebody is entitled to
representation in the criminal world we
do not pick the lawyer it is done
through the public defender's office
public defender then assigns that lawyer
to the case and a lawyer is then
representing that defendant
this doesn't have that structure
associated with it so we would
appoint a lawyer
unclear as to who that lawyer will be
where that lawyer is coming from who's
managing who's going to assign what
lawyer to that case if it is New
Hampshire legal assistance they're going
to need a a much more robust system than
what they have currently because just
the sheer number of of potential
appointments of attorneys that would be
required through this through this bill
so the the the sort of the lack of
underlying structure that that
that this bill does not fill creates a
significant vacuum in terms of what
would happen once a court appoints an
attorney because there's not then a
system to pick that up and say you know
attorney Smith you're now assigned to
this case
the other aspect of of this
um that again comes to the structure of
it is
landlord tenant cases happen very very
fat quickly they they have very short
deadlines from the date the case is
filed to the date that there has to be a
hearing I think although don't hold me
to this is 10 days
um so what has to happen in that time
when that
tenant files the appearance files the
financial records is in very short order
a lawyer has to be not only uh
assigned but has to appear has to show
up and has to sort of become involved
legal assistance is very good at that
for their clients but they don't have
sort of this system in place to do it
throughout the state for you know I
don't know how many thousands of of
individuals who would go through it so
as written the bill doesn't provide any
of that substance and we have a great
deal of concern about that in talking
with representative Reed this morning
we're obviously happy to assist in in
any in any way we can in terms of the
legislation but as written
we think that it it could it really
wouldn't be able to be implemented just
as a mechanics of of getting lawyers
appointed getting a lawyer assigned to a
case and getting the lawyer to appear
and then show up in a courtroom within a
very short window of time with that I
would conclude my comments but would be
happy to answer any questions questions
for this Witness
yes representative Manos thank you Mr
Char
um Mr head would the
um would the administrative system also
include the system for payment to
council once the work is done so payment
Council in this bill would be through
the judicial Council not the judicial
branch which is why the judicial Council
put in the fiscal note that has the
dollars not the judicial branch
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you Mr head thank you
thank you very much for your time today
uh David Klein please
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is David Klein I know
you're probably sick of hearing from me
um just want to start off with if a
proposing counsel appears in an eviction
I've had it happen a couple of times I
have no problem with it the comment that
we don't want them represented is not
true those cases actually go through
easier because someone it does explain
to the defendant where the defendant
doesn't know what they're talking about
and that happens a lot in land
Lieutenant cases
um
uh just briefly all evictions in New
Hampshire have to be done exactly
according to RSA 540. there are
deadlines time limits all those have to
be followed every eviction I've ever
been involved with in Circuit Court the
judge makes sure that all those
deadlines are met properly if you don't
serve if it's a 30-day eviction and you
serve 29 days you're thrown out seven
days and you don't have the full seven
days you're thrown out
and many of the judges are actually
pushing us to go to go to agreements I
had the last eviction I had the judge
basically said why don't you go outside
and talk about it it was clear and she
said she indicated that I I was all
right but there was a discretionary stay
right now in the law of up to two months
and she wanted us to use part of it and
also not get give judgment to the ten if
the tenant was willing to move out in
order so that she wouldn't have an
eviction on a record just the filing not
the uh judgment
most evictions are as was testified
before they're not for non-payment of
rent there isn't any real defense to
most of those cases there are a few but
that most of them people just don't have
the money so now it's down to how long
they're going to be there
and that becomes the appointed attorney
will basically be negotiating a move out
date which the judges are pushing for a
negotiated settlement
that same thing incidentally happens in
mediation the mediator will sit down and
talk about the rights and we already
have that program in existence and in
fact we had a bill earlier to have the
study committee so
my opinion is the Indigent defense
Council will not be that helpful to the
defendant now if we expand the mediation
program
and the the funding issues I don't I
don't have the quality to speak to but I
do want to start that it feels like this
bill starts to slippery slope
currently only Indigent defendants and
criminal actions when this possibility
of going to jail incarceration are
entitled to appointed counsel
but this bill for the first time is
going to appoint counsel in a civil case
and then the question is what's next do
we appoint counsel for first defense
driving Under the Influence there's no
jail time so they're not entitled to it
now but you get one of those you can
lose your job you can lose your housing
you can lose your marriage
it's also devastating
another what about plaintiffs of
defendants and domestic violence cases
as we heard earlier this morning someone
can get badly hurt
does it is the victim entitled to a
appointed Council there so how much do
we want to spend how far do we want to
go where do we draw the line
I'm just going to propose and throw it
out to the community to discuss when
you're executing are we better off
funding more mediation with these
federal funds if we can get them or we
better off with Indigent Council I think
mediation would be a better option
thank you for your attention thank you
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
um uh Nick Norman
thank you again Mr chairman for the
opportunity to speak I don't think
there's much more for me to say that
hasn't already been said
um we think that this is very redundant
to Legal Aid Services that are already
in place
Dennis already get legal aid services so
I agree with whatever was said earlier
from the front assistant chair or chair
that said we could just have Federal
moneys go to Legal Aid
we don't need a different structure
most cases definitely
overwhelmingly are for non-payment
there's nothing to defend in a
non-payment case did you pay the rent or
not
so I mean why are we will we be paying
for the expense of an attorney for
something like that
um
I heard something about discrimination
of favoring I heard something about
discrimination of favoring and I don't
know which way it was excuse me sir you
need to you need to be in the back okay
thank you men or women in eviction cases
I I'm definitely in touch with many many
landlords across the state I have never
heard of such a thing I don't know where
that's coming from at all I don't see
any discrimination
of men or women with children one over
the other
um
so I I don't really have any other new
comments I would happily take any
questions
for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
um is there anyone else uh who desires
to testify on House Bill 379.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 379 and open the
hearing on House Bill
401 and recognize uh representative Kent
representative Kenny yeah
all righty uh good afternoon committee
members Mr chairman my name is
representative Kenny I represent uh
Stratford County District 10. of course
that includes the University of New
Hampshire
um I apologize for not being here
earlier Wednesdays and Mondays I'm
trying to juggle classes at law school
and committee but I'm happy to be here
now to present a house bill 401.
so I'll briefly walk through the bill uh
with you all uh it's regarding standards
on an owner's intent to renovate or
remove property uh from the residential
Market
so it adds a second section to RSA 540.
um I will begin
by pointing out that uh page one line
five offers an exception
um
talking about section f
uh that section regards lead exposure so
in those situations uh this bill is not
relevant
um page one line five through nine
offers two elements that an eviction
notice must have uh when there is an
intent to renovate the first is 60 days
notice uh to vacate
and second is to specify the work and
time frame of the renovations
um some questions you may have
is why 60 days it takes time to find a
spot so we doubled from what is current
law which is 30 days
um so I know there's been comments from
the committee that reasonableness is an
aggravating term I'm in law school I
know but it is in the realm of
reasonableness in my opinion
um then I'll move to page one line let's
see 11 through 18 which offers three
elements that an owner must establish to
Prevail at uh the hearing
that's one uh that the work cannot
happen while
the unit is occupied two that the work
will take more than 30 days
and third uh that the tenant is offered
to dwell in with the same number of
bedrooms that doesn't exceed uh the rent
so why 30 days uh it's you it's using
the under current law RSA 130 uh a which
provides 30 days in situations due to
lead hazards so that's where that number
came from just trying to keep it
applicable to uh current law
lines uh still page 1 17 and 18 offers a
when this shall not apply
and it's basically when the owner can
show that they made a good faith effort
to find the unit
um at the hearing
or that the evictions are uh Justified
under the sections a through
um G and again the language about shall
not apply was again borrowed from the
lead statute
um
so starting on line 19 evictions based
on intent to remove dwellings from the
market uh 21 for 26 offers the elements
um one that the eviction notice shall
provide 10 at 60 days at least and be a
sworn affidavit that will not be on the
market for
um a year and then it gets into the
penalty even if it's sold to a new owner
um so the amount of the penalty the
justification behind that it's a low
ball for what
um
a landlord May accrue in a year uh for
rent
um so that was kind of the mindset there
but
uh we need some sort of accountability
uh for the potential of Bad actors who
may try to find a loophole
um
in that regard uh briefly page two line
three through six regards
uh Court uh having the authority to
Grant uh discretionary stays up to
excuse me up to uh six months the
current lie I believe is 90 days but if
granted a question that you may have the
rent will still be paid
um
during this day the only consequence
would be the potential delay
um and again I believe six months is
reasonable so I'm a renter
um you know I looking at current law
with 30 days putting myself in that
situation I I don't quite know what I
would do
um you know I moved two hours away from
my family uh unless my fellow reps from
Durham uh rep Smith or Horgan wanted a
roommate I don't know what I would do so
I'd have to figure that out
um
so
that's basically
all I have I am happy to take questions
um and I will just note that New
Hampshire legal assistance will also be
testifying and they may be better at
answering some questions but I'll always
give my best effort all right questions
for this witness yes representative
Smith
thank you um representative me if you
need a place to rest your head you know
but on a more relevant question
um
so why do we need this bill you've
explained very carefully what the bill
does and now I want you to tell me why
well because I I believe that
you know if if there's going to be a
renovation a tenant
in my opinion housing is a human right
and there needs to be adequate notice no
matter what if someone is going to be
deprived of
um
of their housing and there are
situations where 30 days just isn't
enough time after you find out about
renovations
to secure housing so I think it's
necessary
um
you know I will say that it's it's a a
newer issue after talking to some people
from New Hampshire legal assistance uh
but an issue nonetheless
yes of course
um do you have reason to believe that
there exists at all circumstances in
which
um
um an owner indicates his intention his
or her intention to renovate
um
a unit
really with not a strong commitment to
renovate but a desire to
empty the apartments so that the rent
could change
um good question I
I believe right now it's it's in the
realm of possibilities and I'm sure
people have experienced uh that based on
conversations that I've had
thank you
all right other question yes
representative tur yeah hopefully quick
question
um this again sort of like one of the
bills we heard earlier talks about uh
eviction versus
um the the notification prior to what
I'm guessing is the end of Elise so
does this does this apply only in the
case where the tenant refuses to leave
even though the owner wishes to or or if
they give 60 days notice before the end
of the lease is up can they simply say
you know I'm not going to renew it's
sort of uh add on to what we talked
about earlier
um in that in that regard of of whether
or not the end of your lease means
eviction or not
I think I understand your question
um I'll give it a shot what I can say is
that current law regarding around an
owner's intent to renovate
requires 30 days and
that just isn't enough time in my
opinion so in situations
um this is just trying to up the time
other questions did I representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair and thank
you my friend for taking my question
um I mean there's quite a bit of
concerns I have with this bill but my
biggest my biggest concern question is
line 15 on page one tenants been offered
a dwelling unit with the same number of
bedrooms as are in the unit which here
if she is being evicted at a rent that
just doesn't exceed tenants current rent
so is that just for like say you have an
apartment complex like a a large
apartment complex and they offer a
similar one to that or is this saying
that now the landlord has to go shop
around and find a suitable replacement
um when they're being evicted when their
tenants being evicted so now the land
it's the landlord's problem to like find
them another place to stay
um
well what I'll say is I think your first
example would qualify
regarding your second question the
tenant wouldn't have done anything wrong
and 30-day notice isn't enough time so
um is it the landlord's responsibility
per se to shop around as you worded it
um I think it's it's the landlord's
responsibility to ensure that a tenant
uh has adequate housing if they plan to
renovate
other questions to this witness
representative Perez thank you for
taking my question
um line 2526 does that limit the owner's
ability to sell what if I want to
renovate and then turn around and sell
do I have to say to the person well I'm
going to sell it to you but you can't
you can't rent it out for a year I just
wondered if we're limiting the ability
to sell in this
um you are correct that that's the
language so if
your take if the it's going to be
brought off the market
um then even if it is sold because there
has to be some form of accountability
um you know in situations where
per se
there are workarounds without that sort
of accountability
um you know sell it to a landlord who
you know you may be allies with or
whatnot
other questions for this Witness
oh representative Manos thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Kenny um
I wanted to ask I wasn't clear on your
explanation about the relationship
between the six-month stay and the
obligation to continue to pay rent could
you clarify that please
could you say that one more time
I believe you said earlier that there
was that during a stay there was an
obligation to continue to pay rent
that's what I understood maybe I
misunderstood you but I was wondering if
you could just clarify talking about the
discretionary stay yes
um so to my understanding that if the
court was to order a discretionary stay
that the landlord would still be
receiving uh rent through that state the
only consequence would be pushing off
the renovation
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir
thank you Mr chairman
um uh Jessica morgason please
good afternoon my name is Jessica
marjason still Granite State organizing
project and
um I am wanting to let you guys know I
do fully uh
I love Bill 401
um this is something I've looked forward
to being created over the past couple
years and watching what I've seen as I
explained my tenant Clinic started as an
eviction Clinic because of the mass
amounts of renovation evictions that we
were seeing after about six months we
were able to transition it into a tenant
Clinic to meet any tenants it needs but
the evictions the renovation evictions
were so high tenants would commonly say
the house to my left and the house to my
right is up for sale everywhere I look
is up for sale
um
so things I've seen this beam misused by
360 Dubuque Street in Manchester I've
mentioned this place before the tenants
called me when they got the renovation
eviction as we were going through the
process they decided to go ahead and
move out in time
their landlord was intimidating them a
lot so on the day that the first floor
tenant was moving out she called me
because she was scared to go in and get
the last bit of her stuff because the
new person was already moving in they
didn't even have time to sweep the
floors no renovation happened there but
it was used
last year when we had SB 217 here and we
were all here to test a lot of us were
here to testify on that
um we got to hear Nick Norman testify
that commonly when they use another form
of eviction and it doesn't go through or
it doesn't work the renovation eviction
is the one they turn to because it goes
right through may not be the exact every
single word used but that was the full
implication and luckily he's here to
explain that but it is something
commonly as we learned that day used by
landlords when all else fails just use
the renovation eviction it goes right
through
um
this also the renovation evictions are a
no-fault addiction for the tenants we
should be doing anything possible in
applying any protection we can put in
place to make sure it remains a no-fault
eviction and they don't suffer
consequences that happen so the six
months is great to add into there giving
them that time as we've all heard it
takes about that time it gives a family
time to plan save up the money change
the schools do all that they never
intended to move this is a no-fault
addiction
um
so because of protections needing to be
in place for stuff like that um
when you're in court and you're
listening to the landlord what will
happen is this side will say well I
don't think they're going to do a lot of
Renovations the landlord or the attorney
will say well we have this list planned
and they'll they'll shoot off a couple
lines but that doesn't really explain
anything to the other side if you list
10 things that sounds like you're going
to be busy it's believed and put through
so having something like that set in
place where it encourages them to do the
work with the tenant in there or
um sets parameters to where
they have to actually be doing the work
required to have a tenant move out is
very needed because of the rampant
misuse of this eviction procedure thank
you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
um representative uh Kathy Staub please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee I know it's
been a long day and I truly appreciate
the fact that you're still here to hear
my testimony
um I um
um
you've heard a lot of bills today and
almost all of them have been focused on
trying to keep people in their homes
and you know maintaining a Workforce for
businesses and the quality of life for
New Hampshire residents is is really
important it's it's why we're here and
what we have is a systemic housing
problem and the problem keeps shifting I
signed on to this bill because I am very
concerned about the issues of renovation
which Ms margison just told you about
but I'm going to focus I was not
um I am not a law student and I wasn't
really involved in writing this bill but
so I'm going to focus on the problem
that this legislation will help to solve
the issue is that there are renters who
have never missed a payment they can be
invicted by the owner if they plan to
renovate a unit
um this bill would give people a 60-day
notice that is nowhere near enough time
for the people who are being displaced
to find another place to live so you're
creating a homelessness issue there
um and there are it is a significant
number of people who are being displaced
by these renovation evictions this bill
would help Define the parameters of a
renovation project that would warrant an
eviction as Ms margeson just told you
sometimes they just sweet they didn't
even have time to sweep the floors
before they put somebody in there after
they evicted somebody claiming that they
were going to renovate the property
um obviously we want a landlords to
maintain their properties but there
needs to be a balance and um you know I
I do know very some very good landlords
the good landlords will wait till uh uh
a unit is empty and then they will go in
and then they will do the necessary
Renovations and then they'll turn it and
around and rent it out again and that's
I really truly admire that
um but generally what has been happening
is that people have been in their home
for a number of years and the property
is sold the new owner wants to upgrade
the unit or just significantly increase
the rent and longtime tenants who've
lived in a unit for 20 or 30 years often
older people on fixed incomes they've
never missed the rent payment they find
themselves being evicted and there is no
place for them to go
um this happens in individual rental
properties and in large complexes one
thing that we obviously
um that will we need to watch out for is
that
um if you're old like me you remember
when there were incentives to build
Workforce housing and so developers were
given incentives to build these
properties with the agreement that they
would keep them affordable for a certain
length of time and what happens is that
that expires and then the property is
sold to a new owner and they're not
they're not obligated to maintain any of
that affordability or you know to take
Section 8 vouchers as the previous owner
was was doing this happened in a large
development in Manchester I know that
there was a development in Concord where
this happened and there was one up in
Lebanon where the
um where they were able to the local
Housing Authority was able to buy the
the building and keep people in these
affordable units but um you know there
there's the potential of thousands of
people who could get
evicted from their
um their affordable properties these
low-income developments Workforce
housing and put out on the street with
no place for them to go and I think that
that's the critical thing about this is
that there is no place for people to go
when they get evicted you know as policy
makers
I think we can use our the power of
legislation to help mitigate the impacts
of these things on our constituents and
I think that you know looking at
looking at this situation and it's it's
a systemic problem that we have in the
state of New Hampshire and I really
appreciate the fact that you have spent
the whole day listening to the various
aspects of this problem and how it is
impacting
um our constituents
um and I hope that um you will look at
ways to help keep people in their homes
and um and I appreciate your listening
to me and I'm happy to take any
questions from anyone questions for this
Witness
thank you very much thank you uh Matt
bacon please
foreign
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee
um my name is Matt bacon I'm a real
estate agent with SBN masiello group in
Bedford I'm also a member of the New
Hampshire Association and the commercial
investment board of realtors public
policy committees and I'm here today
representing the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors
we're opposed to House Bill 401 although
we do understand the reason for which it
was crafted and that the sponsors put
this forward and we sympathize with them
it appears that this legislation was
crafted to deal with the current and
very real housing shortage that we're
facing across the state vacancy rates in
most communities are currently around or
a one percent or less at this time so
finding an apartment is an enormous
challenge which causes significant
strain on families worklers and the
overall economy
as you consider the bill I want to make
a few things clear first any tenant with
a signed lease whatever the term may be
cannot be evicted during that time frame
stipulated and Lease even if it's for a
repair or renovation or if the landlord
wants to take the unit off the market so
if you have a contract both the landlord
and tenant must adhere to those terms
and those terms are willingly agreed to
by the two parties evidenced by signing
a lease the tenant is clearly aware of
the length of that lease and no
guarantees are made beyond that date
second if a tenant is on a
month-to-month basis that means either
the tenant or the landlord may give the
other 30 days notice to end the lease
many tenants find the ability to leave
their tenancy quickly without a penalty
to be desirable House Bill 401 extends
the notice period to 60 days I believe
that 60 days would be the longest notice
imposed by any New England State
at the very least the same time frame
should be mandated on the tenant to
notify the landlord prior to leaving in
a month-to-month Arrangement effectively
changing it to a buy month to buy a
month tenancy and misaligning it with
other statutes already in place which
already have a 30-day standard in our
current law
keep in mind currently a landlord must
provide a 30-day notice to evict the
court hearing is another 30 days
typically so we effectively have 60 days
of procedure already in place judges are
then permitted and routinely do allow
tenants to stay an additional 30 to 90
days
So currently tenants often receive
anywhere from 90 to 150 days from
initial notice until they need to vacate
an argument that there are no existing
statutory protections for tenants is not
accurate evictions are not inexpensive
for a landlord I'm not a lawyer but the
legislation appears to place further
burden on the landlord to demonstrate to
a court that the repairs are necessary
most tenants fail to pay the rent owed
to a landlord once evicted and I was
just quoted 1500 for an easy eviction by
an attorney merely for the legal fees
add to that the utility costs the unpaid
rents and damages often left behind and
my average eviction has cost me
personally over six thousand dollars in
my units only only a few owning only a
few units that means that my rental
profits for the entire year are eaten up
by just one eviction but I still have to
pay the bank interest on the mortgage so
they're often the only ones profiting
from my real estate investment holding
if a tenant under existing statute
wishes to contest the repair they
certainly have that ability and a judge
could then seek additional information
from the landlord if warranted under
this bill I would be required to submit
specific evidence to the nature cost and
time frame even if there's no dispute as
to the rationale that repairs are needed
in the new language on 542 B it states I
will need to provide a sworn affidavit
from the owner stating that the dwelling
unit will remain off the market for not
less than one year but if I sell the
property with one within one year and
the new owner makes it available for
residential purposes this seems to
indicate that I would still be liable
even though I don't own the property
currently additionally I don't see where
there's a statutory definition of remove
the dwelling unit from the residential
rental market in state statute
you're kind of going over your uh time
uh so can I just ask you to sort of sum
up sure
um so large layer scale landlords will
probably have fewer issues with this
bill than small landlords such as myself
um we need more apartments in the state
and additional new governmental
regulations may cause some deceased
renting and we feel that that would hurt
everyone and we feel that the real issue
here is that there's a lack of housing
not a lack of protection for tenants
from being evicted for necessary repairs
all right thank you uh questions for
this witness what representative
Alexander thank you so um if I heard you
correctly would you say the housing
crisis is more of a supply side issue
and not a regulation issue yes
absolutely
other questions for this witness
representative Oregon
hope it's okay to ask you a question I
am a co-sponsor of the bill but
something I'm wondering about let's say
let's say I do buy an empty uh
multi-family rental property uh you know
wishing to increase the supply of
Housing and possibly profit hopefully
more than six thousand dollars a year
for the whole building but um how do I
so how how do I how do I protect myself
from
what steps can I take to make sure that
this uh building wasn't taken off the
market in order to to pick the uh
tenants within that time frame with the
short of what I have to go down to the
courthouse and look through all the
evictions to see if people have been
evicted that address or is there some
easier way to to find out like is this
something that I could reasonably expect
the seller to inform me of along with
as I assumed there's always I'd have to
ask about any other gasolines or
obligations on the building so is that
something I
should probably expect myself to ask him
about him or her about it when I buy the
property
so I I don't know that there are any
statutory describe requirements for any
disclosure related to this in place I
know that there are required disclosures
which sometimes aren't observed
um and uh personally dealt with one of
those in a building that had in
um insufficient electrical service that
when if someone someone had used the six
month stay
um like let's say The Last Tenant out
the door I would have had four vacant
units and they would have been in a
construction zone if we move forward
with the others and they would have had
very unsafe electrical conditions uh
persisting for those six months so that
it creates other challenges and I don't
know how to protect against that
um because once title has transferred um
a real estate attorney told me on that
we had no recourse we would have had to
found the lack of disclosure prior to
the date of closing and once the date of
closing had passed we had no more
recourse remaining
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Andrus
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question are there any figures
available as to what type of housing is
needed in New Hampshire is it
departments it is the individual housing
is it low-income housing uh I'm just
trying to wrap my head around it all so
actually uh there's a wealth of
information put out largely by New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
they're the quasi-governmental agency
that distributes a substantial amount of
housing data that is backed by
substantial resource and they receive
the federal funds to then distribute
through the litec program the low income
low-income housing tax credit program
among many others they also administer
the federal funds for Section 8 housing
Choice vouchers so they are a wealth of
that information and they're very
helpful so if you go to the
nhhfa.org website you'll be able to find
some excellent statistics and they break
out the type of housing needed as well
as some of the challenges faced largely
by local zoning and planning ports that
are restrict in the type of housing that
we do need and the density that could be
available there
other questions for this Witness
see none thank you very much sir
Brendan Lemay
all right my name is Brandon Lemay and I
am speaking in favor of Bill uh House
Bill 401
um and I just want to state right off
the bat here when we talk about we View
housing as a supply issue or a tenants
rights issue I like to say that it's
both and I want to say that we need more
Supply but also I think that tenants do
need more rights in this current market
I like to say that the lack of Supply
exacerbates the lack of tenant rights
that exist so I want to say yes and to
that question of whether or not it's a
supply issue
um so a big reason why I'm speaking in
favor today is again I work uh with many
lone moderate income tenants and most
commonly the most common form of
eviction that our membership deals with
is renovation and it is because this is
a loophole around our just cause
eviction laws we have had landlords in
this room admit a public record that
they use renovation evictions when they
can't find another type of eviction to
remove a tenant from
so I feel that with the ease of an
eviction that can come with a renovation
eviction given this Market here we need
these protections for the tenants in
place
um and finally I do have one problem
because I feel like there's one section
in the bill that could possibly cause a
supply issue and that is line 28. it
says that the dwelling has to be off the
market for 12 months I think that's a
little too long I'm going to admit
you're you're not going to hear me say
that when it comes to giving more rice
to tenants but I do feel like this could
adversely affect the supply so I would
probably recommend either a shorter time
possibly six months or even a time
that's estimated that the renovations
would take because we have seen cases
where somebody has been evicted for
renovation the landlord did a new
countertop and within 30 days somebody
else was in there it was a renovation
that the tenant could have stayed in for
uh so I just want to make sure that when
a tenant is being evicted for
renovations that an actual renovation is
happening and it's not just being used
to style the side step a just cause
eviction that we have
and uh that's it I'll take any questions
for this week
thank you very much sir thank you uh
Nick Norman
thank you again Mr chairman
so much has been said
so a couple points there's a thought
about 60 days notice
but you must remember that tenants are
only required to give a 30-day notice
so think about it for just a quick
minute
what's on the market is tenants giving
30-day notices
so what use is it for a person getting
60 days notice looking at things on the
market which are not on the market yet
because they haven't given notice
because they're giving a 30-day notice
it creates a false sense of
decreased supply
so it actually exacerbates the problem
it's going to force more people
looking for housing that doesn't yet
exist
showing a higher demand which is going
to push the rents higher
so that that's just one point in this I
want to reiterate that if we're looking
to
solve something related to the housing
shortage and ease the shortage
and you're not looking at creating more
housing then you were looking in the
wrong place
we need to create more housing
pure and simple and that will solve all
of these issues
it's hard to know how long the
renovation is going to take we have a
lot of supply chain issues these days
especially with the pandemic
and when you have an eviction which
already takes at least two months but in
this case 30 days so add 21 days to that
and then you add 30 more days to that
it's a long time that you can have
uh the apartment not producing money
the tenant can easily not be paying rent
and then the landlord goes through that
longer and longer eviction process
and then all that money has to be made
up that's again pressure on increasing
rents
I do want to say that
we don't Advocate to landlords to use a
renovation eviction as a means of
getting rid of a tenant
there are situations where
you may be faced with a decision of
living with a Troublesome tenant
or actually doing a renovation
and it makes sense as a business
proposition for a property owner in some
cases to do a renovation to
significantly increase the value of that
apartment
and then get a higher rent it's a good
business proposal
and
I personally think it's a shame that we
should be setting up a system that
incentivizes property owners into doing
renovations that will further increase
the rents and make the situation even
worse
I do know a very rare few cases where a
landlord has chosen that option and they
actually do the renovation they do a
significant renovation and of course
they have a much higher rent and you
know what consequently they have less
Troublesome tenants usually
and so you know
right this the there's there's a lot
more to say
um but I know that you're short on time
um there is
I guess I guess I'll stop with that
there's a lot more to say and I would be
really happy to take questions all right
questions for for this Witness
saying none thank you very much Mr
Norman uh David Klein please
my name is David Klein and I promise you
this will be the last time you'll hear
from me today
I want to go home too
um I am against the bill because I have
problems with it
um starting out with describe the
specificity that the work what work is
going to be done I don't mind giving
that but understand every time we go
into some of these projects they expand
on us we always find something else
wrong and it's more work and we can't
put it all down and I don't want to be
locked into that
but I have more problems with the proof
that I have to give in order to evict a
tenant one the work cannot be done
safely that's not a real clear term
because safely varies from situation to
situation you have young children but
they're going to be splinters when you
pull a window out is that safe for the
child or not it's very subjective it's
very difficult to to work with that
work being more than 30 days does that
mean that you can't get the contractor
in for 30 days or does the contract
actually physically in the apartment for
30 days 30 days of people working in
that apartment is a lot of work we're
supposed to tear these things down to
the studs resheet rocket and then put up
all new fixtures it it's not a clear
term it's not a fair term
than the one that really gets me is
having to find a unit with a similar
rent
first of all what happens if the tenant
doesn't like the unit you don't you find
second where does that unit have to be
can I get one in Alabama for this tenant
or does it have to be in the same city
or same state nothing is specified on
this it's very ambiguous it's and
would you like someone else finding a
house for you or an apartment for you
don't you want tenants to find their own
and find something they're happy with I
think it's these these qualifications
are just ridiculous should not be put
through and
um I'm going to ask that you do not go
through this bill I also agree that that
on the taking off the market why do we
want to incentivize people to keep
Apartments when we're short of
apartments off the market for a year
that's way too long
business reasons maybe you empty the
building because the new owner wants it
emptied and the new owner wants to take
it over within six months and which is
not an absurd amount of time for a
purchasing sale of a small building a
year is way too long you're going to
keep these four units off the market
that that provision is uh
unacceptable to me
and I also finally the six-month rule
um
it's not easy to line up contractors
today
you're telling a contract well you might
be able to start in six months maybe
eight or nine once I get this tenant out
the contract is going to say call me
when you've got it empty and I'll get to
you when I can that means that unit's
going to be off the market even longer
because you never know when those
contractors are going to be available
and If and for those of you who don't
have property try and get a plumber
for long term
there are shortage of plumbers shortage
of electricians shortage of Carpenters
what do you think the cost of
construction is so high and the cost of
building more housing is so high so
that that's too long you got to bring it
back I think the existing law with the
90 days plus all the time it takes to
get through the eviction which is
another another 30 to 60 days minimum is
more than adequate for protection for
the tenants thank you for listening to
me and I'll take any questions questions
for this witness representative Morgan
um
this is a basically the same question I
asked Mr bacon from the Realtors but
you're an attorney and you flank things
pretty clearly so hopefully I can ask
you clearly
um what let's say let's say I'm in the
situation where I buy you know a
renovated building that the uh you know
the previous owner assures me it's been
empty for 12 months and um
so then I buy it and then the previous
Tenors tenants could theoretically then
hit somebody up for ten thousand dollars
um ten thousand dollars uh each if what
I was told wasn't true so how do I
protect myself do is it do I
do I have to sue the previous owner or
should I or during what I'm doing the
sale should I try to get an insurance an
affidavit from the buyer or do I even or
is it possible for me to even go down to
the courthouse maybe and check to see if
there's been any evictions at that
addressed during um the last year or so
so how do I
how do uh buyers protect themselves in
that situation I'm gonna Back start off
with the courthouse
if you give notice to get out and the
tenant moves out voluntarily without
going through the eviction process then
there will be nothing in the courthouse
so that would not help unless there's an
eviction file because the tenant did not
get out
I would get an affidavit from the seller
that similar to the affidavits we see
with title insurance that there are no
encroachments with no tenants tennis and
possession of unrecorded leases of that
type of nature uh to protect yourself
and then you can sue based on fraud
or something along that lines that would
be my suggestion but I would do it at
the time in the sale with the purchase
and sale agreement okay good thanks that
sounds good to me thank you all right
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much sir
thank you and uh Sophia Hyatt
hi again hi uh so as I said earlier I'm
a housing lawyer at New Hampshire legal
assistants I'm handing around letters
from uh the owner of Stewart Property
Management which is a for-profit
landlord who supports this bill I
believe they also submitted that online
um I just want to start by clarifying
some misinformation about the law that
has been provided during testimony so
one thing that someone said earlier was
that people can't be evicted for
renovations during a lease term that is
absolutely not true people are
constantly evicted during lease terms
for renovations that's the whole reason
why landlords use this as a loophole
because they don't have to prove
anything at this point a judge can ask
questions but they have no requirement
to ask questions about what the
renovation is what the nature of the
plan is
in 2022 compared to 2021 at New
Hampshire legal assistance we had a 43
increase in intakes for evictions for
renovation from 2022 to to 2021
and we weren't able to help 17 of the
people that that came to us for help
because we just don't have capacity
which should hopefully show you that
there's just not enough resources in the
state to deal with this problem
um right now I think I forget which rep
asked earlier and I apologize but
someone said why do we need this right
now the reason that we need this is
because rental housing is extremely hard
to find and it's very unfortunate but
landlords are using this the fact that
you can evict to renovate as a loophole
and it's a trend that we have seen
through our numbers changing increasing
in these types of ink intakes it's
trending it's becoming more commonly
known about and it's become becoming
more commonly abused uh representative
Lynn said earlier when he was speaking
about his bill that it we should be
looking out for bills sorry laws that
landlords can manipulate and we don't
want people doing that well I'm we're
all talking to you or those of us who
support this bill are talking to you
about Allah right now that doesn't exist
that allows landlords to manipulate the
law and kick people out in the middle of
a lease term and not renovate so you've
heard a lot of people talk about
legitimate Renovations I'm now going to
tell you about clients that couldn't be
here today because it's too expensive to
get a cab here who have been evicted for
renovations and whose landlords don't
actually renovate the property one
gentleman who was living in Exeter and
was evicted four Renovations had always
paid his rent on time his name is tilo
scheller he wanted to be here but he
couldn't make it he lived in his
apartment for five years paid rent every
month on time landlord gave an eviction
for renovations we came to an agreement
he moved out three days later the
apartments on Craigslist having just
been painted and this eviction type of
eviction is only supposed to be done for
substantial renovation that can't happen
when the tenants living there so
codifying this at law would make it so
that the court every single judge would
ask the questions about what are you
doing for this renovation right now they
don't have to and the courts are very
overburdened so they're getting through
cases as quickly as possible when we go
on a Wednesday to Manchester District
Court or a Thursday rather now there
will be 15 cases scheduled at 8 45 a.m
and they're all landlord-tenant
evictions they're not all get getting
the time to have these questions asked
and if these were required to be asked
by the court then the court would ask
them and I don't think that we should
expect that each judge would
individually put it upon themselves to
inquire about things that aren't really
required of them to be asked
um
this the bill only applies to restricted
housing it's not applying to the
mom-and-pop landlords it's not applying
to any Renovations that are required to
address code violations or affecting the
lead laws evictions you were given an
eviction notice and I'm sorry I'm
rushing I just know it's the end of the
day and I really want to make this call
clear earlier today during
representative Lynn's bill you were
handed out a copy of a blank eviction
notice I would love for you to take a
look at that and get familiar with it
because I would assume that many people
sitting up here do not rent apartments
um I rent an apartment but I had not
seen an eviction notice but like till I
became a housing lawyer so look at it
get familiar with it it's very clear
when you look at that document that
there's so many different ways that a
landlord can evict a tenant during a
lease term that's what we're talking
about we're not talking about the end of
a lease during a lease term if they
materially violate the lease they can
evict with 30 days notice if there's a
behavior that is adversely affecting
health or safety they can give a seven
day notice for an eviction if they stop
paying rent during a discretionary stay
they would be kicked out the sixth
period six month period of discretionary
stay extending it from three months to
six months the tenant has to pay that
entire time and if they don't they will
be kicked out and the same thing would
happen
um in terms of and at any time during a
lease or during a stay or anything like
that this doesn't foreclose on the
landlord's ability to file an eviction
for any of those other very legitimate
reasons and the law exists for a reason
I have a client right now who's disabled
whose landlord is doing very legitimate
Renovations and we've been working with
them so that the client who needs
Supportive Housing and so the landlord
has been very accommodating they've
worked with us they've given him plenty
of time I think the letter I handed out
from Stewart Property Management says
that they usually take about six to nine
months to figure out what units they're
going to renovate get the contractors
someone was just saying how hard it is
to get a plumber or something you know
I've needed one in my apartment for like
a month and a half and I have a great
landlord and it's just scheduling right
so if you're going to renovate your
property you probably know more than 30
days in advance and so all we're asking
is for people to give 60 days notice
again that just means I want to renovate
in 60 days so please leave then and if
you do 2 then I won't file an eviction
so you everybody keeps talking about how
they get all this extra time in the
court process if your goal is to have
tenants avoid going through the court
process then give them more time so that
they have more time to look for an
apartment and then if that's not enough
they the judge would be able to give
them up to six months of a discretionary
stay and again the court process takes
as long as the court process takes
that's not what we're talking about
right now we're talking about the timing
of when an eviction notice expires and
again it just I just want to reiterate
that this is a trend that's happening
that you know you I think have a
responsibility to look at the laws that
are put in front of you and how you're
hearing from all of us or for many of us
that they're being manipulated you can
read articles about it in the paper so
I'm asking you to please do something
about that so tenants can have more time
when they've done nothing wrong and
don't want to have to go through an
eviction or if they do have to go
through an eviction give them more time
to find a place and one more point of
clarification then I'll stop is that the
landlord does not have to find a new
apartment for the tenant there's
absolutely no requirement for that it
says that
um line 15 says that the tenant has been
offered a dwelling unit within the same
with the same number of bedrooms
um from which they're being evicted uh
sorry line 17 says this provision shall
not apply if no such unit is available
what that's talking about is if you have
a multi-unit property and there's a
vacant unit and the tenants unit is the
one that's going to be renovated we're
saying if there's a vacant unit offer
the vacant unit to the tenant because
right now that's not required so that's
that's what that's addressing all right
questions for this win
we'd be happy to amend it since that's
not what it says representative yeah
that that's what I was going to say yeah
that one provision the part about about
having to offer another unit seems
fairly open-ended in terms of the
obligation that it's putting on the on
the so I didn't know whether that was
something that could be amended yeah and
I think that's the thing we're very
happy to clarify things the idea behind
that is we're trying to use this to deal
with protectual evictions that aren't
really about renovation so the evictions
I talked about like tilo sheller who his
landlord evicted him and then didn't
renovate the property the idea would be
that if it's really about renovating
that specific unit and you have an empty
unit offer that unit to your tenant if
this is not about anything other than
renovation I think that that's just a
logical way of doing it
um so that we're happy to amend things
we're happy to talk it through but
please think about doing this other
questions for this witness so I guess I
I'm I really I mean you I really want to
make sure that I'm understanding
something are you saying that if I'm a
landlord and I enter into a one-year
lease with you and the lease agreement
doesn't say anything about I can evict
you because I want to renovate at the
six-month term that the law allows you
to allows me to break the contract
correct it constitutes other good cause
so so
has that actually been decided by the
Supreme the Supreme Court has said or a
trial court has said you can use this
provision to break a lease yes
I guess we'll know I really want to take
my name and reputation can you give us
some of those right now you know what
can you give us the cases that say
because I'm just amazed at that there's
not a specific case to my knowledge but
the law does say that if it's a
legitimate business or economic reason
and I believe it's section two and I
have my book right but I guess what I'm
really sorry I mean I understand that
but doesn't that that that would allow
you to to invoke the landlord tenant
process but if you but you I'm I would
be amazed if you can use the landlord
tenant process to break a contract
think about if there's a material lease
violation right so or if there's
behavior that affects the health their
safety of another tenant right so that's
not probably in the least some specific
random behavior that affects the health
or safety the every single thing can't
be contemplated in a contract would you
agree with that I mean there's going to
be things that the tenant like the guy
who's leaving random harassing
voicemails for example if that's not in
the lease that specific thing there are
steps that can be taken that you can
file an eviction notice and you specify
the behavior I'm just using this as an
example not everything's contemplated no
but I understand I would love for you to
come to Manchester tomorrow and see it
because but I guess you I'm not making
this up no I'm not saying I guess what
I'm really I'm not suggesting that
you're making something up but I guess
the thing I'm having real difficulty
with is the other examples you gave the
tenant is being disruptive other I mean
it seems to me that those it's easy to
understand why you are not being
um you're not you're not carrying out
your responsibilities as a tenant right
and I guess I could even see if a
landlord would say look if I don't you
know if I don't fix if I don't make a
renovation that
somehow fixes the electrical system in
your unit it's going to put the whole
place in in danger I could understand
saying that's a basis to to break the
lease but if the landlord just says I
want to you know I want to upgrade the
property during at six months so I can
get more money that's the grounds for
breaking at least I I would really have
to see a case that says that's okay
unfortunately there's not a case and
that's why we're here trying to change
the law at the legislature so I think if
you're outraged by that I would really
encourage you to talk to us during the
executive session so we can talk more
because there's not case law and
oftentimes there's not case law to
support a practice that's happening well
so let me just ask you this would it
would it satisfy you then to the extent
that we're talking about the would it
satisfy you if we amended this bill to
say the amended the appropriate section
of the statute to say
renovation
uh
renovation but not during the lease term
is okay I think that that would sort of
invoke me having to give a position on
117 and I don't know that and I'm not
trying to be disrespectful I just I
don't know that it's that simple but
what I do know is you know I've only
been doing this for a couple of years
and I think last year I testified that I
had like five cases in six months for
renovation like I just said we've had a
43 in increase between 2022 and 2021 for
this so I'm talking about this Based on
data from our non-profit organization
and we we keep lots of data because we
get government government money so I
promise we have good data
um you know I understand that it seems
ridiculous and that's why we're sitting
here trying to change it so
unfortunately I can't point to a case
but I can point to the reality and I I
mean as some have you or other people
from legal assistance made the argument
to a judge you can't you can't allow
this renovation to be made during the
the middle of the term yeah so I mean
yes and the response is this is a
business economic reason and it's a
renovation that cannot be done while the
person's in the property I believe it's
5 40 section two
um and I don't know I can look through
and find it but we could also chat after
but you know this is a very very very
common practice and I think it was said
earlier that it needs to be a practice
you know by these landlords so that they
can get people out when it's a problem
and yes you know we're not saying that
that's always what happens but it's what
happens sometimes and it only takes one
person being evicted like tilo sheller
and the many other clients that I have
worked with who weren't comfortable
having me share their names uh but I
really urge you to think about this
you've welcome to ask us questions you
know come to a clinic with us if you
really want to see this in action come
see how many cases there are come see
how often renovation is used as a
loophole and how regularly uh it is it
is allowed through as a good cause of
action and yes the Court can give a
discretionary shave up to 90 days I
would say what I've observed and again
I'm one person who's had limited
experience it is more accommodated about
a 30-day stay
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you so much
all right
we we've managed to get through it
um any is there anyone else who wishes
to testify on House Bill 401.
seeing none I'm going to uh close the
hearing on that that's the last hearing
we have I want to thank not only my
colleagues on the committee but or all
of you in the audience who have been
here for multiple times for for uh
for your testimony and it's certainly
been helpful to us as we deliberate on
what to do with these bills so thank you
I'll see you
guys tomorrow
tomorrow
wow